order a lodge
thank you
the public order emergency commission is
now in session like a message
good morning bonjour good morning
okay
I gather we have a new witness
okay but I think we're ready to go ahead
then go ahead we are how the commission
calls the former Chief Peter slowly
foreign
sir will you swear in a religious
document or do you wish to affirm
religious document please we have the
Bible the Quran or the Torah available
I'll take the Bible please thank you
foreign
thank you
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out Peter John Michael
slowly
s-l-o-l-y
do you swear that the evidence to be
given by you to this commission shall be
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth to help you God I do so
swear
foreign
thank you
good morning commissioner good morning
sir okay go ahead it's Franco senior
senior counsel for the commission
morning Frank good morning uh Mr slowly
you were the chief of the Ottawa Police
Service
between 2019 until mid-February 2022.
that's correct sir
you served also at the Toronto police
service for 28 years
that's correct well just 27 and change
but thank you you Rose through the ranks
from being a constable in 1988
to deputy chief in 2009 that's correct
you left the service in 2016. isn't it
and then you spent some time in uh in in
private sector that's correct
now I understand that when you first
join the Toronto Police Service there
were relatively few members who had a
University degree who were new recruits
yeah that's correct but you had a ba in
sociology from McMaster University
that's correct and later you got an MBA
from York University yes I did
now you were trained in the incident
command system yes I was
and tell us more about your training
I received uh incident command system
training from 100 to 400 levels
um I received additional training here
in Ottawa I consider it 500 level
essentially it's a District Operations
Commander which allows you to command a
multi-site major incident over a
protracted period of time so I had
designations up to I don't know if it's
the right terminology but a 500 level
and I had practical experience at every
one of those levels in terms of being
part of incident command so either being
an Incident Commander what is now known
as an event Commander major event
Commander a major Incident Commander
through to a District Operations
Commander mostly in my time in the
Toronto Police Service and also during
my two tours of Duty in in the United
Nations peacekeeping admission
now you also had training and experience
with the public order units that's
correct sir tell us about that again I
received a public order unit training
both through the Toronto Police Service
um
it's a little bit fuzzy now because this
is going back to the early 2000s but
there was also a provincial standard
training course that took place uh out
in a rural community that I can't
remember and then there was National
Training sessions that we did from
British Columbia across the country
you also mentioned just earlier that you
spent some time on the United Nations
peacekeeping Mission yes tell us about
that I was fortunate enough to be
selected by then Chief fantino to
represent the Toronto Police Service
think at that time I was the first
senior officer from a Municipal Police
Service to be part of a un peacekeeping
mission that had been organized through
the RCMP I was deployed to Pristina in
August of 20 of 2001 and completed two
tours coming back home in 2002. I was a
Canadian contingent Commander this was a
mission with where the police of
jurisdiction actually had full powers of
of policing including use of force
detention while building up a local
Kosovo Police Service it was also during
9-1-1 and a very significant and
complicated in volatile Zone
when you attended an interview with us
and my commissioned colleagues you
described that experience as the best
professional and personal experience
you've ever had why was that
I just tested and stressed and and
challenged and grew me and literally
every single way possible physically
mentally emotionally I'm a very
spiritual person
it allowed me to see parts of the world
I don't think I'll ever get back to see
again and to be involved in a unique
challenging and often tragic set of
circumstances but one that opened my
eyes to the conditions globally I had a
chance to work with 53 different police
services from around the world and so
that was also an opportunity to learn
The Good The Bad and The indifferent of
of progressive policing at the turn of
the century if I could just interrupt
briefly this is being translated and
there's sign language and you're a
little bit fast on the output if you
could try and thank you sir probably a
little bit of nervous energy in there
but thank you I will try to slow down
that's quite understandable
now speaking of interviews uh you
attended four interviews with me and my
commissioned colleagues between August
and early October you're a very generous
uh with us uh with your time and after
those interviews we summarize the
contents of those interviews and you've
had an opportunity to review uh the
summary is that correct yes sir I want
to show you uh a copy on the screen the
final version of the summary is WTS
six zeros four zero
now is this the the version that you
approved I trusted it sir okay uh is
there any correction that you'd like to
make to this summary no thank you so
this will be uh adopted and uh be an
exhibit
um
now
um the reason
that we're here today are the events in
January and February of this year
leading to the invocation of the
emergencies Act
um as the chief of police in Ottawa at
that time you have your unique uniquely
positioned to give us
um a perspective and to help us
understand but to really understand I
think we need to go back further to when
you started with the Ottawa Police
Service
um
tell us about
um the circumstances of the automobile
service in which you found yourself
well when I was being recruited for the
position it was very clear to me through
the recruiter on behalf of the board
that through their consultative process
with service members and community
members at the Ottawa Police Service
needed to be significantly changed
operationally administratively from an
HR standpoint the usual sort of change
processes that large organizations
require on a regular basis but very
specifically culturally internally there
was a culture
um
that was less welcoming less inclusive
less diverse less equitable and that had
impacts on things like workplace
harassment uh member of morale
externally that translated into a real
or perceived
um level of trust in the broader
Community but specifically in racialized
and marginalized communities that the
service wasn't
in some cases appropriate enough and
that there was a declining level of
trust and confidence
any one of those things would have been
a major change agenda for any external
Chief coming in all of those combined
required a significant effort of change
management and change leadership that I
was asked on behalf of the board as the
incoming Chief to deliver over the
course of my five-year contract
if I could call up your CV the document
ID number is com
50759
we can go to page two
down
so
you see under Ottawa Police Service
2019-2022 we talked about how you were
given a major culture organization
change mandate and that's something you
just outlined for us tell us about some
of the challenges you face once you took
uh the the post
um
I'm not sure the commission has all the
time in the world for that list but um I
mean I think the most simple thing to
say is any any effort of change is going
to be difficult particularly in a large
organization in this case I believe the
Ottawa Police Service is over a century
old
um
and and these were long-standing
structural deficit issues uh needed
investment in recruiting uh through
staff development training leadership
development in particular was was
something that repeatedly our membership
identified an external external uh
Auditors identified
um and those things just don't I thought
that's not a light switch you can turn
on and off it's something that you have
to build and grow and almost organically
move through the organization
operationally while they were excellent
in some ways I just want to be clear
commissioner the Ottawa Police Service
and one of the reasons why I came here
had a reputation deservedly so of one
being one of the best operational Police
Services we've heard about their
expertise in planning their ability
through missing persons investigations
was Second To None they had really
advanced in some cases Advanced HR
systems that were to be to be seen as as
a best practice so this is not a deficit
across the board but there were
significant deficits in very specific
areas that was contributing to some of
the cultural and morale issues
my attempt in the first three months was
really to go around on a listening
process in small groups large groups
internally and externally to identify
those areas bring a command team that
was even in the early days a struggle
there was significant challenges at the
command team level but people were
leaning in and doing their best I would
say though that the challenges really
came in in March of 2020. three
significant events the suspension of one
of my two Deputy Chiefs
um the culmination of a significant
internal criminal corruption
investigation where three of my officers
were arrested after an extensive uh
joint RCMP Ottawa Police Service
investigation
and of course the Declaration of the
global pandemic
two months later the death and murder of
George Floyd
the black lives movement and the defund
movement
I think that signaled the start not just
here in Ottawa but across police
services in North America I suggest
around the world as a significant change
in the level of public trust and
confidence in policing and the broader
justice system
um it certainly had material impacts in
police services here in Ottawa the
defund movement put significant pressure
on our board and our Council to adjust
the policing budget in regards to size
and to change Police Service delivery in
terms of integration
and these were real challenges on top of
the insignificant the significant
challenge of a change mandate that the
board had explicitly and expressly given
to me as the incoming chief
now you identified a few challenges that
are not unique to the Ottawa Police
Service such as the pandemic such as the
that defund movement and so on what
about within the the organization you
talked about earlier challenges
involving the command team tell us more
about that
well the command structure I believe to
this day but I might be wrong
um is the chief of police two Deputy
Chiefs and a chief Administration
officer
um
within my first three months in the
position I lost one of those Deputy
Chiefs to a suspension
that then required me to
um accelerate a succession plan that
truly wasn't ready for acceleration and
bring in a series of three-month
assignments to the rank of the
superintendent
um I had two very experienced senior
officers at that time both
superintendents had a lot of experience
and so I rotated them for the first year
but within that year both of them
retired and after that the rotation went
uh further into the superintendent ranks
some were really good fits some
struggled but it was a very sub-optimal
situation
in 2021 in the early part of the year
the board made a decision to to
end the contract of my chief
Administration officer
that then required me to look at my
command level and the only person that I
could put into that position was deputy
chief Bell
so essentially for the full almost the
full year leading up to the events of
the Convoy I had one full-time deputy
chief who was in a civilian position
as a chief Administration officer and I
was rotating to for the most part two
uniform superintendents through the
deputy chief process Again full respect
to those individuals they stepped up in
some cases volunteered when I asked they
stepped up and they did their very best
in very very difficult circumstances
during probably the most difficult time
in Ottawa Police history and in policing
across Canada and so I have nothing but
praise and thanks for them but it was a
sub-optimal situation that everyone was
struggling to make the best of
now did that happen in 2021 you said
well the the suspension of deputy chief
chaswell was in 2020 the subsequent
retirements of my two more two most
senior superintendents happened over the
course of
2020 into 2021 the
um
separation of the chief Administration
officer was in early 2021 so for the
majority of 2021 that circumstance of
deputy chief Bell being in an
administrative function and two
superintendents operating in the uniform
functions was the situation that I was
managing with
so at the at the most senior executive
level you were having
rotating staff so to speak
um what impact did that have on the rest
of the organization at that time as a
cascading impact on down the way as you
move any officer from one level to the
next on a temporary position not a
permanent promotion you then affect the
next level and the next level
I remember once in Toronto someone said
every time we promote a new Chief we
have to change out seven positions below
I don't know if it's the exact
calculation but that's the ripple effect
so it not only destabilizes the
executive level it destabilizes to a
degree the other parts there are always
benefits I mean people are given stretch
opportunities they're given leadership
opportunities earlier than they maybe
normally would have and again some rise
amazingly to that others do an excellent
good job and others struggle but it does
create churn in the organization that
was already in turn based on all the
changes that were mandated by the board
and the massive external churn by the
factors such as the death of George
Floyd in the global pandemic
another factor that for me as a newcomer
to the city as an outsider chief
I think we can all remember in the early
days of the of the pandemic the lockdown
and the requirement not to meet in
public was significant one of the most
important ways that any leader can get
to know their own members and the
community or the clients that they serve
is to meet in person
so much is lost on zoom and emails and
text messages never covered as we've
seen in testimony here
but I lost that opportunity three months
into my mandate to actually sit down
with my members in the cafeteria and
have a cup of coffee with them to have
small group focus group meetings which I
did extensively in my first three months
and even when we could get together we
were massed up so we couldn't see facial
expressions and we were spaced out
across the big gymnasium so we couldn't
really communicate we had to literally
shout at each other
I think all of that unfortunately meant
that we couldn't build the level of
cohesion internally or externally during
a very critical contentious period of
time a sustained critical and
contentious period of time but we did
our best
we've heard from other witnesses that
notwithstanding the Ops excellent
reputation in the past for planning for
and responding to large-scale events the
pandemic itself has caused a lot of
changeover and depletion of expertise
tell us more about that that situation
it's actually been well articulated I
will I will only add in Mark Ford who
his father was a former beautiful police
here an excellent chief of police Mark
was an excellent leader he was one of
those first two superintendents I
brought in on rotation along with Joan
McKenna Mark actually was
the most experienced Incident Commander
and one of the most experienced critical
incident Commanders unfortunately he
retired some six or seven months before
the events that were going to be
substantially focusing on so that would
be one example of many where we had
people who had you know gone past their
pensionable time had given their their
life blood literally to the organization
and and to the the profession of
policing and had made a decision as many
Executives in many different parts of of
Civil Society did to take their
well-earned retirement and and go on
with their life with their health intact
I we celebrated his departure but he was
missing from our team and we really
needed our best people to be in the best
place as possible
now you told us earlier that you came in
uh to the Ottawa Police Service and you
were given a change mandate
how was that mandate perceived when
you're about two years into your job
well there's a there's a there's a
probably a not polite saying about
police officers I suspect it applies to
everybody there's two things that every
cop hates the way things are and change
so it was going to be difficult no
matter what nobody wanted things to
remain the way they were and everyone
was fearful of change
to varying degrees across the full human
spectrum of course
and this wasn't just a tinker around the
edge change mandate it was to go right
to the heart of the culture and to the
most difficult parts that culture the
darker part of that culture things like
systemic racism systemic misogyny
um the trust factor between police and
the broader Community but very
specifically the racialized and
marginalized and Indigenous communities
here in Ottawa and those were the most
contentious topics in policing for my
entire career going back to 1988 in
Toronto any chief of police or any
command team that took on any one of
those issues was going to be taking on a
major major challenge
taking them on in the middle of a global
pandemic in the middle of the black
lives matter movement and the defund
abolished police movements just made it
that much more complicated but it was
still necessary it still had to get done
not because it was my mandate it was
just the right thing to do for policing
it's what our members actually wanted
and it certainly is what the community
wanted
so if I take your mind back to January
early January of 2022 before the freedom
Convoy event arrives in mid-January how
would you summarize the state that the
auto Police Service was in
committed to the direction
worried and
tired
from the effort to have traveled as far
as they did
and what was the level of trust among
the different members within the service
and their trust for the leadership
I think I could answer that in any great
specificity clearly there was a range I
think I don't know which one of the
witnesses presented I think it was um
inspector beaudant from the opp that
talked about the range of crowd Dynamics
human nature is human nature so no
matter what organization you're in
you're going to get some five percent
that will adopt everything that's said
without questioning five percent that
will resist mightily anything that is
said with all sorts of questioning and
then some range in between of people
that will move if they're incentivized
or if they feel there's a sufficient
um altruistic value around it I think
those crowd Dynamics play out in any
crowd group including the group in this
room here today
now with that context uh let's talk
about the beginning of the freedom
Convoy events when did you first learn
about the freedom Convoy
my recollection sir was a February 13th
Hendon report February I'm sorry January
13th you may need to check me on dates a
little bit
um I believe that was a report that came
into my inbox
for whatever reason that day and it was
an extremely busy period we were still
dealing with a multiple death explosion
in our city that killed some five or
four or five people
um but I did have a chance to glance
through the report
certainly there was enough information
for me to know that this could be a
significant event in the near term my
recollection is that I forwarded that
email to deputies deputy chief Bell and
acting deputy chief Ferguson I
understand that there hasn't been an
email to show that but that was my
recollection
um but irregardless somewhere on or
around February 13th there was a
direction to deputy chief Bell to
commence an intelligence review of all
the circumstances around what was being
reported to be a convoy coming to our
city and to lead the over the over to
oversee the work of developing an
intelligence threat risk assessment that
would then inform acting deputy chief
Ferguson's assignment to develop the
operational plan for the event informed
by the intelligence threat risk
assessment now we've heard from the
evidence of your deputies that after you
became the chief of the Ottawa Police
Service one of your priorities was to
ensure that operations were intelligence
LED can you tell us more about why that
was important to you yeah thank you very
much
um
just to take a back little step back all
operations not just emergency
preparedness and incident command or
critical Institute but all of our
operations from traffic management order
management
crime management
um that we should be intelligence-led
information best practices
evidence-based best practices should
inform for the most part our systems our
policies our procedures our practices
and the evaluation of the outputs and
outcomes that came from that so that was
an overarching theme how it applied
within uh incident command incident
command systems emergency preparedness
was again
a weather report that says there's going
to be rain tomorrow well let's try to
validate that to a greater degree is it
going to be raining in a city this large
is it going to be raining and flooding
in one part or is it across the entire
city because that will that will then
assess the amount of resources we need
and where and the sequence of events we
need to apply
that's an analogy that's not meant as a
an actual example so intelligence LED as
much as possible understand the nature
of the context of the situation the
factors involved the nature of the
threat the risk of the threat the
likelihood of it actually taking place
and the resources necessary to mitigate
in the first instance and respond to in
at the back end and then to recover from
the recovery period which I suggested
this is still a recovery period
commissioner for the city of Ottawa and
the country of Canada
does that answer your question sir yes
uh and my next question is to what
extent were you satisfied that that was
in fact the case in at the Ops on around
January thank you um I believe in in
evidence in Chief
um uh interim Chief Bell did reference
his own views on the advancements that
we had made particularly in the previous
year and he's absolutely correct that we
made significant advancements around our
intelligence-led approach to our broader
operations crime traffic order
management order management as a subset
includes critical incident command and
incident command system we had made
significant strides in in making sure
our information section and our
intelligence section we're lined up with
our operational sections and that we had
sufficient crime analysis uh
administrative analysis to execute and
continuously improve on those processes
we did not specifically take on
intelligence-led threat risk assessments
as a very specific product our
priorities at that time were crime
traffic
order management was not at the same
level I think in 2021 we had our a very
high level of gun and Gang Related
shootings and so crime traffic was the
number one issue in the community always
is no matter what jurisdiction so those
were really our one in two priorities
and Order management was probably at the
third level because we actually had up
until that point a very good record
very good record of planning and
implementing plans and successfully
ending a range of demonstrations but we
had made progress
I did make it very explicit particularly
this one I'm not 100 sure on but
particularly around the events in mid
2020. when we started to see large
events coming into the city wet sweat
and black lives matter in in June
Justice for Abdi in the fall these are
complex volatile political
trust Factor events that were
contentious and and could have gone a
thousand different directions I was very
very strong at that point on the
intelligence threat risk assessment
driving the operational plan and in that
period I think we did make some
significant moves forward around how the
Intel tra threat assessment supported
enabled enlightened the operational
planning
right now you mentioned that the first
hand in report you read about the
freedom Convoy was on January 13th
that's my recollection sir and uh so I
take it that you read it
yes I can't say I read every single line
it was probably more of a skim through
read but but I did read it yes sir and
what was your reaction upon reading it
this is potentially going to be a
significant event and we probably need
to get some people
working on the Intel side and and
starting at least to put the framework
of a plan in place
was that why you forwarded it to the
deputies that was my recollection of
forwarding it but that's certainly why I
assigned deputy chief Bell to lead the
the overseeing of the intelligence
threat risk consensus and assigned
acting deputy chief Ferguson for the
operational plan by the way those were
their functional areas of responsibility
deputy chief belligan I think has
testified that intelligence was one of
his directorates and that the planning
section was one of the directorates that
acting Deputy Ferguson had just
inherited she had just started as the
acting deputy chief in January 2022 and
you expected the two of them to
coordinate the information or
intelligence that that the intelligence
unit received and uh incorporate that
intelligence in the planning process yes
sir
did you receive regular updates from
your deputies yes I did Sir how often
after that that the first week that
February 13th week
um
we may have raised it in discussion at I
had a regular nine o'clock command
meeting and whatever the deputies would
lead their respective areas of of uh of
command and talk about major projects
things that should come to my level
I have a general recollection that we
would have discussed it at least once or
twice during that first week period
coming into the second week the week
leading up to the weekend of January
remind myself to slow down a little bit
coming up to the week end of January
28th 29th and 30th
I recall that being almost on a daily
basis and I think towards the end of
that week or middle to the end of that
week we had my nine o'clock meeting and
then a separate command briefing on the
intelligence and planning of the uh of
around the Convoy events when you refer
to that week were you referring to the
week before the weekend arrival of the
Convoy
yes going going into that
first weekend before the weekend of the
arrival and then through that Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday right and
what did you learn as a result of these
regular briefings about the nature of
the Convoy that was about to arrive
um
my early Impressions was there was to
some degree uh some doubt as to whether
or not this was actually going to
materialize
sorry whether it was going to be going
to materialize whether this this this
series of convoys was focused I think
mainly
in the British Columbia area
um but whether or not it was actually
going to materialize
um clearly as the days went on and
Hendon reports came in
mainstream media social media started to
follow it more there was certainly a
sense that no there's there's going to
be something that comes from as far away
as St John's Newfoundland and and from
from Vancouver British Columbia
and other parts in in Ontario itself
uh the briefings that I was getting was
that
those two areas were working together
um
our intelligence group were connected in
with all of our policing partners
municipally provincially and federally
the Ottawa Police Service intersect
program had been engaged early around
information sharing intelligence
gathering operational planning uh
confliction deconfliction and
coordination all of those things were
sort of standard for any major event
that had occurred under my tenure as a
chief of police and had been well
established going back some 15 years
under previous Chiefs of police so there
was nothing out of the ordinary
certainly things from a from a process
standpoint I I saw what I expected to be
the level of communication coordination
internally communication coordination
with our key Partners in the national
capital region and even more broadly
given the national scope of what was
unfolding that we were engaged with a
range of other police services across
the country
now in that week leading up to the the
arrival of the Convoy what was your
understanding as to the duration of the
event
again all of the reports the briefings
that I was receiving through my chain of
command was that this was going to be a
weekend event
some arriving the Thursday more arriving
the Friday the bulk arriving for Planned
or or at least scheduled events on the
Saturday and the Sunday that there might
be some remnant that would stay behind
but that Remnant would be similar to
other demonstrations that had come
through where people stayed in the
nation national capital region
for a variety of reasons but in some
cases setting up small tent cities that
would at some point over the subsequent
days weeks and in some cases months
would be gradually through a measured
approach with multi-agency involvement
from NCR and the city they would be
eventually moved either to a better
location or moved back to wherever they
had originally come from
now during that period did you continue
to receive regular Hendon reports I was
on the mailing distribution so it came
into my inbox I could also see there
were other Ottawa Police Service members
on the on the distribution and by that
point I had explicitly asked and had
been told
that members within deputy chief Bell's
command and intelligence directorate
were receiving hand and reports were
involved in hand and related briefings
and that those reports were informing
the intersect discussions of threat risk
assessment did you continue to read the
Hampton reports when they landed in your
inbox not every day sir I would if I had
the ability I would again usually skim
through a document I do recall sort of
in the middle to the back end of that
week on a daily basis doing a a deeper
more full read but at that point I was
anything anything that was coming in
including emails from private citizens
about this I would try to skim read and
if there was something relevant I would
usually just forward the email over into
deputy chief Bell's command and copy in
his intelligence directorate commanders
to make sure that they had the
information that they could collate that
into their larger threat risk assessment
now you spoke about your understanding
uh during that period that it was going
to be a two-day or weekend event was
that understanding uh based on the
executive briefings that you got or a
combination of that as well as other
sources including the hand and reports
that you did receive or or read yeah the
latter the sum total of everything that
I was reading or being briefed on that
was the unbalance the assessment
and the totality of information or
intelligence that you got did not change
your view at the time that it was going
to be a two-day or weekend event that's
correct sir
um and what was the nature of your role
as the chief at that time as compared to
the two deputies who were assisting you
maybe so so let me be more specific in
terms of the collection of or the
analysis uh or the the dissemination of
the intelligence within the Ops for the
purpose of planning it responds uh what
were the respective roles of you as the
chief as compared to the two Deputy
Chiefs who were assisting you
uh every chief of police or commissioner
is accountable and responsible for
everything in the organization but I had
delegated specifically delegated those
responsibilities to the two individuals
deputy chief Bell and acting deputy
chief Ferguson to oversee and ensure
that there was an appropriate level of
threat risk assessment in forming an
appropriate level operational plan
would would it be appropriate for you to
ask questions for instance when you
received additional information
absolutely on any issue whether it was
an HR matter or a Professional Standards
investigation if at any point there was
a data point or a context issue
something that didn't seem to make sense
I would always ask a question just to
make sure that I understood the
circumstances that they were dealing
with and if appropriate I could provide
advice or direction is required and did
you direct deputy chief Bell to conduct
or have someone conduct a threat risk
assessment
that's entirely the direction that he
had that was his responsibility was that
something ordinarily done in response to
this kind of event or was that something
particular to this situation yeah just I
want to be clear about something deputy
chief Bell himself wasn't to sit down at
his desk and conduct a threat risk
assessment but through the resources and
the directorates that he oversaw to
oversee that there was an appropriate
threat risk assessment yes that was his
Direction sir
um
but uh was it uh an ordinary process for
the threat risk assessment to be
conducted in response to any major event
yes that was that was a best practice
that I had
learned and developed over the course of
my tenure in Toronto and other
areas it was something that was to some
degree already significant degree
already in place here in Ottawa but I
wanted it at the highest level possible
and I think deputy chief Ferguson acting
Deputy Ferguson gave that in her
testimony that that was a clear
expectation that I had made coming in
now we've heard from deputy chief Bell
that in this case a threat is threat
risk assessment was in fact conducted so
if I could take you to the document
Ops four zeros3073
actually this is not the threat
assessment but this is an email you
wrote uh after reading the threat
assessment I do recall having read the
threat assessment that was prepared
um
I've seen a document in disclosure that
is titled threat assessment I don't
recall receiving and reading that
document I did read the threat
assessment that was embedded in
the pre-arrival operational plan that I
received on January 28th right so now
this one this email chain uh depart
that was sent by you uh was stated
January 26th so
um and if we go
uh so you'll see that
um actually if we go down further to see
the origin of the chain
so not so not so far
do you remember receiving an email from
a concerned citizen about the potential
violence of the upcoming event and if we
scroll up
you forwarded this email to your
deputies
um and you outline the concern if we
scroll down to the next page
you describe what the concern was and
then you said yes yet our breathing note
as of last night says that there is no
intelligence to indicate that this demo
strain will be violent
and you um you issue this guidance
please review all available information
Intel incidents and ensure we have the
most accurate threat assessment and the
most appropriate operations plan for the
event now it's not entirely clear from
this email whether or not you've read a
threat assessment but you were certainly
aware that there was one
yeah what I'm referring sorry
thank you sir what I'm referring to I
believe is it just a a briefing note I
don't know what that would have been in
the form of it could have been an email
that was sent around before last night
that had that that said there was no
intelligence to indicate this was going
to be violent but it wasn't the threat
risk assessment document in any of its
versions that I was referring to I see
and and I laid out a series of I guess
it's four points here of data that had
come into my awareness over the course
of the night into the morning including
the email that I forwarded that would
suggest opposite so it was again just a
reminder
there's contradictory information just
make sure that that is incorporated into
the overall Federal risk assessment and
that is as optimal as it can be so that
the plan can be as optimal as it can be
now um so this is dated January 26th I
want to show you
um an intelligence assessment conducted
by Sergeant Chris Keyes on January 25th
and perhaps you can take a look and let
us know if you had reviewed that
document the document number is Ops
403086
in the production we receive we we've
seen a couple of different versions I
assume that this the assessment was
updated uh as the week unfolded but this
is version one
does this uh
ring any Bell this is the first time I'm
seeing the document sir okay
um if I could take you to page
five
so the third bullet the author says that
in six years of working large
demonstration events from the
intelligence point of view the writer
has never seen such widespread Community
Action which means three things for
planners first in the event the event is
likely going to be bigger in crowd size
than any demo in recent history possibly
on par with Canada Day events but more
disruptive second there was significant
popular support for this event on a
scale of not seen in recent years
this means the protest groups have
access to larger protester pools than
they have ever had access to which means
there will be like likely widespread
disorganization and confusion third
local area bandwidth for cellular mobile
devices will be impacted significantly
causing Communications issues for both
the police and the event organizers
planners should be ready to have police
radials on hand to avoid clock cellular
networks this is an example of the
intelligence unit providing relevant
intelligence to guide the planning of
the events right yes sir so it's a it's
a is an example of how it's supposed to
be done but there are suggestions here
that this event is unlike some of the
other recent events there are signals
here do you agree that it may be
unprecedented
at this point I wouldn't say
unprecedented I think he's actually
Sergeant Chris keeves is one of our best
intelligence operators I had a chance to
interact with him quite a bit when I was
at the Police Service
I think he actually uses some very
important language here that that
caveats his comments he talks about
recent years not ever and he does that
several times in here
the what he's describing is very
accurate we're seeing generally in
protests I'd suggest over the last 15
years in the age of social media a
greater level of mobilization
and increasingly the last decade a
greater level of a variety of funding
and logistical support this this email
took me back to
um uh Idol no more
um
the um oh my gosh my memory is feeling a
little bit commissioner sorry but the
Occupy Movement
um where the these sort of sentiments
crowd size crowd Dynamics Logistics
mobilization larger disaffected
populations polarized populations that
would give director indirect support
would directly protest or indirectly
protest I'm slowing myself down a little
bit here
um these were elements that we had seen
what Sergeant Chris Keyes is saying in
here my interpretation of it is that the
planners need to be where this is likely
going to be bigger than recent events he
didn't give a time frame is that two
years is that ten years
and so we need to be cognizant of it so
it's a good alarm Bell but it's not a
five alarm that he's ringing right now
it's a warning for a very healthy
trouble to a very healthy warning uh and
the last line that was voted in the last
paragraph As a result law enforcement is
being met with numbers of people beyond
the norm that's what you're saying a
larger crowd size what would you expect
your deputies to do with this kind of
warning
well the deputies would ensure that this
information is being shared amongst the
planners as was directed from an
intelligence operator over to the
planners I would I would want to know
that they had sufficient systems in
place that when a briefing note like
this was produced that it would go from
the intelligence directorate to the
planning team and that it would be again
used in real time as they were
developing the plan in real time and
these are real-time systems it's not one
first and then the other in real time
information is coming in very fluid very
fast moving very complex situation
my sense from the briefings that I was
getting was that that process was in
place and it was functioning
sufficiently would you expect your
deputies to brief up and give you the
warning
on a specific level like this no
okay
um so um let's go to another document
um now first of all let me ask you uh
the since you were reading the hand in
report do you recall if there's any
hidden report that you could identify
that would suggest that it was a weekend
event as opposed to
prolonged events involving weak or
months
um I saw head in reports that had
elements of both sir
again elements of both in the totality
of all of the Hendon reports that were
specifically prepared on the topic of
the Convoy events prior to the arrival
of the events themselves
I would literally have to go back
through them all and I think you and I
have talked about this in previous
interviews a line in one report unless
you've read the entire report can be
misleading one report unless you've read
all the reports could be misleading so
it's the totality of the information and
even then the hand in reports as
excellent as they were and commissioner
I want to be clear
I've expressed my gratitude to
commissioner Creek on multiple occasions
even after my resignation about the
quality of the intelligence support that
we receive from the opp and specifically
around the quality of the hand and
reports
but in the totality sir
I do not recall and to this day even
with the benefit of hindsight I do not
have any clear impression or saw any
clear conclusions that we were going to
have anything more than what I was being
briefed on by my team this was going to
be a Thursday Friday mainly Saturday
Sunday event with the potential for a
smaller group to remain behind but in
numbers that we had managed previously
um
let me show you uh one example
um from the January 25th hand in report
and see how you may interpret this
report opp401108
we go to page three please
go down
so do you see the section that starts
with intelligence gaps first of all what
do you understand intelligence gaps to
mean
um known unknowns
they know they need some information but
they do not have the information and
therefore can't validate the other parts
of the assessment and that there needs
to be some effort to
acquire that information and convert it
into intelligence sufficient to close
one or all of the gaps
so if we look at the first few bullets
first of all participant participant
numbers online indicators are unreliable
so this is a Known Unknown they knew
that they needed the number but they
knew that they didn't have the number is
that right that's how I interpret it sir
and then the next two bullets have
references to specific dates nature of
activities in Ottawa by Advanced Convoy
participants
January 28th January 29th
so when these days are referenced in
these reports what do you take them to
mean
that we're going to have two days of
activities that that that
they don't know what those activities
will be on those two days
that's right they don't know what may
happen on those days could we infer from
this bullet that things were only going
to happen on these two days no what
about the third bullet events possibly
scheduled at Parliament Hill on
the 30th uh of January the same right
yes sir so we know from this that the
police didn't really know what would
happen on that date but we cannot infer
from this bullet that
um these are the only dates when things
would happen you're absolutely right in
the larger context of all the
intelligence information sorry what was
the date of this report again
25th of January I'm certain that by the
25th of January we were into the cycle
of briefings where this is a three four
day event mainly the Saturday Sunday
so even at the point where these known
unknowns were being listed well we
couldn't tell you what the agenda of the
activities were going to be there would
be some activities there would be people
demonstrating in the city it would
involve some level of vehicular traffic
likely involving large trucks
um
but you're right none of the information
in these known unknowns fills in hour by
hour or block by block of time as to
what exactly we'll be taking place
right so this is during your 25th and
then on the 27th as we get closer to the
first weekend arrival you attended a
meeting with your command team as well
as the legal services if I could take
you to a document number Ops three zeros
one four five five nine
at page one please
so if we scroll down slightly do you see
the last bullet
so first of all the bullet that says
Chief questions it sounds like at this
meeting you ask some questions in the
fourth sub bullet
interdict Tow Truck Equipment prior to
it being used against us heavy equipment
within Convoy to take down barriers a
level of pre-planning we don't normally
see concern they have this for something
that is supposed to be lawful
uh is it fair to say that by this date
you had some concern uh for
given the
presence or anticipated uh presence of
the heavy equipment when it was supposed
to be something level you were
questioning why are these equipments
there
yeah that actually almost reflects I
want to say word by word but certainly
the sentiment of some of the
intelligence that was in the hand in
reports I can't remember the date of
that
um I do believe and again stand to be
corrected commissioner evidence in Chief
was led by by interim Chief Bell that
talked about the heavy equipment
um there were efforts made to interdict
to prevent that from coming in or at
least mitigate it and I believe he said
that this is not information I had as a
Time achieve so I'm relying on interim
Chief Bell's testimony that in fact much
of that heavy equipment did not make it
into the downtown core and he described
differently some of the equipment that
did make it down there than what has
been reported on previously in in Media
so as the chief
you had the the Strategic oversight uh
so to speak
um and you were asking appropriate
questions to ensure that those deputies
who were reporting to you were doing the
job when this kind of concerns arise am
I correct absolutely I mean it could be
as simple as I think a term that other
people have given testimony on you just
need to kick the tires on different
parts just make sure you ask questions
at different levels strategic
operational yes sometimes tactical to
make sure that they're aware of it and
they have put some effort into it and
there's a reasonable approach to how
they're going to address it
now we also understand from the
testimony of Inspector Lucas that there
was a potential that the Ops would be
overwhelmed during the weekend of
January 29th and 30th
um
I can take you to the transcript but it
was in evidence
so I guess my question to you is this
um if there are these warning signs and
as we progress towards the the weekend
these warning signals get stronger and
stronger
shouldn't the Ops have known what was
coming
to answer your question no if you're
asking and I don't want to interpret
wrongly your questions so if like if I
go in the wrong direction please pull me
back
as the signals became stronger and
stronger what I would expect is first I
would know the signals were getting
stronger
and clearly we did
secondly that whether I asked about it
or someone offered it that we would have
a constructive discussion around
mitigation
for those signals I can tell you
I think it was well I can tell you I
think it was the Wednesday that I
received my first formal request through
acting Deputy Ferguson to reach out to
fellow Chiefs of police and request
additional resources if I'm wrong on the
date commissioner I'll stand corrected
but middle of the week I reached out to
London Police Service York I believe
Toronto
asking for a general resource officers
but particularly public order officers
it's my recollection again I stand to be
corrected that around this state or on
this state I had another request to
reach out for more public order I
believe in commissioner Creek's
testimony that he was aware of that
request he had two public order units
that were sent to Ottawa I don't believe
they were under our ICS control but they
were in the Ottawa area and available so
that is what I would call
inspector Lucas signaling we might be
overwhelmed by the Numbers we'll need to
bolster our abilities to not be
overwhelmed particularly that would be
public order assets and I had a specific
request to get more public order assets
and I made that request in this case to
commissioner Creek and thankfully as he
did
provided those resources as as quickly
as he could now we heard from
superintendent Bernier when he testified
at the commission that after he read the
January 27th hand in report excuse me he
told superintendent Drummond uh
about this bizarre disconnect between
the hand and intelligence and the Ops uh
preparation do you
do you think that there was a bizarre
disconnect
uh first of all while I have the
greatest respect for inspector Bernier
he was not involved
directly in the planning or the
intelligence risk assessment
police services and organizations are
wonderful places everyone has an opinion
the briefings that I was getting from
the commanders that had been assigned to
the task the people that they had
assigned through their responsibilities
to produce the information some of which
is displayed on the screen here
did not indicate that there was a
bizarre
and do you think your deputies were
doing the best they could
I think they were yes sir and and
knowing what we know now and reflecting
back on the way that the Ops handled or
apply the intelligence they got
what lessons if any should we learn from
that
thank you an important question
commissioner um
Frank if I if I'm going deviating too
far please pull me back but probably one
of my top recommendations for you to
consider sir
while we had excellent intelligence and
particularly excellent support from the
Ontario Provincial Police
this was from the very onset
a national issue it's a national event
started in British Columbia it was
joined on the east coast and it brought
convoys from the southernmost point in
Windsor
probably the greatest number of
participants and vehicles came from our
border uh with with Quebec across the
five inter-provincial Bridges
the vast majority of the formal
intelligence threat risk assessment
reports that we relied on came from the
Ontario
Provincial Police
to this day I have a question
why wasn't I getting intelligence threat
risk assessments on a regular basis of
the quality that I got from the opp
from our federal Partners again I want
to be clear commissioner they
contributed meaningfully and I'm
grateful for their contributions but
I've said this in the Parliamentary
committees and I'll say it again to the
commissioner there's a structural
deficit in our National Intelligence
threat assessment process
I'm grateful for the Ontario Provincial
Police for filling that Gap and doing so
to the very best of their ability but it
was not optimal for us or any other
jurisdiction that faced any element of
these events and one of my
recommendations Sir with great respect
is that there needs to be an investment
International intelligence threat risk
assessment structure organizationally
institutionally through integrated
organizations and institutions
some of that will be a financial
investment but it doesn't all have to be
a financial investment it needspian
investment to bring this country forward
truly into the 21st century where we are
two decades two and a half decades into
it
now in your view was there anything that
the op the Ops could have done
differently to better handle the
intelligence they did have there is no
doubt sir and you you I'm sure you will
ask me multiple times over the course of
my testimony could we have done better
absolutely
I never had a chance to do a debrief
I suspect I understand that interim
Chief Bell has conducted some or
completed one I'm not sure the status
and I'm sure within that document there
will be many many examples of how we
could and could have done better and
need to do better going forward I
believe in his testimony lessons were
already learned and applied to
subsequent demonstrations so if you're a
long way of answering there is no doubt
that we could have done some things
better but specifically about how it
handled intelligence anything you can
teach us from your experience low
hanging fruit and I believe it's already
been rectified to some degree a
substantive element of our intelligence
and information directorates I would
suggest even in other
functional units and directorates the
ability for us to conduct open source
social media and and other online
information gathering with the caveats
of Charter rights privacy rights
absolutely that would have to be a very
transparent process
I stand to be corrected but when I
became chief of police we actually had
a unit that would have by description
and definition fulfilled much of that
function not all of it
it was either zero percent staffed or
staffed by one person because we did not
have the financial resources to put
human beings into those budgeted
positions we didn't have the internal
skill sets even if we could find a human
being to sit in there
I believe that's been rectified to some
significant degree based on testimony
from interim Chief Bell but that is
something it took me
almost a full year two years to convince
the Toronto Police Service to do and
this is going back
2010 2011 after the events of the G20
actually before and after when we
finally got our first
uh we call this it was called a cyber
group but really it was a for for
pre-intelligence and post-investigative
online capabilities there are very few
Police Services anywhere in Canada
Municipal provincial
OPP is an exception I don't know about
certain Quebec RCMP and the opp are the
and the Toronto Police Service are the
only ones that I would comfortably
describe as a reasonable
trending to Optimal level of capability
in that area the Ottawa Police Service
did not have that capability
okay now a moment ago in answering my
question you referenced the need to
respect Charter rights that brings me to
my next topic um you'll recall that one
of the topics we discussed during our
interviews was your understanding of how
the charter might have limited police
options in responding to the arrival of
the Convoy
um do you remember those discussions yes
sir so if I could take you now to the
interview summary at page 15
foreign
go to the second paragraph
sorry scroll down please that's right
the paragraph that starts with Chief
slowly Chief slowly was advised that
based on the known intelligence reports
Ops did not have the legal authority to
deny the freedom Convoy access to
downtown Ottawa simply because some
people disagreed with the views of some
participants he understood that Ops did
have authority to close roads and
restrict traffic if there were public
safety concerns but closures and
restrictions had to be commensurate to
actual threats or reasonably predictable
threats
highway traffic act or bylaw violations
alone would not be sufficient to justify
restricting access to the city for all
protesters so that was the The View you
expressed at the time is that the view
you still hold now
yes sir with this caveat I'm a police
officer not a lawyer
right and some of us regret to be
lawyers
now um since our interview we've
received a illegal opinion provided to
the Ops on on this issue so if I may
take you to that opinion
and find the document number
it is Ops four zeros3692
okay scroll down please
now you see there's a the paragraph that
starts with while the Convoy has not yet
reached the city of Ottawa
by the way this memo I believe is dated
January the 28th
um
deputy chief Bell requested the opinion
on the 27th and got it the next day so
this paragraph says while the Convoy has
not yet reached the city of Ottawa
various considerations will need to be
assessed and reassessed to determine the
appropriate response including the
balancing of computer competing Charter
rights impacts to public enjoyment and
the right to Mobility impacts to health
and safety impact on obstructing
emergency vehicles and impacts to Public
Safety generally do you remember if you
had access to this this legal opinion at
the time yes sir I did
um so in terms of these bullet points
they mentioned the impacts to public
enjoyment and the right to Mobility do I
understand that to apply to the right of
the residents to move around freely in
the downtown core and not be impeded
unduly by the uh by the by the trucks
and commercial vehicles
um
sorry yes right sorry okay uh and then
uh impact on obstructing emergency
vehicles that's obviously important
um for uh for reasons we'll understand
and the impact to Public Safety
generally
um so in assessing the options available
to the Ops to respond including closing
um roads and you know setting up
barriers to the downtown core these
considerations were applied
at the time
well first of all just an observation
um deputy chief Bell
made the request on the 27th again if
you recall my earlier testimony this was
a four-day event starting on the 27th
tuning to the 28th which is the Friday
with the main events on the 29th and the
30th Saturday and Sunday this legal
opinion while helpful to a degree
arrived technically in the middle of
what we were already dealing with there
were already vehicles in the city
protest Vehicles there were already
protesters and demonstrators in the city
as we were receiving reading and
considering this this did not arrive a
week before or even a day before this
was already in the middle of the events
with that caveat
this is helpful
it certainly articulates to a greater
degree what I think most of the police
officers and even my general counsel
Christian you know would have known and
could have articulated differently it's
not definitive it's advice not Direction
I understand that's council's job but
there isn't a definitive line that says
because there might be any level of any
one of these Five Points you therefore
must go to some substantive
interdiction prevention blocking of
the events that are going to happen
again language is important and I think
you and I have talked about this before
the reference of the lawyer who draft
this says the Convoy I believe
there wasn't one Convoy ever
there were multiple convoys and there
were multiple other individuals and
small groups and I think superintendent
Morris used better language than I will
but Affiliated groups that joined or
left on a daily basis
I'm always mindful when I read
particularly advice documents that use a
pejorative term
when what we were dealing with in
reality was a massive group of fluid
interactive individuals in groups where
there was no one leader no one
spokesperson and no one thing to deal
with this was helpful but not
particularly instructive
now by the 27th of January am I correct
and I believe this evidence came from
superintendent Abrams that the Ops was
expecting somewhere in the range of 3
000 trucks in to come to Ottawa downtown
I believe recall seeing that number
presented by inspector right so with
that in mind if we go to page four of
the same opinion we scroll down to page
four please
sorry with your with your Indulgence
commission with your Indulgence
I I do want to be clear though what was
listed in those five points
materially happened on the Saturday the
29th mm-hmm
those I think Deputy Bell gave excellent
evidence on his own I won't repeat his
testimony but what we saw in terms of a
violation of our community's rights our
business community's rights the level of
unlawfulness
and assaultiveness in the broadest sense
of that term including the literal sense
of that term
was not what we expected and was
overwhelming not just for the Ottawa
Police Service most importantly it was
overwhelming for those communities that
were most directly impacted by those
events that weekend and every other day
after that
so this was helpful because it to some
degree anticipated
anticipated
that there would be competing Charter
rights there would be significant
Mobility challenges there would be an
impact on our Emergency Services
in the ways that they were described
theoretically on the page so there was
usefulness in this exercise it was just
a little too little and already in the
middle of the events that were still
unfolding around us I guess my next
question after I take you to the passage
I I want you to have a chance to
consider is what it would be reasonable
to anticipate in light of this guidance
from the from the lawyer so this
paragraph starting with therefore
therefore while the case law indicates
that those who wish to protest have a
charter protective right in doing so it
is Not Without Limits these limits as
the courts have recognized prevent
threats of violence acts of violence and
unlawful conduct moreover these limits
also prevent demonstrators from
obstructing travel on roadways it is
worth noting however that there has been
at least one decision where it was found
that a blockade for a very Brewery
period only constituted a minor
inconvenience and was therefore
permissible so this paragraph reference
the need to preserve travel on roadways
as a way to limit whatever for other
competing rights the protesters may have
for a Sam free assembly and free
expression and so on
so
having this in mind can you help me
understand why when upward of 3 000
commercial vehicles and trucks are
expected to arrive in downtown
Ottawa that this wouldn't put some
limits on where those trucks could
access in downtown Ottawa thank you and
as as I'm reviewing this document and
we're having this dialogue um
all of these things were actually within
the operational plan
um I believe inspector Lucas has given
evidence to you sir that he considered
that number he considered it uh that
through the combination of the PLT
negotiations engaged by OPP and Ops
officers that there was agreements made
with as many of the convoys as possible
that would significantly reduce the
impact of such events by parking trucks
and arranging
bus or ride share into the downtown core
that would alleviate much of this that
they recognized that emergency lanes
need to be kept open of significant
amounts of planning detailed out in the
traffic plan and other plans again
evidence led by many others in that
regard the Ottawa Police Service were
neither ignorant of this and more
importantly they had taken steps to
reasonably mitigate this based
significantly on the intelligence and
information available and as we've heard
by other Ops members including inspector
Lucas deputy chief bell based on the
previous experience that they had with
similar types of events in a reasonable
similar time frame so I I think again
this was an informative document it
validated much of what we were thinking
it provided
a more clearly articulated legal basis
for what we were thinking
um and we put in place the mitigation
pieces that I felt were reasonably
presented to me in advance of this and
we had the support of an excellent group
from the opp and their PLT as well we've
heard that unfortunately the majority of
those agreements were broken let me be
careful about my language
and I believe sir it was inspector Lucas
that that gave an Insight that I was
only aware of in his testimony
um
I believe it was the Windsor Convoy that
arrived first and largest into the City
and occupied the majority of the Red
Zone area along the Parliamentary
District
once that happened the convoys kind of
relying on inspector Lucas's testimony
if I get into this wrong I will walk
that back
but once that happened inspector Lucas
described something I think he called it
like a chaotic scramble of convoys
breaking off from going anywhere the
traffic plan collapsed the extra
resources held in reserve had to be
immediately actioned to try to get the
agreements that were in place to get the
trucks to the designated parking zones
none of that was accomplished in the
morning of and I guess the early
afternoon of the Saturday the 29th The
Windsor group had claimed for the most
part Wellington Street in the
Parliamentary district and everybody
else wanted to get as close to that as
possible I shouldn't say everybody else
a lot of other participants for almost
the full duration of that event tried to
get to that most prized and prolific
public place and that was another
complicating Factor on our operations
our traffic plans our PLT operations
even our Pou operations
so I think we had an informative legal
opinion sought at a reasonably early
opportunity
received literally in the middle of the
event certainly within less than 24
hours
stop me if I'm going on too much sir but
my last point in this
and it's a what if and I don't want to
engage in too much conjecture but other
Witnesses have have provided this what
if I believe deputy chief Bell talked
about this
assuming that even on the 28th
commissioner that we decided to lock
down the city close off all the
inter-provincial bridges and the off the
off-ramps from the 416 and 417 highways
we would have needed in deputy chief
Bell's estimation 2 000 officers I think
it would have actually been more
even if that was our wish even if that
was the clearest conclusion that came
from any of the Hendon reports or any
other combination of intelligence or
legal opinions on the 28th of January we
were not going to get 2 000 extra
officers into the City and deployed on a
plan that could execute and Implement
anything that relates to this
now you you pointed out that this became
the reality as of the 28th it
materialized in your word on the 29th
sir sorry I don't know the 29th but
isn't it fair to ask that
um by the 27th
when Ops knew that 3 000 Vehicles were
coming to Ottawa and much of the online
messaging suggests that the protesters
had an intent to stay for as long as the
mandates were not lifted why isn't it
predictable
and why shouldn't the Ops be acting on
this advice to take active steps to
mitigate access to the downtown core
two things first of all we did take
active steps roads were closed we've
heard repeated testimony from Ops and
OPP senior officers that there were
efforts to manage the convoys enroute in
on the king's highways a new term I'm so
used to the Queen's highways but the
king's highways
um and so there were mitigation efforts
second thing and it does relate to the
first the biggest mitigation effort was
the work of the excellent PLT teams from
from the opp which is best in class PLT
program in the country I hope I haven't
disrespected my RCMP colleagues but
that's a humble opinion take it for what
it's worth they have an excellent PLT
program but our PLT was engaged
I believe from commissioner Creek's
evidence or it might have been
commissioner Abrams evidence engaged as
the Western convoys crossed Manitoba and
they were engaged with all the other
convoys so PLT had negotiated in good
faith and received good faith agreements
small a agreements because I don't think
it's a contract that the 3 000 trucks
would be mitigated substantially by
their willingness to move those trucks
into pre-designated areas and carpool
for lack of a better term into the core
they had agreed not to block the
emergency lanes
we had no indication even on this state
that we're going to have the type of
public display of unlawfulness
terrible term and my English teacher
will turn over to grave assaultiveness
in the broadest sense sensory as well as
physical
hate related incidents that we saw
materialize and metastasize on the 29th
into the 30th and Beyond
let me ask you now
from your perspective how did that
weekend unfolded
tell us about the events Fast and
Furious
right
um
in preparing for today I read through
some of my notes and uh
um I think I shared with my counsel I'm
I was reading the nine o'clock briefing
on the Saturday morning
whether you find this as validation or
not commissioner but the nine o'clock
briefing that I received on the Saturday
morning the 29th was still talking about
a weekend event
it described we might have a tent city
at the end of this Tent City in the
vernacular meaning that we would have
some five six seven eight maybe 20
tenths somewhere in an NCR Park
Confederation Park and that we would
need to remove it as we had in previous
ways and I'd seen that done during my
tenure
there is a bit of a back and forth that
I'm quoted in as saying well can we make
sure that we have our ESU which is our
Emergency Services Unit
down on the ground and when everybody
when anybody brings out a tent can we in
a very smiling and polite way ask them
not to put their tent up so we have less
work to do after the weekend
that is literally the substantive
assessment traffic plan is working PLT
Agreements are in place convoys are
arriving officers are ready to go
intersect is stood up ncrcc has stood up
and we might have a bit of a tent city
to deal with that is consistent with all
of the briefings intelligence and
operational on balance in summary that I
had been receiving up until that point
that wasn't the case probably by 11
o'clock in the morning
it happened that quick
what happened by 11. my understanding
and my observation was by 11 o'clock we
had an a significantly embedded
clearly beginning to occupy and in some
cases fortify
elements of Wellington Street the
Parliamentary district and other parts
of our downtown core
that we were not able to maintain the
agreed level of cooperation with the
various convoys
and that the traffic plan and the
Staffing and Reserve Staffing was
significantly if not already fully
exhausted
I did not have the detailed descriptions
as have been provided
uh in testimony here around what was
taking place in the ncrcc and I can't
validate or invalidate the level of
Chaos
potentially the occasional F-bomb that
might have been thrown around in that
room of dedicated professionals who were
having been excuse my term punched right
in the nose and engaged in a standing
eight count trying to get the city back
to a level of safety as quickly as they
can and also trying to keep our Ottawa
Police Service members and our partner
agency members our city workers
residents business owners as safe as
they possibly could in a set of
circumstances that at this point sir
clearly was unprecedented
clearly was unprecedented
so are you describing the event of the
29th the morning early afternoon of the
29th which essentially stayed on a
steady state with varying degrees of
crowd Dynamic and other injects like
alcohol and drugs into the evening but
that was pretty well the next 72 hours
so at some point on the 29th you realize
that you're confronting something
unprecedented yes sir
um I believe inspector Lucas described
it as drinking from the fire holes
that's a very polite description
how would you describe it
however many convoys there were that's
as many fire hoses were coming add 10
more fire hoses for all the other odds
and sods that showed up put three more
fire hoses in for the minus 35 degree
temperature
four or five more for the level of
fatigue
that our officers already had going into
those events
43 more fire hoses for the level of
public trust in policing based on all
the events that I outlined earlier on
and I think that's a more accurate
assessment of the amount of water that
we were taking on at that point at the
height of the daisy Vance how many
trucks would you estimate was there were
there I received an estimate I never
made the estimate either as high as 5
000 trucks and fifteen thousand
participants is the upper end number
that I received that I recall receiving
on the Saturday
I say 5 000 trucks I want to be careful
five thousand Vehicles predominantly
trucks but that might have included a
range of other vehicles that I can't
detail-free and that's just in the
downtown core yes sir
um what about the emergency lanes were
they kept open
my understanding through testimony is
that they they managed to keep the
Wellington Lane
South Lane open
for much of that day I don't know if
they lost it for portions or at some
point between the Saturday and the
Sunday they lost it or made a decision
to close off Wellington and then create
a an Emergency Lane access seagrass
through other Street combinations I'm
not clear on the details sir as the
members of the Ottawa Police Service
began to focus on responding to this
these events in downtown uh what is what
was the impact on the rest of the city
it's a very important question and I
think touched on at some point in
testimony
um
the downtown core was like
clearly was the epicenter and and a
hyper volatile
hyper complex
I won't be able to provide adjectives so
I'll just leave it at that
but you could drive
south of the four
16. do that right 417.
into literally still downtown
neighborhoods and and you would hear
honking and you'd see
unfortunately Canada flag stuck on
vehicles and and behavior that was
clearly anti-social but it dropped off
significantly once you got south of
of the 417.
further out into the Canadas and the
other parts there were probably micro
things happening I'm never really sure
of it
so the city would be aware of it it
would be obviously on TV social media is
exploding at this point and people are
dialed in to what's going on
but from a physical standpoint physical
location you know 98 of it was in a
micro concentration hyper concentration
of activity
and
trauma unfolding trauma to our community
in in the heart of our city in the heart
of the Parliamentary district and and I
don't want to in any way forget
you know their Federal Representatives
here but the trauma impacted on federal
employees elected officials public
officials the entire infrastructure and
ecosystem that represents our nation's
capital the Parliamentary district and
the I believe Mr champ quoted 18 or 15
000 residents in that area
I don't know how many businesses I know
the Rideau Center was closed all of that
happened literally within hours and the
relief did not come I believe until
February 17th 18th or 19th
and we've heard evidence from some of
the residents and business owners
affected during the first week of
hearing that from that time on they
started feeling
abandoned by the police by other
leaders and they felt uh hopeless that
was one of the adjectives they used
um and they started seeing a kind of
General chaos and lawlessness
um
how would you describe what was
happening were those adjectives accurate
first of all I'll never I'll never
challenge the feelings of a member of
our community they're their feelings
there is
righteous and as accurate as they need
to be for the human being that expressed
them so I'm in no way challenging
wherever that sentiment came from
um I can tell you that I met with spoke
with walked around and talked with many
of the residents the business owners I
was at a business Improvement
Association meeting that was referenced
by one of the witnesses and I heard a
range of sentiments I saw a range of
responses from incredibly resilient and
understanding and patient people an
elderly couple both of them in firm and
wheelchairs traveling through that minus
35 degree temperature stopped me as I
was getting out of my SUV while doing a
live call
on a board meeting on February 1st I
believe
and talk to me I had to I think
gerardines was talking and I was
literally talking to this couple Chief
we know you guys are doing the best you
can please it's hard for us to to get
around the sidewalks we're trying to do
our shopping we know this is really
tough when you and your team please do
your best for us so yes I heard
expressions of hopelessness I heard
accusations of abandonment
I would have to say the vast majority
that I received directly to me was
around resilience impatience
get this thing resolved as quickly as
you can as completely as you can but
resilience and a level of
understanding as to what the officers on
the ground and I don't say just officers
the members of our organization the
partners that were deployed already from
Opp RCMP London God bless them I think
people understood how difficult it was
but they didn't see the the situation
resolving in a day in two days and I
think it's reasonable for people to feel
really
aggrieve that there isn't a clear
solution or a timeline to a clear
solution that they could tangibly see
and anticipate and we were simply not in
a position
to provide that to them
and at that time
in in addition to the perspectives of
the the residents and business owners
Etc uh since you're the chief of the
Ottawa Police Service can you tell us
how how was the how were the members of
the Ottawa Police Service holding up
because this was only the beginning it
continued for another three weeks or so
foreign
part for me sorry
you want us to take a break and thank
you sir it's okay
they were doing their very best
under inhuman circumstances like the
city was like the community was
it was too cold and it was too much
but they did their very best
and I'm grateful to them
and they should be celebrated not
celebrate this wrong word
they should be understood
do you feel that they were misunderstood
yes
can you elaborate on that
I think I've given this testimony in
parliamentary standing committees the
level of disinformation and
misinformation was off the charts
it was crushing to the members morale
was crushing to the incident command
teams morale I was crushing to my
executive teams morale I suspect it was
crushing to the board it was crushing to
everybody
it was unrelenting it was 24 hours a day
and I think by the end of the weekend it
had become a global story
that mainstream media was following
and none of it was portraying
in any way accurate
the hard work of the men and women of
the Ottawa Police Service and the
partner agencies that stood with us
none of it
to this day it hasn't
and that is very unfortunate because
public trust and confidence in any
Police Service
I believe is the number one Public
Safety Factor
when any Police Service loses
significantly public trust and
confidence that in of itself is a
massive Public Safety threat and risk
it materializes in so many ways I don't
know if the commissioner wants me to
elucidate
expand on that but I'm happy to do so
and unfortunately as quickly as the
events unfolded on the morning and the
afternoon of the Saturday public opinion
against Seattle Police Service and its
members turned just as
quickly and to the same unprecedented
levels that were unrelenting
at least for my entire experience up
until February 15th
well you spoke of how the officers were
misunderstood let's hope that this
inquiry will be the beginning of that
understanding
commissioner can we
would this be a good time to take a
recess
if you would like sure we can take the
morning break for 15 minutes
the commission is in recess for 15
minutes
foreign
order a lot
just respect for your profession
period I'll go back
good morning commissioner okay
go ahead
so before the break
um
Chief slowly you were telling us about
the event of that first weekend and how
and how it hit everyone uh really hard I
like to take you now to January the 31st
which I believe is the Monday after yes
sir we've heard from deputy chief
Ferguson that that was when uh the
executive team realized that a lawful
protest has now turned into an illegal
occupation
um that was her evidence and I'm
interested in your view on that
um my view is it was unlawful the moment
Allah was broken into a relation to the
events and so for me that was clearly
the Saturday morning
um
I don't want to in any way interpret
deputy chief acting Deputy Ferguson's
impression
I think I would position the 31st as we
now know this is going to be a longer
term occupation there are fortifications
and there are there is a alarming level
of public safety issues writ large and
we're going to have to Pivot our plan to
now address the current context and near
future context that we're going to be
dealing with so it's in that context
that perhaps
again I want to misinterpret but perhaps
the full command is fully on the same
page and the incident command team is
pivoting the plan now into the next
phase of this occupying period tell us
about that pivot what did the executive
team decide to do
I don't know if there is
any significant decision I mean we
needed a much a
we needed a significant update on the
intelligence threat risk
um
much of that was in place in the build
up and iterations but we now needed to
to escalate to another level and again
that cycle of intelligence threat risk
assessment to then feed the pivoting
operational plan to what extent are we
going to need different resources
greater levels of resources in one area
versus another area and to what extent
do we need to build out uh subplans and
and other things for me at the chief of
police level is what resources are we
going to need
um what do I now need to do to inform
and or engage other levels including the
oversight body of the audible Police
Services Board the city of of of
Ottawa and and other factors and I will
be I was still trying to understand
really what had just arrived in our city
what really was it
um and and even just level set my own
understanding never mind the work that
was being done
on behalf of me through deputies Bell
and acting Deputy Fergus Deputy Bell
described that first week as appear
period of orientational reorientation do
you agree with that description
I understand I think I understand the
theme behind it I would probably use
different language but I think it's I
think it's definitely a what just
happened how do we now need to reorient
to re reassess and then start to address
the situation going forward
so before the Convoy arrive we've seen
an initial plan dated January the 28th
what was the understanding now in terms
of going forward in terms of the need
for a new plan there was no need for a
new plan there was a need for an
evolution of the plan that we had
an evolution of the threat risk
assessment that was in that plan again I
want to make it clear there was only
ever one plan there were many iterations
of it there was only ever one threat
risk assessment there were many
iterations of it
so what was the understanding then about
this the need for this new evolve plan
on the Monday the 31st yes
probably the number one thing at that
point was Staffing Staffing Staffing
Staffing
and how did you go about achieving that
um again without that the absence of my
notes but as simple as how many more
officers can we redeploy from our
overall complement of policing a city of
a million people in the nation's largest
Municipal geography to that micro core
of the red zones in the immediate
neighborhoods around it
um I think by that point
again I'd stand to be corrected if the
records say otherwise with that point we
already started to look at changing our
shift hours to create a greater volume
of officers available officers and
civilian members
um
I don't know if we had at that point
reached out to the association the the
Ottawa Police Association
um to start to negotiate a whole
different shift schedule that might have
come later on in the week but that was
the focus and then external resource
requests requests that went to OPP and
other police services to send additional
resources on top of what they had
provided us already so around that
period January 31st and the next few
days
did the Ops start reaching out to other
external agencies for for help yes
absolutely tell us what steps you or the
other members of the executive team did
um predominantly
it sort of happens at two levels
um you know the the the agency to agency
relationships would already be you know
phone calls and text messages to people
that they knew in other agencies you
know you'll get something formal from
the chief but we need X Y and Z and then
the formal request would come up through
acting deputy chief Ferguson and that I
would make a reach out to the respective
agencies so it probably my my Approach
for the main I may have deviated every
now and then would be a text message to
the chief of police or commissioner
saying that you'll be getting a formal
request but I'm looking for x or y or Z
and then my executive assistant would
produce the document and I would forward
that formally once I got a positive
response the positive response I would
then forward to our legal services
department and they would go through the
process of enabling a a memorandum of
understanding in mou
and now I want to get a better
understanding of the options that were
opened uh while the Ops were reaching
out for external help so I want to take
you to a document Ops four zeros five
six three one
foreign
so just looking at the top it says
public order truck Convoy de-escalation
planning meeting
February 1st
2022
do you have perhaps we can scroll down a
little so you can familiarize yourself
there's a meeting with the chief can we
go down further
a number of discussion points
so for example the third bullet
um there's a notation that every single
option
to be explored and is open to discussion
he is happy to come back and further
discuss anything if we need him to
um he I take it uh refers to you yes sir
so if we go down further PLT would like
one more attempt to speak with every
Convoy to get them on the same page
we scroll down further
every Pou we ask for will not be
released to come to Ottawa as protests
happening now everywhere we might not
get the starving numbers we asked for so
there are a couple of things I wanted to
ask you to comment on first of all
there's a reference to things happening
elsewhere what can you tell us about
that
I Believe by the 31st I'm certain unless
I'm really off base but Coots Alberta
was already in play at that point
um on the Monday I don't recall any
other
Ontario sites I don't even think the
announcement of the
no I on the Monday oh sorry on the
Tuesday by then there might have been
some sort of indication that there would
be an event in Toronto around Queens
Park but I don't think there was any
other active sites in Ontario there were
I believe some demonstrations that other
provincial capitals across the country
but for sure Coots was active and
clearly being televised and we were
seeing I was getting briefings from
commissioner lucky on on the events out
there
so by this time which I believe was
February the 2nd or the first February
the first I believe
um things are happening elsewhere and if
we go back to the top
one of the discussion points uh do you
see
the third Bullet From The Bottom it says
Pou unit across the province needed
what does that refer to
so
um maybe I could just give some context
to the meeting please so this is a
Tuesday
um
we are into the significantly into the
pivot at this point
um
I had received varying levels of input
some of them just random emails some of
them very specific conversations with
people with a lot of experience in
unprecedented unusual Public Safety
events
and the validation that I was getting
from
small eye information to large eye
information based and expertise was this
was unprecedented this was larger than
your Police Service is going to be able
to handle it was National and in some
cases International in scope
it was fueled by
significant funding significant deep uh
misinformation disinformation and
polarization just to name a few
this meeting was my first attempt to sit
down with acting Deputy Ferguson as a
major Incident Commander
I had invited I had asked for inspector
Lucas to be at the meeting he could not
attend and I respect his reason although
I don't know it specifically
I think in Spectrum Murray was sent as
his designate I think but he was a
senior officer from the ICS team that
was their staff sergeant Mike Stoll who
was the ESU Commander our Pou Commander
what does ESU stand for emergency
emergency safety unit
or Emergency Services Unit sorry it's
been a it's been a little bit of time
it's synonymous with Pou public order
essentially but broader I think actually
a broader
a broader use of trained officers that
are actually more effectively deployed a
really good practice here that Ottawa
should be recognized for Ottawa Police
Service should be recognized for
um
and I had brought with me the two PLT
supervisors because I had information
feedback internally that our PLT members
weren't being optimally used and were
feeling out of the loop of substantive
discussions like this and I had
requested that the two supervisors be
there and and they were there and you
see their contributions later on in the
notes
but this is the substantive first time
that I'm sitting down with the incident
command
thread strategic operational and
Tactical
asking what are you folks seeing how are
you assessing this no decisions being
made here I need situational awareness I
need your assessment we had been blessed
with commanders of some expertise and
experience from other jurisdictions that
were in that room I think London was
there
I can't remember if Durham I believe
there was an opp Commander I can't
recall but there were at least three
three other agencies in the room so it
wasn't just us talking to us there was a
healthy amount of external expertise
and we went through what I would call
I won't say it's a whiteboarding session
but a consultation discussion session
that I wanted to get to at some point to
okay well this is good now what's the
move forward coming up from this so
that's the context of this meeting no
I'll pause there if
if you want to come back to the question
that you wanted me to ask answer yes
because I'm interested in this notation
that Pou units across the province
needed so
around I'd say around the midpoint of
that meeting
um
I would have almost turned to Michelle
Moran and Mike Stoll who were sitting to
my uh my right and said what's the level
of Pou that you would think we would
need to start to dismantle the Red Zone
and end the occupation
um and then there was like a real-time
discussion between my folks and the
other Pou commanders in the room there
were others that were chiming it was
mainly a Pou discussion and I've been in
them many other times before so I know
how this feels I just sort of sat back
and watched this new generation of
experts do their thing and it was kind
of it's kind of cool to watch
um and within a really short time for a
period of time it was almost unanimous
this may not be the exact language but
as close to it we're going to need
everything in Ontario and a bunch more
from across Canada
that was one of the moments where I
truly understood the scale of what we
were facing
everything in Ontario and a bunch more
from across Canada for me was State
visits
an Olympic event
ghc20
nothing else requires that mm-hmm
that's when I truly understand from
people with amazing expertise from
different jurisdictions
add on to that whatever other resources
we're going to request that's somewhere
already in the range of six seven eight
hundred officers
plus investigators plus boots on the
ground officers plus dispatchers
analysts special constables to handle
Mass arrests the number is going to be
well north of a thousand and it's way
more than we will ever be able to supply
within the Ottawa Police service within
the Eastern region of Ontario within the
province so that recognition came as
early as February 1st yes sir now if we
go down a little
in the first box under discussion point
I read a bit from it earlier PLT would
like one more attempt to speak with
every Convoy to get them on the same
page truckers need to clear all the
roads and stop honking in exchange for
fuel in a place to park
have zero room for to negotiate if they
don't deal with it in this way they will
be removed why is it that
there was Zero room to negotiate
I I don't know I'm assuming this is the
PLT contribution to
to the discussion so I I don't
these aren't my notes and it doesn't
seem to be attributed to one or both of
the supervisors I don't know if this is
their briefing contribution in totality
so I'm not sure what by what that means
I was just curious because it appears
that the PLT would like more time more
opportunity to to speak to the Convoy
and then perhaps there was another view
Express no room to negotiate I I was
just wondering if you could Enlighten us
on what this discussion was about oh
again there were some 20 people in the
room and it was really an open Forum
discussion with people just
contributing ideas in a very fluid way
right if I could take you now to the
next document uh the next day
Ops three zeros one four four eight four
so if we go to page 22
[Applause]
now achieve slowly do you have a
practice of making notes to yourself
sending yourself emails as reminders or
things like that yes I do sir and would
this be one of those examples yes sir
um so here we read
um advise that all options on the table
needs to consider sorry can can you I'm
just not sure the context for date or
time of this sorry yes call with mayor
and it's the timestamp at least on the
entry is 130 okay thank you and we see a
name on the top left
Maria
Fortunato who's that that's my executive
assistant or was my executive assistant
so um the contents of uh the email which
is I guess note to yourself says advise
that all options on the table needs to
consider the political option what roles
can Premiere and PM play in diffusing
the demonstration it is not my legal
responsibility to end a demonstration it
is my legal responsibility to provide
adequate and effective policing
to Serve and Protect the city
slash citizens
um what was the purpose of this note to
yourself
at this point I actually didn't have an
assigned scribe so I was trying in real
time to capture information around
conversations I thought were important
or a point that I was trying to remember
so it's not a consistent practice with
every single meeting that I would go
back and and do this
that's the context of the note
um I don't know if that answers your
question sir and since the subject at
the top says call with mayor yes read
demonstration does that capture some of
the contents of the call some of it yes
sir on the 2nd of February yes now on
that same day you made a public
announcement that turned out to be
somewhat controversial
do you know what I'm talking about I I
think I can guess what's coming sir okay
give me a guess
there may not be a policing solution to
this why did you say that
for all the reasons that we've talked
about
the size and scale of the events were
not going to be able to be handled by
any one police of jurisdiction certainly
not mine
that this was a national scope event it
started
from corners of all parts of Canada and
arrived in our city it was already by
the second in several other locations
Coots specifically I think by the second
there would have been some indication
that Queen's Park in Toronto would have
been a location
um this was borne out by a wide variety
of polarizing issues not the least of
which was the the vaccine mandates but
there were many other anti-government uh
sentiment expressed at all three levels
of government
and some of this was just people looking
to come into our city and participate an
event
to have an unruly and in many cases
unlawful party
um
this was the underpinnings that
created this event and brought it
substantially into our city we're well
beyond the police services act Mandate
of me as a police chief and the Ottawa
Police Service in the police of
jurisdiction and we're going to have to
engage other elements of civil society
and likely all three levels of
government to make in some way a
meaningful contribution to a sustainable
solution to the end of it
what was the context in which you made
this statement
I believe there was a
I can't remember as a board meeting or
if it was a
council meeting that that the board was
in attendance at there was a range of
questions for hours and at some point
one of the questions elicited that
response
and how was your comment received
if there are 35 million people in Canada
probably 35 million different ways
do you feel that you were understood
no largely misunderstood but by a lot of
people very understood
and have you had a chance to reflect on
the statement you made
since the time you made it a lot
and what conclusions have you come to it
needed to be more clear okay what did
you need to be more clear on
that the Ottawa Police Service is doing
and will continue to do everything we
possibly can do just to be clear that
was literally the substantive answer I
was giving during that meeting all
options are on the table we're doing
everything we can we're calling all the
Staffing we can we are rearranging our
plan we're calling out to our partners
so before that statement was made it
wasn't made in a vacuum we were hours
into a long meeting with multiple
questions from multiple stakeholders I
believe my board were present I stand to
be corrected City councilors the mayor
what are you doing how are you going to
end this when is it going to end
please understand we're doing everything
we can and we'll continue to do
everything we can on a repeat Loop but
at some point
this isn't going to end just by the
Ottawa Police Service
even if we could find a way to get all
the resources we need it's going to come
back again next week
the month after Canada day this is a
larger movement or series of movements
this is a trend that's happening across
the country and around the world and so
there needs to be more than just a
policing solution to it that's the
context now I did reflect on it and in
the days and weeks and now months after
that I've in Opportunities like this
expanded on that short phrase I think
there's ample documentation in my notes
scribe notes to talk about me explaining
this further to the chair at board
meetings and other conversations and
meetings so I didn't just leave it till
now to provide a more fulsome
explanation within hours and days of it
I was trying to provide that more
fulsome explanation to my board
oversight and to other public bodies and
civil actors
now there are those who may say that
your statement fostered a perception
among the public and the protesters that
the Ops was vulnerable and unable to
police the Convoy uh what do you say to
that
again like my earlier comment sir um
everyone is entitled to their opinion
and they're certainly entitled to their
feelings and I can understand
that if if that was the only thing they
heard from me and they were not
available to hear all the other efforts
I made to clarify that that could leave
them with a sense that we've just given
up
so I'm not challenging that
um but let me be clear I I don't know if
that is different from any other
statement I've made around the role of
policing in society if you recall my
earlier comments when I introduced my
approach to policing and how I did it
police are not going to solve guns and
gangs and drugs on their own without
Education Health Care Social Services
the volunteer sector communities
themselves the police are not going to
be able to solve sexual assaults on
their own without advocacy groups and
legislative change so there there isn't
any major aspect of policing crime
management order management traffic
management even traffic management we
can't Patrol the amount of Highways
unless we have bylaw changes signage
changes engineering changes that were
well beyond the remit of the Police
Service to demand and deliver so for me
this is a consistent theme that I have
spoken on and acted in accordance
throughout my entire policing career it
wasn't for me an unusual statement but
it was heard in unusual and
unprecedented circumstances and
misinterpreted broadly badly
do you think that the lack of clarity of
the statement
might have risk contributing to a loss
of public trust in the ability of the
police to respond I can't rule that out
sir but I think I made enough efforts
after that to clarify that and
demonstrably the Ottawa Police Service
kept with its Partners kept putting out
everything we possibly could for as long
as we could I would very strongly
suggest well past where we should have
been
our actions should have spoken louder
than words but unfortunately by Saturday
afternoon there had been a cemented
narrative and I don't think it ever
changed my statement probably didn't
help it
but I don't think it was really
changeable from that first weekend
now we've also heard from other police
leaders who disagreed with the statement
from their perspective in the way that
they interpreted the statement and they
they felt that there was in fact a
policing solution and the way that the
the the occupation was ultimately
dismantled prove that there was a
policing solution what do you say to
that
again if their comment was based on what
was said without the benefit of hearing
all the other explanations
um I certainly attempted through the
larger calls to establish the things I
just talked about we are still looking
we're still doing everything we can
we're seeking all the help we can and if
we can get 1800 resources or whatever
number the final amount was to come in
then we could take care of the unlawful
aspects of this but there are broader
implications and underpinnings that
could bring it back to my city or any
other city or jurisdiction and so
sustainably to resolve the situation we
were still going to need larger Civil
Society all three levels of government
I don't know if this is the time to
interject around any of the the levels
of Declarations of emergency Municipal
provincial or federal
but clearly we have indications and I
believe that there were assistances from
those various levels the injunction the
private injunction and so
there are clearly examples where some
additional efforts were needed beyond
the efforts of the police to resolve it
local community mobilize themselves in
mostly constructive ways in some ways
less constructive but there were efforts
across the board from private citizens
to public institutions that contributed
ultimately to that success
while I respect the comments of my peers
I want to be careful in my language here
I don't know any major operation
including that one that did not benefit
material from the supports outside of
police organizations themselves and I
think that's unfair to the contributions
made by broader Civil Society including
all three levels of government
comments so I want to be clear about
that but no police organization of any
size operation of any size that I've
ever been involved with that had the
clear level of success no deaths no
serious injuries no significant damage
to infrastructure no rioting no burning
police cars
I don't know of any size operation that
didn't materially benefit from the
consent and cooperation of citizenry the
injections of material resources or or
advice expertise from other experts
outside of policing legislative change
etc etc
okay so this was uh on the second right
that you made the statement sure let's
move forward by a few I did recall it
was the first but I'm I'm not going to
I'm not going to quibble right
um
so let's move forward by a few days and
we've heard from other witnesses that
the weekends are always the worst is
that right in terms of the search of
numbers
yes in terms of the surgeon numbers and
then the extra dynamics of convoys
coming in or not coming in and
definitely larger in scale and more
complex
right
so um I want to show you an email dated
February the 5th at 6 33 a.m the
document number is Ops three zeros 7355
I expect it will show an email from you
to acting deputy chief Ferguson
and by this point on around the fifth uh
what was the state of any evolving plan
that the Ops had
I think on that date I received a
briefing on the three options I'd asked
for from the meeting on February 1st the
POU options
so that's a substantive sub-plan
development
um by then we'd had major changes around
our our internal Staffing capabilities
decisions around how to redeploy
resources around both the events for the
Convoy as well as policing the rest of
the city which still had to happen on a
24-hour basis obviously
um we had made announcements around our
efforts to try to address the disorderly
unlawful and assaultive behavior they
hate
type behavior that was happening
directly in the community's most
affected around the Red Zone
variously described as Surge and enforce
and contain
so those are some of the examples of
overarching we were now planning for a
week's
cycle as opposed to a weekend cycle
requests had gone out to partner
agencies not just for police officers
but for planners people with expertise
in PLT Pou recognizing we didn't have
the expertise or the number of people
necessary to do the type of planning and
sub planning that we needed to do and I
know I'm going fast commissioner so if
you need me to slow down I will so
there's a range of activities that are
that are engaged in evolving the
pre-arrival plan into an
an in event
plan
well that context is helpful as we take
a look at this document
can we scroll down a bit
so in this email you said you have
directed
um inspector dayu to convene a full
incident command briefing at 8 00 am
if we go down further
there's a recap situational awareness
and then below that we see some two sets
of priorities
first of all the general priorities has
a couple of points search contain and
then Force that's the first point second
demonstration fully Implement plan but
close everything in Brackets roads
Bridges Highway off-ramps Etc as early
and as long as possible third shutdown
secure enablers for unlawful and unsafe
protests
funds fuel fun I won't read the the
contents in Brackets
is there a fourth Point can we go down
okay so that's it the first priority
General priorities uh explain to us what
this is all about
so this is the second Saturday you'll
recall what happened on the first
Saturday
um
Point number two around close everything
at the meeting that was held that was
qualified I want to be clear about that
um clearly access and egress access into
the City and access into the downtown
core was one of the major reasons why
that situation on the first Saturday so
quickly escalated and metastasized into
the events that we're feeling right now
it was reasonably predictable at this
point that we were going to have another
large influx of convoys ones and twos
vehicles and walk across bridges
demonstrators that would again likely
overwhelm the amount of resources even
at that time that we had in the city
and so that was a major
public safety risk that on the second
Saturday was now even more likely to
happen and so that's the point there The
Surge contained and enforce was
announced on the Friday morning at a
media conference and this was
specifically to address the level of
ongoing disorderly assaultive hate
related behavior that are downtown
communities and businesses were
experiencing particularly in
councilor flurries Ward and
um
councilor McKinney although I'm not sure
she's in office now but former counselor
McKinney her award
um and and the overwhelming amount of
community complaints business complaints
were coming from the unlawful
type behavior in that area and we needed
to that surge containing enforce is not
for the red zone that is for the areas
outside of the Red Zone and the
reference around stacking the day shift
and the night shift is to hold back the
night shift officers and then deploy the
day shift officers we have a larger
amount at that time to be visibly
present in the mid-morning to mid
afternoon when the bulk of those
arriving
demonstrators and activities unlawful
assaultive type of activities would be
taking place
the third point is around
probably less of a public safety piece
but still unlawful unsafe funds that
we're enabling to some significant
degree the ongoing activities here and
and and other locations but certainly
here in Ottawa fuel the trucks needed
Fuel and we were already trying to deal
with the Jerry cans and and that the
open Flames propane in residential areas
that I think has already been spoken
about and the fun probably not the best
word to use but these were I think
significant
significant
emotional and psychological impacts on
those that felt captured
abandoned that that elements of the
demonstration and the Convoy events were
fun where they were suffering and I
think there was a reasonable need for us
to take whatever lawful and ethical
actions we could to stop it or
discourage it and negotiate it in some
way again those were largely the actions
that that PLT I believe were involved
with now let me Focus for the moment on
the third well the second and third
point
the the directive to close roads and so
on as well as shutting things down like
a few seizure and so on in earlier
testimony from deputy chief Ferguson and
I believe Deputy Bell as well they
expressed The View that um
this is an example of a strategic level
executive
going down crossing the boundary into
the operational or even possibly
tactical level of command and
there was some question about the
propriety of a strategic level Commander
doing that what's your view on on this
this is me Crossing that boundary and
for a very specific reason it's the
first full week the entire service is
fully deployed and fully exhausted
we are getting massive complaints from
our community and they are suffering by
this time they're suffering the
resilience I talked about
is still there in a lot of people but
it's waning
we are now reasonably able to predict
the cycles of increases on Friday
Saturday into Sunday and down we know
what's coming and we knew what hit us
the week before and this is the chief of
police calling a special incident
command meeting to say are we ready do
we have the capacity are we able to
significantly alter what took place last
Saturday to what is going to take place
this Saturday and I need to look around
the room and Eyeball everybody and get a
nod or a head shake and then figure out
what we need you need for resources
so I frame I framed out
something that people could come
prepared to discuss and invited them to
that meeting
so just so I understand you're
acknowledging that you were in fact
stepping into the operational tactical
levels but you're saying this is
Justified under the circumstances I was
stepping into the operational levels to
make sure that strategic intent was
really clear to the operational
commanders now at this time on the fifth
who was the event commander in charge
what I thought it was superintendent
Chris rielm I found out at the meeting
that transpired later that in fact it
was superintendent Jamie Dunlop so when
you made these directives you weren't
aware yet uh that it was
um it was Dunlop superintendent Dunlop
that's great
now some may say that the proper way to
do this is not for the Strategic
Commander to step into the operational
level but uh to have a discussion with
the operational commander and provide
strategic direction or if the Strategic
Commander did not have have enough
confidence in the operational Commander
to replace that person rather than to
to start directing operations him or
herself what do you say to that
um if you scroll up to the top of this
please
so this is what's the time stamp on this
email sorry I just can't see it
I believe it's 11 33
on Saturday February the 5th well that
doesn't make sense
oh um I I'm told that this may be
Greenwich
meantime and so uh is this six hours
difference
so I think this is around five hours
it's around five or six o'clock in the
morning
um so to give you context
Confederation Park had become a
significant site that we were conducting
PLT negotiations
um the issue of fuel coming into the
downtown from
Coventry Road was escalating
um
the level of complaints legitimate
desperate complaints coming in from
businesses and residents are escalating
we had spent most of the Thursday and
Friday trying to build towards the
announcement on the Friday of the surge
in force contain the statements all
options are on the table we are putting
all of our resources on the ground you
will see a a visible different amount
visible greater visibility of police
officers engaged in a wider array of
activities including enforcement to
address the substantive complaints and
concerns affecting our community and I
know I went way too fast there so I'm
going to take a breath and let people
catch up
coming into the Saturday night
I woke up because I wasn't getting a
whole lot of sleep those days
I woke up somewhere around three o'clock
in the morning could not get back to
sleep I checked the situation report
that came in from Duty inspector Frank
dou and he laid out information that is
contained in this email
the Confederation Park
I'm not reading exactly but the
Confederation Park negotiations ended
badly the indigenous Elders that had
come in were treated badly there was an
attack on one of our our sergeants at
one of the sites other city workers were
being attacked this for me was an
alarming situational report in the
middle of the night
that no one else was likely reading
and I wouldn't have been reading until I
had woken up with my alarm at five
o'clock in the morning
but I read it
so I got in a shower I got into my car
and I got down to the station and I
changed into my gear and I looked around
we were thinly staffed I understand why
there was not much to staff with we were
thinly staffed and when I went down onto
the we call the zero level of our
headquarters and asked the watch
commanders there and the sergeants
what's our staffing levels look like for
nine o'clock 10 o'clock 11 o'clock when
the bulk of the resource when the bulk
of the convoys were coming in the
numbers I got were really concerning
the level of threat from the situational
report from inspector Dao at three
o'clock in the morning was alarming so
overnight we had an escalated level of
threat at multiple different sites and
in the morning I wasn't getting a sense
that we had the Staffing commensurate to
what we had announced and what we
actually needed
and so I needed to make sure that I
could pull together an incident command
team and ask these operational level
questions to be assured that we were in
a better State of Affairs than what I
was getting at that point in the morning
and I think that is a reasonable level
of situational awareness for a chief of
police in an unprecedented crisis to ask
of their operational Commanders
um would you agree then that these
priorities set out in this email were
conceived by you and directed by you
they were conceived by me they weren't
directed by me they were these were the
areas that we were going to explore at
the Commander's meeting
but then we also heard from deputy chief
Ferguson or while we confirm through her
testimony uh the notes that she wrote
that you expressed
the the the sentiment that
um
that this plan was not to be changed not
changing the operational plan need to
implement the hell out of that plan for
the next 72 hours the plan we have is
excellent so um I believe we asked
um deputy chief Ferguson whether that
was what you said and she confirmed it
do you remember at what point was that
because is that the subsequent meeting
that we had when I called for the
incident command meeting
um perhaps it would help if we go back
to Ops triple
zeros14479 those are deputy chief
Ferguson's notes
if necessary we can also go to a
transcript
from last
Thursday's testimony
so if we go to page 43
can we go down
sorry
oh sorry we need to go back up
sorry go up
further up
I'm sorry just further down
there we go
need to turn the need to turn the corner
on
this stick today not changing the op
plan need to implement the hell out of
the plan for the next 72 hours
um
so does that refresh your memory yes so
you set that
yes and you consider this an excellent
plan
and it was not to be changed just I'm a
little confused sorry sir yes um the
three-pointer that I put in my email
inviting is not the ops plan I'm
referring to here ah could you clarify
that yes
I sent a meeting request I'm concerned
about these three areas we're going to
discuss them
we have this meeting and I'm saying our
ops plan is the right plan
what I want us to do is implement the
hell out of it so surge in force contain
was part of our ops plan implement the
hell out of it that means you're going
to have to have enough resources to do
that
to Surge into the neighborhood you I
think the number we said was I might get
the numbers wrong but I think it was 30
per shift over three shifts in two
neighborhoods where you would see 15
extra uniform officers in those
neighborhoods but if we can't staff to
that level we can't implement the heck
out of it or even implement it so the
Staffing request is around make sure
that what we've announced as part of our
excellent ops plan which is not changing
has the Staffing to implement that's the
reference
the reference around the traffic plan
we're supposed to be reducing the amount
of convoys coming into the city make
sure the traffic plan is staffed
adequately and implemented effectively
so we don't have the same level of surge
of trucks and vehicles coming into the
downtown but we're not changing the plan
there was a clarification
and there was a misunderstanding from
inspector Frank dawu when I first
contacted him at probably four o'clock
in the morning
where he interpreted close everything as
literally
get the opp to close every Highway
off-ramp of the king's highways across
the entire Municipality of Ottawa
he would need probably a thousand police
officers to do that and I would never
intend that to happen I would never need
that to happen I never needed it to
happen
that misinterpretation has stayed alive
to this day I clarified in this meeting
down to off-ramps that give direct
access to the downtown core where our
red zones are area that's what I need I
wanted all the inter-provincial bridges
closed because all of them give direct
access to the downtown core and I wanted
to know that we had more roads closed
internally than we had the weekend
before but I never publicly in the media
and I never in these meetings said get
the opp to close everything everywhere
and keep it closed
right that's uh that's helpful
introduction to my next question because
um there was a public announcement the
day before on the fourth right
um what's your best recollection as to
what was said at that uh uh press uh
event uh in terms of what was
contemplated
my best collection was around the
concept of all options are on the table
we are looking at greater levels of road
closures including Highway off-ramps and
inter-provincial bridges
but would you agree that the purpose of
the meeting on the fifth was to
establish the resources required
in order to carry out these priorities
not at all sir I wanted to ensure that
the resources that had been said that
would be in place were actually going to
be in place right so uh we could have
misunderstood but let's see if we could
clarify this if I could take you to your
interview summary
WTS 6040
at page 27
if we go down further
actually if you scroll up a little bit
sorry
right there on February 4th Chief slowly
announced at a press conference that the
Ops would be making greater use of road
closures including closures of off-ramps
for Highway 417. there's no statements
there saying that we're going to close
everything no no that I I agree with you
on that but that's uh the the
announcement but I'm asking you about
the purpose of the meeting on the 5th
the morning meetings so if we go to this
paragraph that says Chief slowly saw the
situation report early on the morning of
February 5th in response he held several
early morning meetings to ensure that
Ops is search and enforcement strategy
and efforts to harden the downtown core
were proceeding properly
he wanted to ensure that Ops had the
Staffing to implement what it had
announced on February 4th
specifically he sent inspector dayu an
email with a list of meeting topics and
asked him to organize a meeting with the
members of the IC I believe that's
instant command
and the command team
so and and so it goes so am I correct
that on the fifth this meeting was
arranged in part to ensure that the Ops
had the Staffing to implement what he
had already announced today before
[Music]
yes but the plan was already to have
those staff in place I wanted to make
sure they were actually available a lot
can happen in 24 hours potentially
without me knowing The Incident
Commander could have developed a plan
that was going to take resources away
from those commitments if they had said
we can't staff your surge in enforcement
because we've got all those neighborhood
officers doing something else or we had
a shooting in the West End last night
and it's an extensive scene and we can't
redeploy our traffic to that that I
would have understood we couldn't staff
what we planned but we weren't trying to
figure out just then if we had the
Staffing for what we had announced that
is not correct
as a best practice would would it not be
preferable to First ensure that Ops had
the resources before announcing uh
announcing these plans publicly
I was told we had the resources sir
all right but you agree with me that it
would be it might be problematic to make
announcements when it turns out that the
resources are not there or for other
reasons the actions cannot be carried
out because it might contribute to a
loss of public confidence if that was
the case and clearly there was no
understanding that the resources were
available and reasonably predictably
going to be available that would be
problematic that was not the case in the
situation
okay
so we've covered the events on the
fourth
and on the fifth
um
now the general priorities and we go
back to the email on the fifth
we've looked at the general priorities
Mr collector you need the document
number
um
Ops 307355
so I've already asked you achieve slowly
about the general priorities
I want to ask you now about the location
priorities which is further down there
we go
so there are four locations listed
Confederation Park Rito
I take it that this refers to the
intersection Rito and Sussex
I believe so sir yes uh third is
Wellington and then fourth is sjam
um who set these priorities the general
and the location priorities
so those were the locations where a red
zone
redo Wellington and sjammer the three
basic Footprints of the of the Red Zone
those were established I believe Through
The Incident Commander up through Trish
Ferguson she was the first that I recall
hearing about the red zone and the
footprints were described to me in
subsequent meetings from probably the
Sunday through till now
a confederation Park as I advised I
think that started up somewhere around
the Thursday I might be mistaken but
Wednesday Thursday Friday but certainly
had escalated to a significant event for
us to be managing on the Thursday night
Friday into the weekend
so those weren't my priorities those
were already priorities established by
virtue of the briefings I was getting
the situation reports that were coming
into me
are you speaking now of just the
location priorities or does that apply
as well to the general priorities
I'm sorry what general priorities are
maybe the the previous list if we scroll
up
the three points
well
we were dealing with a demonstration so
that's literally the entire fear of
operations number two surge containing
in force was to address the trauma
impacting our communities
and shutting down the ability for this
thing to sustain itself again those are
just priorities that we've been working
on literally since the previous weekend
those aren't new priorities that's
essentially what we have been working on
well I uh perhaps I I'm not clear uh but
I my question is who set these
priorities or is your position that
shutting down fuel funds and fund these
are priorities known to everyone sorry
in terms of shutting down enabling
factors at a broad level that was
already well underway we had already had
established I think through Deputy Bell
and Christian you know contacts with the
city to try to shut down the GoFundMe I
may not be using the right terminology
but but not allow those funds to
continue to enable the ongoing
occupation of the city
um Diesel and propane and wood had
already been established through
briefing Cycles coming up to me as
priorities that The Incident Commander
and the team were working on and there's
lots of communication around that and
questions in public forums so that was a
very well established I would probably
agree the fun piece was something that I
had inserted in there but clearly had
become a significant problem and a
public trust problem and so if that's
probably be the only newer element but
already a well-established part of our
briefing cycles that we had been
discussing what about close everything
I've explained again I've explained with
the with the context that that was
misinterpreted and then clarified in the
meeting that happened subsequently but
who set that priority
the
the direction to close roads into
provincial Bridges and so on the
pre-planning document
then I don't what I don't understand is
I thought a moment earlier you said you
did step
you did cross
from strategic level to operational
level but for a good reason yes well
then let me further explain I'm not
enforced I'm not introducing new
priorities I am asking these are the
priorities that we've set
are we able to implement them we have a
plan
are we able to implement them do we have
the resources are we ready to go this
morning because we weren't ready to go
the last morning we did not have the
ability to have the resources to address
the level of surge coming into the City
and now we have additional priorities
that we've identified over the week I
wanted to make sure I'm not setting new
priorities I'm ensuring that we have the
resources to actually fully implement
the vernacular the heck out of the plan
that we have in place it's an excellent
plan
do we have the resources can we fully
and effectively implement
that's my mindset going into the meeting
that's why I've called that meeting
okay uh so just so I understand your
position is that whoever developed a
plan the plan that kept evolving
they decided the priorities you didn't
set anything new except for the third
point the fun part
even that sir I would suggest clearly we
were already aware of the issue of the
bouncy castles and the DJs and the
dancing and the fireworks that was
that's a very short list of all the
things that were afflicting the
neighborhoods in and around the red
zones open barbecues
um people blocking Lanes tearing masks
off people's face I could I could go
down the list and detail the incredible
range of assaultive type Behavior but
the broad thing is shut down these
enablers and let's not allow our city to
look like it's a theme park in the
middle of a of a public safety crisis I
hadn't introduced anything more than
articulate the obvious and these were
briefings that I was being given for
days in advance of me calling this
meeting
all right and another point to clarify
uh because you told us earlier that this
is not the plan that this is not this
email these priorities are not the plan
that you thought was excellent there was
another plan the one that has evolved so
I want to take you there's only one plan
sir the one plan that kept evolving uh I
want to take you to a document and see
if you can confirm that was the plan uh
as of this time could we go to Ops four
zeros 6941
so it says Freedom Convoy Canada Unity
phase two operational plan it was a date
that's partially cut off February 4th it
looks like
if we scroll down
to the table of contents perhaps
does this look familiar
the basic template of our operational
planning
we go down further maybe we can just
scroll through so the former Chief can
can familiarize himself with this
document
let us know if you're ready to scroll
down yes please do
okay thank you
so with those priorities be reflected
well assuming that this is the the plan
uh because this is this the cover says
February the fourth and we have the
email saying February the 5th it should
be proximate in time sure so when you
said we had an excellent plan
could were you referring to this plan I
don't know if I was referring to this
plan I don't know for another iteration
I don't ever received it but at whatever
point I was last briefed on our plan
that's the point of reference that I'm
making on the Saturday the 5th right and
should those priorities general or
location wise be reflected in this plan
again unless there's sub plans that have
those priorities identified in there I
can't recall ever receiving or reading
through this version of of the plan
but you have have read a version of the
plan that you called excellent I have
been briefed on versions of plan you'll
recall I only got the pre I only got the
pre-operational plan on the 28th two
days technically into what the event was
so I wasn't required to sign off on
these plans there's no signature block
for me I'm not I'm not approving plans
they're happening on a real-time basis
so I don't have a time stamp in my head
that I saw a document at point zero and
said that's the excellent plan the
briefing cycles that I've been getting
I have an understanding of what the
priorities are how they're being
resourced how they're being going to be
action what what requests for resourcing
is coming to me but that's based on a
briefing cycle not me sitting and
flipping through pages of a plan and
saying wow this is excellent this is the
one we have to implement so just to be
clear the initial plan the one dated
January 28th that one you did read yes
it was delivered to me the morning of
the 28th and any subsequent evolvement
of that plan you learn about those
developments through briefings but not
through your reading them with the
exception of the February 9th version
right
so as of the fifth when you describe an
excellent plan is an excellent plan that
you haven't read
it's an excellent plan based on the
briefings I can't recall whether or not
this was sent to me
okay
um so if we move on uh to
the next topic
which is something that you've alluded
to the
the the event commanders they're they're
some switching of commanders and at the
beginning of the event you weren't
always a prize of those changes in a
timely manner so I like to ask you about
that let me find the page reference
Ops 4004771
.
so you see that this is dated January
the 30th is an email from you to um
deputy chief Ferguson deputy chief Bell
who's John Steinbach he's the executive
was at that point the executive director
of Communications and strategy
and then it was also sent to Russ Lucas
and Chris rayon so I assume that that
was because uh superintendent realm was
the event Commander at the time
that's my understanding sir
now um
according to superintendent rayon's
notes he was removed as the event
Commander
on around February the 1st
because
um Trish Ferguson the deputy chief
Ferguson
um received direction from you to remove
him is that correct no it's absolutely
false right so that's what I I wanted to
clarify because we actually heard from
deputy chief Ferguson that he was
removed for other reasons but we do have
these notations in superintendent
William's notes that's why I want to
bring those to your attention if we
could go to document I was told by
acting Deputy Ferguson that the switch
for Dunlop was because
my recollection was because inspector
Lucas needed some time off he was tired
I may have misinterpreted that maybe it
was Chris rione but that's my
understanding that there was a temporary
switch to give somebody days off to go
and sleep basically
I gave no direction whatsoever at any
time for superintendent rayon to be
removed from his role as event Commander
okay but we do have notes from uh
superintendent rayon so first I want to
take you to two sets of notes uh can I
see those notes yes that's what I'm
taking you to so Ops three zeros one
four five three seven
I believe it's page five
so um
1930 which day would that be is the
first or this it would be the first I
believe because the next the date after
the line is February the second we can
go back and check uh the the date might
have been on the first page actually so
can we go back to the first page to
establish the date
or the second page I guess
oh no okay so keep going down
all right so this is
page two of seven is February 1st now we
scroll down
that's right
that's the next page
I was informed by deputy chief Trish
Ferguson
to report to duty tomorrow at Green bank
and to take care of my teams
no reason why I was removed from ncrcc
and that I am no longer the event
Commander so the notation on this date
suggests that he was removed and he
didn't understand why
now if we go to page six
go down a bit
okay so now we have his notes on
February the 10th
and the notation says advised by acting
deputy chief Ferguson that Chief slowly
had me remove by her on February the 1st
so it appears from these notes
that he was removed on the first not
told why and then there's a notation on
the 10th that giving him the reason that
he was in fact removed by her
uh well through her by you
um so I just wanted to to get your
position on what happened absolutely
false never never gave that direction
so in fact you were not aware that he
was removed I was again I understood
from my recollection and I don't know if
there's notes to support my recollection
is hearing that inspector Lucas was very
tired he had been gone through the
entire planning cycle and had survived
through that first weekend and he had
requested time off and it was for him
that superintendent Dunlop was replacing
I don't recall a reference to
superintendent realm I don't have no
recollection whatsoever of any
conversation in which it was suggested
to me or I directed that superintendent
realm be removed as the event Commander
right zero okay now if we go could go
back it's very concerning that it's
articulated in that way
uh well that's why I want to bring these
uh to your attention so you have a
chance to to respond
um Ops three zeros one four four eight
four
and if we can go to page 10 please
so uh these are notes to yourself again
foreign yes yes sir stated February the
5th
title is meet with
acting deputy chief Ferguson and DC Bell
I advise that I had only just officially
heard the superintendent Dunlop had
replaced inspector Lucas
as The Incident Commander at the
previous briefing
so you just learned on the fifth
that uh
Dunlop is now the commander and sorry
again here's the confusion for me
because
either in that meeting or before
Ferguson said sorry acting Deputy
Ferguson said
Lucas needed time off we brought Dunlop
in so that's why I'm referring to Lucas
not ryom here in my mind my notes
contemporaneous notes are
Lucas got replaced why why didn't you
tell me I had no idea about the rione
piece I had no idea about why he was
removed I had no idea he was removed my
only contact was Lucas was removed and
that was surprising for me yes I I'm not
challenging your version I'm just trying
to to understand from your perspective
just what happened because it was pretty
confusing when we're trying to go
through the record
um as you can imagine uh the next
paragraph DC Bell advised that he was
the new Incident Commander installed
this week referring to Dunlap and was
leading the implementation of the
preferred Pou option
I asked why I was not advised of the
change in The Incident Commander
from inspector Lucas to superintendent
Dunlop acting deputy chief Ferguson took
ownership of that failure to communicate
and DC Bell admitted it was based on his
recommendation
I counseled acting deputy chief Ferguson
that she was accountable for all
Incident Command Decisions so I hold
responsible for this change and for not
advising me of the change I Council that
DC Bell that he's to stop interfering in
acting Deputy Chiefs Ferguson's role as
major Incident Commander I Council both
such major changes in the leadership of
the instant command was to come to me
for final approval outside of
operational exigencies I advise both
that I did not have confidence in
superintendent Dunlop as The Incident
Commander based on his performance at
the panda game and so on so I just want
to
clarify a number of things first when
superintendent realm as the event
Commander was replaced by Jamie Dunlop
on or around the 1st of February you had
no knowledge of that until on around the
fifth
even on the fifth I don't think I
realized what had happened to Rio
right but you did not understand that
the event Commander is now Dunlop you
did not know that until the fifth yes
sir and that was concerning for you
extremely you addressed a situation with
both Ferguson and Bell
um and that is because as the chief
executive you need it to know
I needed to know who was running our
operations
so what effect of any did that incident
have on your trust of your team your
command team
he was a massive trust hit tell us about
that
I think it's pretty clear honestly
we're in the middle of what is now I
consider a national security crisis my
opinion doesn't have to be held by
others certainly a local public safety
crisis and one of if not the most
important functions is The Incident
Commander
the major Incident Commander event
Commander Incident Commander that that
is my entire understanding of the
leadership capability and capacity to
orchestrate all of what needs to be done
across the incident command system just
so that we can continue to provide
adequate effective policing that is a
major level change
and one that was made without any
consultation any communication to me and
one that appeared to have been
kept secret from me until literally it
came up in the briefing meeting that I
had called
I don't even know if to if to this day
that I didn't call that briefing meeting
that I wouldn't have known about it
until the Sunday the Monday or the
Tuesday
what's also materially important here if
you scroll back up please
right there
I asked why I was not advised sorry
he was the new Incident Commander
installed this week and was leading the
implementation this is Dunlop was
leading the implementation of the
preferred Pou plan
Supreme Dental Dunlap was not at the
February 1st meeting in Canada that two
hour plus meeting where we had that
discussion around where are we now and
how can we get out of this
he was not a part of the discussion of
the public order unit commanders who
were expert in that area
how could he have been replaced to lead
this if he wasn't part of that essential
meeting
I left explicit instructions and it and
it was in the notes that you showed
earlier if you need anything more from
me if you need to clarify I'm available
to you this is clearly one of the most
important things that I've asked Trish
Ferguson and her incident command team
who were there represented as fully as
they could be Lucas couldn't attend you
recall for whatever reason
this is critical I need a a set of
options in three days before the weekend
events come and somehow in that time
frame without me understanding or even
knowing
switch of that magnitude was made and
then put in charge of the planning for
that
I was expecting a briefing on
I finally got a briefing later in the
afternoon on the fifth of those three
options
could it have meant I could have had a
briefing on the Wednesday or the
Thursday
possibly and could that have meant that
we could have started two days three
days four days earlier
to actualize that scale of operations
including making the request for the
public order commanders on scale that I
was told on the on the February 1st
meeting
we lost time and clearly there was a lot
of confusion even this note demonstrates
I'm still not quite sure who's running
what and for a chief of police
with the citizens in in the trauma and
victimization that they were under our
own members as struggling as they were
at best I can call this a significant
lack of judgment on behalf of my two
operational deputies
at worst
probably this would have been a review
that I would have done after
the events had concluded and looked at
it even more closely
did your level of trust in your two
deputies change
from that point on
yes
did they regain your trust afterwards
significantly but at that point it was
low
um and to support some of the other
things that you've said can we go to Ops
three zeros14479
while that document's building being
pulled up uh commissioner I would just
know it's Paul chant for the record
um just taking a look at the testimony
of deputy chief Ferguson it wasn't put
to her by any witness about uh whether
she had been directed by a former Chief
slowly to remove
a superintendent rayon from that
position so I'm just just noting for the
record that that we don't we don't have
any other evidence on that in the
background thank you
I believe my friend is correct I think
she simply said the reason she believed
uh he was removed but she wasn't uh
given this document
yeah we just took the transcripts and
confirm that thank you
so um
if we can go to page
67
.
do you see the notation
the chief began by saying
we floundered last week
and because we switched Riders part way
can read the next word true I believe
right
through
perhaps you're better at reading this
can you help us I don't know if I'm
better sir but what I can read here the
chief began by saying
we floundered last week and because we
switched we had switched writers part
way through
something the switch between ryom and
Dunlop to indicating indicating the
switch between Rome to Dunlop to
Patterson the chief and the team will
not change any of the players
until the operation is over unless
Bill gets hit with a
truck
I don't know what that means
uh well that comment was supposedly
attributed to you
I never used that term in my life so I
don't know what that means
Bill Gets Hit who's Bill but apart from
that phrase uh on the last line do you
agree that this was the message
communicated
um
on this day which I believe is
February the 9th
um these are her interpretations of what
was communicated so I don't agree with
no no but I'm asking for your
recollection if anything was said of
that nature on February the 9th so of
that nature we will not be changing out
any of the major incident command
positions unless there's issued
circumstances if it's three o'clock in
the morning and someone
got hit by a truck
and you got to switch switch tell me in
the morning at the first early
opportunity or call me because I had a
standing position that any major issue I
could be woken up out of bed for a phone
call operational officer safety issue or
a major issue like this you can call me
and they all knew that
so but other than that the team we have
the plan we have implement the heck out
of it right you you expressed a view
that
um things were delayed because of this
unfortunate miscommunication or what for
what what for whatever reason uh the
lack of communication of the change to
you or to seek your approval first no to
be clear things were delayed things were
confused there was a churn of three
incident commanders within a way too
short period of time yes some of that
might have resulted in delays I can't
tell you specifically it felt to me that
the POU plan was delayed because of
dunlop's insertion and his need to get
up to speed and his then
reinterpretation of things that's about
the only thing I can point to that was
materially delayed I don't know if
there's any other material delays but
the confusion was clear this is also
around the same time I believe
that we're starting to get some concerns
that are articulated from the opp that
there's confusion with the incident
command team I recall a phone call from
commissioner Creek in this period where
he was saying my folks are saying there
seems to be some confusion with your
incident command team
I took that to mean what was happening
in this circumstance and that's why on
February 9th when the integrated command
team sorry integrated planning team was
coming in for their briefing that we
weren't going to do this to ourselves
again
so do you remember saying something
about
floundering the week before because of
the switching Commanders
I might have used a term like that yes
okay that's helpful and you talked also
about the discussions around not across
the board that's not a pejorative term
we're floundering around the incident
command switch rights precisely
and you mentioned pot was discussed
around this time too
um well okay let me take you to uh
uh where I I want to go
um
I want to talk to you about the use of
PLT in fact I think we may be going back
in time
um because this is uh this these notes
were made um
on the 8th or 9th and uh this is a
discussion about the week before whether
things were delayed the week before so
I'm going back to the the week before
we've all heard about the
Coventry
incident I believe you know what I'm
referring to I believe I do but I'll let
you carry on right so
um
specifically the PLT was involved with
some successes and challenges during
that first week uh do you agree so for
example
um we we've heard about Coventry we've
also heard about Confederation Park
and would you consider
the plt's involvement
at the Confederation Park the clearing
of the conversion Park to BSS I want to
significantly contributed to yes
so I want to get your perspective on the
role of the PLT within the operational
um
system because we've heard from
different Witnesses about these
diverging approaches
um emphasis being put on enforcement as
opposed to
engagement
so to speak and we've heard evidence
that you and perhaps Mark Patterson
superintendent Patterson
at the time during that week of what one
witness has described as ad hoc
enforcement periods that the two of you
were favoring more enforcement in
contrast to Deputy Ferguson and Bell who
were more in favor of pot I'm sorry
that's a long Preamble but do you get
what I was trying to to I understand
that there's been a theme around that I
come back
um from my earliest days as a in
training as a public order unit
commander and in all of my times as a
public order Incident Commander Incident
Commander Major Incident Commander Duty
operations Commander the use of
engagement Community engagement
pre-juring all the way through even in
the restoration phase has been something
I was trained to and done and did in
both police services that I had to honor
to be part of Toronto Police Service and
the Ottawa Police Service
while the PLT program expanded from an
RCMP OPP kind of technique to broader
to other police services I for that most
part I was out of policing at that time
left the Toronto Police Service and was
a partner at Deloitte I came back into
the Ottawa Police Service and the term
police liaison team was a new term to me
but their function was not new at all to
me I had deployed such tactics seen them
work effectively and less effectively
and fail but always had that approach
come back out of incident command and I
know I'm going too fast
come back out of incident command the
concept of community engagement is
something that I had been
championing for and had done at multiple
levels for multiple decades there isn't
anyone in God's green earth that would
have to convince me of the necessity and
the value of community engagement trust
building negotiation mediation
de-escalation in any aspect of policing
not the least of which an insulin
command critical incident command
I have never in my entire life as a
police officer certainly as I became a
senior officer and executive and chief
of police have advocated for more
enforcement over anything else my record
in the public is exhaustive on that
the operational plans I led in the
Toronto Police Service when I had four
thousand officers under my control
responsible for anti-gang activities
always had a significant element of
mediation negotiation and engagement I
built the Toronto police neighborhood
uh policing you uh uh strategy and
brought that here to Ottawa so this
concept of Peter slowly as being some
sort of
Ultra enforcement driven focused leader
is a narrative that someone has
constructed to attack my character but
Bears no resemblance whatsoever to my
actual record in policing including my
time as chief of police here in Ottawa
including the three weeks that I was in
charge of the Ottawa Police Service
during these events
is it fair to say then that the view
attributed to you
as less inclined to allow the pot team
to do his work and to prefer quick uh
quick win as one witness has described
it by
by enforcement methods that is
inaccurate I did talk about quick wins
as I do literally in every major
operation or administrative project you
need quick wins I think that's just
basically standard around to do
something different you need to prove
you can do it different and it builds
morale and confidence in that concept
quick wins was my contribution to that
and I didn't get any sense that there
was a wrong or misunderstood
contribution what unfortunately has
happened is that has been tied by
someone or some people for some reason
unknown to me to mean that PLT could not
or should not be used or could not and
should not be used properly or worse
that somehow I had to approve every
single PLT action otherwise it could not
occur and that is a complete fabrication
and a lie
um and just to clarify your attitude on
the role of the PLT
um so let's go to the next document and
see if you can Enlighten us Ops three
zeros
Ops 304568
now just to give you the contacts I
believe these are the notes of Staff
Sergeant Ferguson
not deputy chief Ferguson staff sergeant
Ferguson who was the the lead of the pot
team at the Ops
sorry just for correction John was
brought in part way through the events
to provide additional supports and
Leadership to the PLT but that wasn't a
function he had beforehand right that's
a that's a decision that I was aware of
and fully supported yes
um for Council does that Ops
30s14568 yes
and if we can go to page 15 please
we enlarge
so
um
I believe the date is February 5th but
we can confirm if uh if we need to
um
so do you see Chief slowly hear the
notation that says continue to negotiate
pot doing a great job need more of them
train
so maybe we should screw up just to give
the witness some context
this is February 5th
uh we can go scroll further up okay so
it's February 5th
so it's a conference called critical
incident command
um we go further down
go down
I thought there was a reference to the
chief briefly
reference to what that it was uh the
chief uh who's well it's further up
there's a right okay so
um Chief slowly do you remember
um
congratulating or
encouraging the team
I don't know he was doing a good job
sorry to interrupt I don't have a
specific recollection but I I on
literally a daily basis that would have
been a comment that came from me so I'm
glad it was captured by John Ferguson
I'm glad I said that because they
probably deserved it based on the
success of Confederation Park I don't
have an explicit recollection
but there are other occasions when uh
when we see notations in other people's
notes not with regard to this incident
but PLT or negotiation more generally
when the the comments are a little more
ambiguous so I want to get your help uh
in in Illuminating that I want to take
you to another document Ops three
zeros14454
um
if we go to page 55
so we're now on February 5th if we go
down
can we go back up please
yeah
because I may have the wrong reference
moments induction
okay
um I don't want to waste anyone's time
let's move on to another document
foreign
can we go to page 32 same document
so here there's a notation what is our
trajectory
and then there are two branches
enforced
enforced end
or a negotiated occupation end
need to take a decision today
um
February the 3rd sorry whose notes would
these be and I believe these are notes
taken by the legal services okay
so and sorry what time or what what's
what's I'm not sure we have the time we
just have the date
which is February 3rd
if you want to scroll up we can see if
we can find out more
but that's redacted so that's that's not
helpful
um so we're left with these notes uh it
may be that you cannot help us
um with more information but I thought
I'll try do you recall anything
discussed along these lines on the third
can I don't know how many meetings I
would have had on the third I what do
you have a sense of what this is a
morning meeting is this an afternoon
meeting
unfortunately the contacts uh we don't
have much to to guide us on on these
pages so I'll just leave this and and
move on to the Coventry uh incident
um
oh
okay so I have a new note uh let's try
page 59.
same document page 59.
if we go to the bottom please
right here
so here there's a notation this is again
on on February the 5th uh the notation
that says negotiation gives us
legitimacy to use Force if negotiation
fails I take neg to to refer to
negotiation you can it's not my it's not
my handwriting so no these are the I
would assume so yes Legal Services
um but PS I take it uh refers to
to your initials yes sir
um do you recall any discussions around
it the use of negotiation as a way to
give the police legitimacy to use Force
should it fail well
somebody's interpretation in every in
every aspect of policing a measured
approach is the preferred approach from
our use of force train uh Continuum
through to incident command
communication negotiation de-escalation
risk mitigation is the preferred route
and if you can't demonstrate you did it
even for a second even if you had a
second of opportunity if you can't
demonstrate that you attempted to do
that then you have less legitimacy
around your decision to use force that
would be the context in which I'm
talking about it what I am not saying
here to be clear is let's just pretend
to negotiate while we put on the armor
and go in there and hurt people I would
never say that
and if anyone suggests otherwise they
would have misunderstood your view on
the matter
it would be really hard to understand
how they could misunderstand that but
that would be the most charitable thing
I could say right now we spoke earlier
about this assess at the Confederation
Park the involvement of the PLT
now we want I want to take you to the
the event involving Coventry uh that is
that didn't go so well did it
for the PLT
well thank you for that clarification
um
from my limited understanding of it
there was a lot of moving Parts there
in the net I'm still not sure whether as
a whole it Advanced our operations
um
it certainly caused again confusion and
contention among key elements of it and
demonstrated that we were not at the
level of
maturity and optimal alignment around
these things but some good things did
did occur as well
what good thing occurred in your in your
in your view this was part of the change
to the transition from the the pre-plan
into an a new phase of involving more
attempts to stop fuel coming into the
location we had just I think that week
had the success of at least temporarily
ending the GoFundMe piece we were
starting to see some effect from the
efforts of of addressing unlawful and
unruly behavior in our neighborhoods we
were starting to get a sense of what the
priorities are we had the Confederation
Park win I would call that a full win
largely through PLT which I've talked
about so we were starting to
show that we could aim at a priority at
a problem and an objective and get a
material result out of it not just be
paralyzed into complete reactive
immobilized periods of time which we had
suffered in the first 72 hours so for me
this was a sign that we were starting to
get somewhere towards the front foot
rather being completely on the back foot
so while I would completely agree it was
a challenge for the PLT and a
substantive one and I won't in any way
change the commentary that others have
brought to it but to suggest that it was
a complete failure I can't agree to that
um as I understand it the issue was not
so much whether it was legitimate to
seize fuel or to prevent people from
taking fuel downtown uh as
superintendent uh Bowden explained that
wasn't the issue the issue was
for the PLT team
to tell the protesters that
something is okay
um
that uh but but then to turn around and
arrest people when they take the few
away that's the problem that's leading
to mistrust between the pot
and the protesters do you agree
and I I don't want to
be obtuse on this that level of detail I
was never aware of
after the fact
why didn't that happen the morning I'm
briefed on it didn't happen I have no
idea if it happened or didn't happen I
think one of my complaints is
I actually didn't get a call the night
before to say it wasn't going to happen
so I don't know what was said by what
PLT member to who what promise was made
I have no level of understanding even to
this day what the PLT log notes say that
they told them and versus what happened
I've heard repeated descriptions of what
took place and even to this day I'm
still quite not quite sure what the
sequence of events was clearly though I
am aware that there was a significant
departure from the optimal way that PLT
should be utilized and it had a major
impact on the plt's abilities to move
forward that I am aware of and I'm
confident enough in that evaluation and
that's why you will see even more after
this point I'm requesting additional PLT
expertise from commissioner Creek I'm
reinforcing PLT and the need for it to
be properly utilized literally at every
meeting that happens after this
um just so we're on the same page it may
be helpful if I take you to
the interview summary of Staff Sergeant
Ferguson if we can go to WTS
six zero two seven
please at page eight
so he provided a description of what
happened that day I I like to read that
to you and then get your thoughts on it
so at 4 40 pm on February the 6th
superintendent Patterson advised staff
sergeant Ferguson that Pou was going to
Coventry Road and would be seizing fuel
for evidentiary purposes at that time
pot had been at Coventry Road for at
least two hours engaging with protesters
staff sergeant Ferguson informed
superintendent Patterson that pot was
negotiating with protesters and that
they were compliant but superintendent
Patterson indicated that he intended to
proceed with the public order operation
staff sergeant Ferguson attempted
unsuccessfully to convince others in Ops
not to proceed with the public order
operation at Coventry Road at 5 PM
inspector Marin reiterated
superintendent Patterson's direction to
start Sergeant Ferguson that they did
not want the fuel from Coventry Road to
be displaced and that they were
proceeding without warrant at 5 10 pm
staff sergeant Ferguson contacted deputy
chief Bell and advised him that the
enforcement operation would undermine
plt's negotiations which had been
proceeding for at least two hours
stop Sergeant Ferguson informed deputy
chief Bell the protesters were compliant
shortly after the call ended at 5 18 PM
deputy chief Bell contacted staff
sergeant Ferguson and informed him that
he agreed with superintendent
Patterson's decision
later that evening staff sergeant
Ferguson learned that deputy chief Bell
supported superintendent Patterson's
decision because three Convoy Vehicles
had left the Coventry Road site and were
transporting fuel to supply protesters
downtown in a nutshell that's what
happened do you have any view on what
transpired there and any thoughts on how
these kind of problems or troubles could
have been avoided
um
well
if if that is accurate again it's one
person's account but for the purpose of
there's so many problems in this
paragraph beyond the PLT
Sergeant Ferguson contacting deputy
chief Bell sorry staff sergeant Ferguson
contacting deputy chief Bell makes no
sense to me
why is that deputy chief Bell is not in
charge of operations in any way on
February 6. that is that is an internal
incident command contact out
is all of a sudden in the middle of PL
World he's likely not aware of the
larger intelligence and the larger frame
of operations that superintendent
Patterson is even superintendent
Patterson is probably 24 hours into his
job so there's a lot of people who've
been all of a sudden moved into
different positions after a period of
Realm Dunlop Patterson
there's a lot of confusion happening at
this point this is clearly an Evidence
of a sub-optimal system trying to write
itself people try
and people trying to get help but going
up the command and the wrong chains of
command getting involved in areas that
they shouldn't be getting involved in if
this is accurate Deputy Bell should have
contacted Deputy Ferguson there's a
concern from PLT I'm making you aware of
it can you manage that back down that
would have been more appropriate
so there's a lot of things happening in
here it's on the basis of one
individual's
concept and that's an individual who's
probably relatively new into their
position and has never been trained on
PLT
so which one problem you're talking
about yeah that big long paragraph for
them I know which one who who wasn't
trained on Piet my understanding is that
John Ferguson was a trained and
excellent crisis negotiator right but
was never trained on PLT as a police
liaison officer that's my understanding
I stand to be corrected right so um to
summarize we have confusion uh regarding
the command structure who should be
reporting to whom about what you're
giving us the example of Staff Sergeant
John Ferguson seeking Direction from
Bell I suspect John's substantive
position is under Deputy Bell's command
and so in his brain
if I have a problem I escalate it to my
Deputy I'm I'm assuming that right
that's the only reason logical reason
why he would he would go to deputy chief
Bell and not go go through
Patterson
deputy chief acting deputy chief
Ferguson to get a resolution to the
problem that he's facing and there were
a lot of movement from one unit to
another for a lot of people during those
periods
um and uh that the fact that the event
commanders has changed a few times
Patterson being the third Commander also
didn't help
um what about the the
what about the the fact that the the PLT
and the enforcement arm which we learn
were the two sides of a the command
triangle uh what about the fact that
they didn't seem to be coordinating
their actions in carrying out their
respective UH responsibilities is that a
big concern it's a big concerns for and
again I I reiterate I I this is an
Ottawa Police Service
that its PLT program was a part-time
program
the PLT officers I had approved them to
get training I think in the late summer
early fall of 2021
so they're a part-time group of people
who within six months get some training
we're still in covid I don't know how
many times they've been able to utilize
that training in any substantive way
before the arrival of this massive
unprecedented event
and then they're literally asked to do
the impossible
from the beginning to the end and do the
best job they possibly can but no there
isn't an optimal optimization within
this incredible unprecedented event
between that command triangle there
isn't
and even with the extra help that we got
from the opp and the arrival of experts
like uh inspector we weren't going to be
able to flick a switch and all of a
sudden go from Ops
immaturity to OPP Excellence within the
Dynamics of what's taking place in real
time in the city of Ottawa so without
any unrealistic expectation of flicking
a switch what are your thoughts on what
we can do better in terms of avoiding
this kind of troubles
um what can we learn from all of this
well first of all again commissioner
with your
the the incident command system
I had the honor and pleasure in I think
2000 8 2009 along with
um
Mike mcdadell then of the RCMP and
um
Sullivan Sewell Sullivan who was then a
deputy chief here in the Ottawa Police
Service
all of us have been trained up on the
incident command system we believe that
that was the appropriate incident
command system for the types of
demonstrations we were seeing in the
news in the new century I hate to make
myself sound old but that's what we were
back then
um and we had made presentations to the
Ontario Association of chiefs of police
that to avoid integration challenges we
should have a standard incident command
approach
across the province we were able to get
the oacp executive to adopt that and
that became through that process I want
to say the standard because I can't say
for sure it's written into the current
Police Service Act standards but that
became the default standard for incident
command across the province we attempted
to do the cacp level I got promoted and
I don't know where that ended up I now
know there's a national framework long
way of saying we're going to
increasingly have to bring large
organizations together how cross
potentially multiple sites we need to be
working off the same understanding
nomenclature processes we need to narrow
that gap of
of
a gray zone between strategic
operational and tactical I would suggest
we also need to narrow The Gray Zone
around a working incident command
structure as it sits into the regular
business of policing in any jurisdiction
or multiple jurisdictions
training needs to be standardized no
one's clature needs to be standardized
equipment needs to be standardized joint
training needs to happen and all of that
has to happen a long time before a major
unprecedented Paradigm shifting event
like what we just saw arrives in any
jurisdiction
this is one of those structural deficits
sir that have existed for decades in
policing
all require money but it's going to
require a little bit of investment on
that end but it requires an investment
of time and resources and focus and what
this event did to Ottawa to Ontario and
Canada was exposed that type of
structural deficit it's the same
concept of structural deficit around
intelligence gathering
we can't afford to duct tape our way
through these incidents anymore
and unfortunately this is this reads
like a duct tape effort to get through a
really complicated Dynamic situation
I need to be clear
every name here
did their best in the circumstances they
found themselves in I don't read into
anything here a deliberate attempt to
undermine or frustrate or cause risk to
the public
just didn't go off very well
thank you commissioner I note the time
we're past one o'clock would this be an
appropriate time to break
okay so we'll take the lunch break for
uh an hour and uh
come back to continue the
evidence thank you
the commission is in recess for one hour
foreign
foreign
foreign
Mommy
order a lot
the commission is reconvened
good afternoon commissioner at the
record Eric bruso commission Council
um very very briefly uh I just rise to
to give notice formally uh the documents
that the police team is bulk entering
this week
um my colleague Mr Mather sort of
explained the process on the record I
believe last week we circulated a list
last week we received objections those
documents have been removed from the
list and commission Council will deal
with those objections with the parties
the final list was circulated to the
parties this morning and those documents
will be marked as exhibits they are a
number of emails and other documents
from the Ops uh the opp the WPS Windsor
Police Service as well as a few RCMP
documents and city of Ottawa documents
and including
um
witness summaries for Witnesses who
importantly are not going to be called
to testify but whose evidence we wish to
put in by way of summary
okay thank you
so with that parenthesis
okay thank you
commissioner before I continue with the
examination
um just to clarify for the record uh
when I put the notes of superintendent
Rio to the former Chief slowly uh Mr
Champs correctly pointed out that uh
those notes were not put to
um deputy chief Ferguson in our
examination but she did In fairness to
her say both in her interview summary as
well as in her evidence
that superintendent realm was removed
for personal reasons he needed a rest or
some rest days so she did not say
anything about his removal being
connected to the former Chief I just
wanted that to be clarified on the
record okay
now Chief slowly just before the lunch
break we
spoke about a number of issues that I
also wanted to to clarify so that
there's no misunderstanding first of all
um I asked you about
the the date when you found out that uh
superintendent ryom was replaced by
superintendent Dunlop and I believe you
said that was on the 5th
of February now if I could take you to
uh a document I want to see if that
would refresh your memory Ops three
zeros 14484
.
so if we go to page two
so it appears that on the 3rd of
February these are again notes to
yourself
um on the 3rd of February at around well
in the morning you attended a meeting
with both deputies on teams with
superintendent Dunlop
what was your understanding as of the
Third
about
superintendent dunlop's role if he was
not the event Commander
thank you um
on the whole sir I wasn't sure what his
role was
um I had uh
understood that
staff sergeant Mike Stoll would be the
primary presenter of
the the analysis that came out of that
meeting on the first
a range of three options I've described
them but not necessarily accurately as
to what they would come back with
and and a preferred option including the
implications of resources etc etc
on the third if that's the Thursday that
would be the Thursday
there were two yes
there were two meetings uh one at 10 30
and then another one I think maybe
around 12 o'clock
where I was waiting for Mike Stoll to
give that presentation
um I think the notes indicate that
he wasn't available the presentation
wasn't on what I had asked for and I was
saying look I just want that
presentation that I'd asked for
so there are two I would call aborted
attempts to provide that on the Thursday
morning the first one around 10 30. the
next one around 12 o'clock or so if my
my mind is accurate finally the third
attempt which occurs on the afternoon I
think of the fifth the Saturday I get
the three options I get their preferred
option at that point
so
I'm still not sure even at this time
why Dunlop is Jamie Dunlop sorry
superintendent Dunlop
is involved in the presentation and what
his role in it is
my recollection I stand to be corrected
is he wasn't introduced as the interim
event Commander the event Commander
that's my recollection and my confusion
is based on that on that point
okay
the other thing that we spoke about was
with respect to the Coventry incident
and we were attempting to draw some
lessons from that event one of the the
issue you identified was the fact that
Staff Sergeant John Ferguson went
outside the incident command system when
he sought guidance from deputy chief
Bell
now if
stop Sergeant Ferguson
were if he had concerns about the
direction that he was getting from the
van Commander Mark Patterson
superintendent Patterson at that time
who should he have gone to
um
so uh while it was confusing again I
don't want to characterize it as he did
the wrong thing I just want to be clear
about that John Ferguson
there would have been options
um John could have gone to The Incident
Commander which
at this time should have been Russ Lucas
he could have gone to the event
commander and explained attempted to
further explain and if that wasn't
happening
he could have gone to the major event
commander in that case major Incident
Commander in that case would have been
acting deputy chief Ferguson so there
were options for him to engage
I understand it seems and he was doing
his best to get people engaged around
something he thought was important
but just so we understand
um superintendent Patterson was
inspector Lucas's Superior
if he was challenging a decision by
superintendent Patterson wouldn't it be
problematic for him to go to somebody
who reported
to superintendent Harrison
um
challenging but but still appropriate
there is an incident command chain of
command and then there's an
organizational chain of command
so at any point when there's a
disagreement in the chain of command if
done professionally if done timely and
if it's done seeking a constructive
outcome not for rumor mongering not for
undermining not for any other
Personal Agenda you can engage that
chain of command in trying to reach some
sort of a better outcome I think that
would be appropriate
now I understand from inspector Lucas's
interview summary that he sought by by
that time
[Music]
around 5th or 6th of February he had his
row had diminished to more akin to an
operations Chief at a technical level so
if
stop stop Sergeant John Ferguson had
issues about the operations is it not
arguable that he shouldn't have gone to
inspector Lucas
and I again I want to be careful I I
perceive that through through
information that's been presented at the
testimony myself I wasn't aware of that
so that's new information for me that
inspector Lucas's perspective on his
changed role is new information for me
if that was materially the case if that
was known to everybody and if it was
known to John Ferguson yes he would then
have an another challenge of who could
he turn to I would I would accept that
but this is all new information to me
too so it's just conjecture sorry
conjecture at this point to try to
answer your question sir and I I
appreciate that you're doing the best
you can we're also trying to understand
what lessons to draw from it and we just
don't want to draw the long lessons so
so the other option uh that you
identified was for uh staff Sergeant
John Ferguson to perhaps approach
um
uh deputy chief Ferguson because she was
by then the the major Incident Commander
but wasn't that also problematic because
they're married
at some risk to go into the realm of
conflict of interest and relationships
and organization I mean that's that's
that there is that challenge
um
um
but in in in the frame of the Ottawa
Police Service at that time there wasn't
any breach of policy and so it would
have been appropriate if he felt it had
again you know constructive objective
not unprofessional not undermining not
self-seeking to have sought the
intervention of or at least to provided
his information too
the major Incident Commander I I do also
recognize if I understand the context
as to what happened this is sort of a
real time unfolding event
it seems to be again and maybe maybe
wrong it seems to me that there wasn't
an opportunity for staff sergeant
Ferguson to wait for a briefing cycle to
raise the concern when all the people
would have been around the table
and then that would have allowed acting
Deputy Ferguson or even
uh superintendent Patterson to
reconsider
seemed like he was trying to get a
real-time decision in in the midst of an
operation so the third option would have
been to wait for a briefing cycle raise
it as part of the briefing cycle to try
to deconflict it and make it better
going forward I I don't think it was
appropriate in that circumstance right
so um because there are some
uncertainties about the circumstances we
shouldn't be too quick perhaps to
to I certainly can't be quick to judge
or or to to in any way attribute blame
but I think commissary goes back again
these are the these are the still it
still need to be developed areas
of
consistent across-the-board
understanding of incident command
systems within the operation of a
policing service that clearly here in
the Ottawa Police Service and other
jurisdictions we need to get to a higher
level there are examples of Excellence
across the across the country
I think we need to try to raise that
raise all boats in the harbor as high as
we can
thank you so let's move to a new topic
you've told us earlier that the Ottawa
Police Service was badly in need of
external help you needed more resources
to resolve the situation on the ground I
want to take you to a document
this is Ops 3014454
so you see that the document is stated
January 31st so this is the first Monday
after the arrival of the Convoy
and uh looks like it's a meeting with
the RCMP and the opp uh you were there
if we go down the pages
you see the notation can't safely remove
them unless we have hundreds of officers
to maintain
risk
and then if we go down further
we no way we can come by
not sure it's that word
four more days
without
something helped lots of help to help
was that the and then the next line says
now transitioned into an occupation
does this reflect the thinking uh at the
time on or about the 31st that
that the OPI Ops will need
um
hundreds of officers
in order to safely remove
the protesters yes sir
and then if we go to the next page
we need
sorry go down a bit oh sorry go down
oh go up sorry
we need resources and what is that next
word uh it looks like Communications
saying together join together at 3 pm
question mark do recall these
discussions at that meeting
yes I mean it specific lines not as
clear but I recall the meeting with
commissioner lucky
and I believe commissioner karik I don't
know who else would have been on the
call
and if we go down the page a little
there's a comment from Trish
um maybe go to the next page
here looking for boots on the ground
what did you understand her to me those
would be your sort of General General
Duty Officers traffic direction taking
it Taking a traffic point along the Red
Zone Patrol
um just general duty officers that could
be utilized in a variety of different
ways so do you understand the request at
that time was for General Duty Officers
from
from the RCMP and the opp well she she
outlined the other yeah that's that's
the running list that she was asked to
sort of
you know come up with on the spot I
think it's actually a pretty reasonable
list based on what we knew at that time
and where we were
and how did the Commissioners uh kirik
and lucky answered
well I can't we just go down
uh from
commissioner karik will facilitate all
of your requests and get embedded
in the command structure yes
so you had a commitment from
commissioner karik as of the 31st that
they would do all they could to to
assist and they were willing to embed in
the ops command structure and then
commissioner Lucky from the RCMP why did
negotiations fall through last night at
8 pm what what was that about what
negotiations
I'm not sure
I'm not sure what she's referencing
and then if we go further down there's a
comment attributed to you reach out to
you see got no and certain Quebec right
so you extended the ask
to gatino and certain as well yep
um
do you know what kind of help at this
time the opp and the RCMP we're offering
we know what you asked for but do you
remember what they were committed to to
providing
um
if I understand the question they had
already had resources in the theater
um
again I stand to be corrected by other
information that might come up RCMP I
believe had three what they call troops
public order units
in in the national capital region they
were not under our incident command
system control but they were available
in an emergency and they had certainly a
range of important duties
to manage
I believe at that point we still had OPP
public order units again not if I
understand correctly not under our
incident command supporting
parliamentary protection services but
again in the theater general area of the
theater
within what I would say within the
incident command system deployment there
were General Duty Officers
from the opp somewhere in the range of
30 40 50 again stand to be corrected on
numbers
as well as a range of other Municipal
Police service agencies contributions
London Police Durham Region Police
think Toronto might have been up at that
point
most of those Republic order unit
officers though as opposed to General
Duty Officers that's my recollection
around the January 31st okay if I could
take you to the next document which is
an email that you sent to commissioner
karik dated February the second the
document number is OPP four zeros one
five seven six
so um
this was sent February the second
on the first line
you see that
you wrote I'm seeking your assistance in
providing resources to assist the Ottawa
Police without operational plan
the subsequent bullets mentioned 50 to
60 uniform officers PLT and Pou supports
as well as instant command supports and
then the next lines talks about a
tactical dispatcher was so were these
the nature of the request yes so those
have been I'm assuming that that would
have been a refined list of requests
that I'd received from acting deputy
chief Ferguson who she had she had would
have received it through her incident
command chain of command now in
testimony yesterday from commissioner
karik he was asked about a formal
request and the implications of a formal
request under the police services act
section 9 subsection 6. just to be clear
your request here was that the kind of
formal request under the police services
Act
may not be understanding the question
sir sorry so it may help help if we take
you to the ACT uh
com
50819 you're familiar with the provision
I'm referring to right I'm not that
familiar with it so let's go to it uh
the act and look at it together
so this is the police services act if we
could go to page 12
. so under request of chief of police in
emergency
this is uh section 9 subsection six a
municipal chief of police who is I'm
just not seeing it on my screen am I
missing oh at the top
oh see okay sorry thank you sorry I
missed it do you see the heading request
of chief of police in emergency
um involved
so I I maybe I'm aware I'm I'm aware of
the language in the ACT but I wasn't in
my mind
referencing this if it happens to fit it
that's that's fine but that's my
question uh when you wrote the letter
you were not having in mind this section
I was simply sending a communication to
another Chief or commissioner asking for
resources
what do you understand to be the
difference of requests made
formally under subsection 9 6 or the
kind of informal request that you appear
to have sent
I will say I've never in my policing
career relied on this section so I don't
have a other than what's written on the
page
this would seem to be if we needed more
officers we could ask the our resources
we could ask the opp
but I I mean if this if if this is
intended to and again I'm not aware of
what's underneath it that this means we
can't manage we we can't adequately
effectively continue to be the police of
jurisdiction can you come and do this
for us I wouldn't interpret that that
way and that was certainly not the
intent of me sending that letter to OPP
commissioner karik to ask for those
resources
well that is uh that is where I'm going
uh because
um
Perhaps it is open to interpretation but
certainly one interpretation is that the
the opp had the ability
to step in and take the lead
um I believe there's certain conditions
that would have to be met they couldn't
just arbitrarily make that decision and
and that's why I'm asking you if a
request is made under this section would
you have been comfortable to let the opp
take more of a lead role uh under this
section if I felt the conditions in
Ottawa required that level of
intervention from the opp or any other
Police Service I would obviously be
making that request and therefore be
very comfortable with it subject to all
the usual discussions as to how that
would transpire but I was not making
that request you were not making that
request and I guess my my my question is
given the situation that you found the
Ops to be in
um shortly after the what you call the
paradigm shift after the first weekend
isn't that something that should have
been done logically not at all sir why
not
we were three days 72 hours into a
situation
I don't think anybody in Canada at that
time really understood what was going on
and I think it would have been
irresponsible
and unnecessary to burden another Police
Service
with that level of request
um
without having any real understanding
so I just don't think there's listen you
could talk to other police Chiefs and
they may have their opinions but as of
the 31st or the second when I sent that
letter that was not a situation that I
was considering at all that's not a
situation that anybody had raised to me
either within the Ottawa Police Service
or from the Police Services Board
not in the realm of considerations
did the situation in Ottawa escalate at
some point to a stage where you would
have considered that appropriate
not during my tenures or not
so in your view up until
mid-February
uh February the 15th was your last day
as the chief the situation was not
desperate enough in Ottawa to for the
chief to be requesting that kind of
assistance from the opp that's correct
sir
what would be the downside to
the opp stepping in when they had the
resources and if they were willing to
help the opp never had the resources
necessary sir
they could coordinate the resources and
they did a good job of that but the oppi
its own could not have come in and with
its totality of its complement provided
the full level of some 2 200 officers
that were required
well they alone might not have been
enough as we know
during the final days at both the opp
and the RCMP stepped in but certainly
the opp had more resources than the Ops
had at the time quantity of resources
while being a factor would not be even
in my humble opinion a significantly
weighted factor for such a decision as
for a chief of police in any
jurisdiction
to request through section 9 of the act
for another Police Service to come in
and run its Police Service
but in addition to quantity
they also seem to have the the right
expertise such as the as we'll come to
talk about it the the group led by Chief
party the integrated Planning Group they
had the expertise they had the capacity
they were willing to help they were
offering help why not there's a lot of
things they had and they offered those
things and we utilized them as quickly
and as effectively as we could and
ultimately through to my end of my
tenure and beyond that there was a very
successful outcome
but you've asked me before that the
circumstances in Ottawa rise to the
occasion of what I Now understand to be
the function of section 9 no they didn't
sir
right
um so this is the letter sorry the um if
we can take uh this off the the police
services act you remember we were we
looked at an email uh this one
uh that was your request I want to take
you to
another email that you sent on the
fourth so this request was sent on the
second on the 4th of February we have
another email
OPP four zeros1582
that's right uh this is the part I I
want to take you to you address this
email to commissioner sorry what's the
date of this please sorry
the 4th of February thank you
so you addressed this email to
commissioner karik you said once again
let me express my appreciation for the
significant and ongoing support that you
and your OPP team have provided to the
Ops over the course of the
demonstrations it would appear from this
reply that you received the additional
resources that you requested
um
short answer is yes I don't know if I
don't know if we got everything that we
asked for and when we got it but again
at this point I have no concerns
whatsoever
I think this is more just I'm I'm
actually seeing some of the most
well-turned out OPP officers and
Vehicles operating in and around my
sphere and they really just look good
they they were like the Cavalry coming
over the hill um and they were just
really well turned out really
professional group of officers so I'm
just complimenting Chief to commissioner
the quality of his people mm-hmm
um on the 2nd of February when you send
the request to the opp I believe you
also sent a request to the RCMP let's
take a look at PB dot NSC dot can
1.401743
so this is a
actually this is your reply
um
February 2nd thank you commissioner
lucky
if we go further down
that's right we see an email from her to
you
and at the bottom paragraph
sorry let's go up a bit uh the paragraph
that starts with at present at present
all of our public order units are
actively deployed and I'm not in a
position to be able to redirect any
teams to Ottawa do you have a do you
have a memory of what you were asking
for and and what this response was meant
to address
sorry just again the date is this
February
the second second
um so this again must be around the time
that we're we are
pivoting the plan we know we're going to
need this is the day after the February
1st Canada meeting
um we know we're going to need a
substantive amount of Pou short term and
long term and so this was the request
that I sent out to the RCMP for Pou at
least I don't know if there were other
things that we asked and it seems that
the substantive response here is you
know our Pou units are deployed
you can't get them reasonable I'm not
challenging back
um they're having their own resource
challenges
and they're exploring the possibility of
the of the other 50 resources I'm
assuming they're police officers but
there might have been a variety of
different knowledge skills and and and
abilities that we were asking for so
so these are examples of the kind of
early request uh following the paradigm
shift and the kind of responses you got
um on the 6th of February I understand
that you told the mayor and chair Deans
that you needed 1800 additional
resources am I correct
1790 odd but yes I think we've the
number 1800 has become the most
functionally used number
um let's go to the uh an Ops document
three zeros one four four five four
um page 98
foreign
so there's a reference here
1800 additional members
that came from other services
sorry the date of this weekend sir sorry
can we scroll up
okay February six thank you 5 10 pm
so am I correct that
um
that the number 1800 was communicated
um
as early as the 6th of February yes so
again just context wise uh there's an
emergency board meeting held on February
5th during that meeting in the public
session I received a direction from the
chair of the board to produce
a list of all the resources that we
thought we would need to my word safely
successfully lawfully and the events in
Ottawa
um
I needed explicit understanding from the
chair did she need that on the spot or
could we could could I and my team take
that away and then provide a more
thoughtful and full response and she
said yes
um
the team had I'd asked him to try to
turn that around in 24 hours and I think
by this time which is almost 24 hours
later we had a substantive list that was
drawn up and it wasn't just
police resources this also included
discussions around what other things
could the city help us with increased
bylaw fines other potential supports
from the city and Civil Society I think
we were looking at the short insurance
industry whether they could help us to
address some of the issues around the
the trucks and and vehicles so
that's the background to I think this
meeting
how did you derive the 1800 number
um again without the benefit of notes
but at some point after the board
meeting there would have been
um a request
at two levels within the incident
command system
for their planners to identify that the
number of types of resources and
Associate that to the the Rel the
overall operational plan and the
relative sections sorry subplan sections
than across the organization
I asked each of the functional command
areas so that would again include acting
deputy chief Ferguson in her functional
role
deputy chief Bell in his functional role
and chief Administration officer dunker
in her functional role to identify
supports the reason for the two sort of
coordinated requests we needed
a certain level of capability resource
capability predictability
within the incident command structure to
work under that structure to achieve
the goals of ending the events in Ottawa
but we were still struggling with
Staffing for our police of jurisdiction
responsibilities and I don't know if at
this time we'd finished the negotiation
with the Ottawa Police Association for
the shift schedule change but we were
struggling on both ends Staffing to a
level Beyond just maintaining the Red
Zone with through the incident command
piece and Staffing to maintain our
contractual obligations and help member
health and wellness requirements in the
general Police Services to the rest of
the million residents in the city
the sum total of those 1790 odd
resources reflects all of the different
aspects that we're looking for and they
were broken down
short-term midterm longer term
the bulk of the resources I would
suggest were more short term
a significant amount was midterm and
then a longer another amount would have
been long-term that would have been
assisting in prosecutions after the fact
case management crime crime analyst to
pull all that together but the bulk of
that request really was in in the days
and weeks as opposed to the months and
years portions of some of it
now I understand that later that day on
the 6th of February there was a command
team meeting where
um you asked your team about the
resource needs later on the sixth on the
sixth okay
is that a court with your recollection
again just so many different meetings if
you can show it to me I might have a
recollection and the commission has
heard evidence from superintendent
Abrams that he was present and overheard
some of the things that you said to your
team but not overheard he was uh he was
there he was invited to attend and the
next day he rode to his superiors
including Chris Harkins
um among others about what he observed
on the six so can we go to that email
foreign
if only I have the document number
op
p
opp401546 just for clarity searches
while the documents being searched
um my understanding against stand to be
corrected
I had a meeting with my command team on
the afternoon of the fifth after the
board meeting was over
where I was interrupted for part of the
meeting had to leave to go out for a
phone call and come back and it was in
that meeting I said looks we've just
gotten direction from the chair we need
to produce this over the next day start
thinking about what you need
this is a big lift that we're going to
have to do then on the six after my team
had worked through the night through the
day the number of 1790 odd was broken
out into various functions
so if supernatural's recollection of
that comment it should have been in my
memory on the fifth not on the sixth but
I stand to be corrected I could be off
on on the date
I I but the date of the email is not in
question the date of the email is the
seventh as you can see on the screen and
it was on the seventh that
superintendent Abrams wrote to his
superiors
um including Deputy Commissioner Harkins
and this is uh what he wrote uh Deputy I
did not want to mention this on the call
with a group but I feel it important for
you to have this information on my call
with ops command last night Chief slowly
asked his people to send him their
resource needs they told him that they
need 250 members a day to run things
Chief slowly told them that if they need
100 he will ask for 200 if they need 200
he will ask for 400. he seemed very
comfortable asking for twice what he
really needed
he looks at it that
if the other partner police agencies
can't meet the ask
can we can meet the asked number then
Ottawa may still got get more than they
really need
was a very strange call to be a part of
hearing the commissioner say that he may
ask for a thousand members I felt you
should be aware of the above so that's
what he wrote about his observation the
night before when he attended the
meeting with the ops command what do you
have to say to this it's a very strange
interpretation by superintendent Abrams
what I can tell you was that at one of
the meetings that I recall on the fifth
maybe it was the sixth but what I recall
on the fifth I said to my folks up until
now I've been getting requests that I
would call incremental what we need to
get through this day or this weekend
what we need to do and what the board
chairs asked us to do is what do we need
to get to a safe complete successful
sustainable end to the events happening
here in Ottawa this could take weeks
so I need you not to think incremental I
don't want you just to think in a
short-term cycle of planning I need you
to think exponential
short medium and long term it's in that
context I don't know if I gave the exact
if they say 100 200 but don't let your
thinking be incremental you have to be
able to consider the full range of
resources we're not going to get to be
able to make this request again
so think about everything you might need
a special constable
crime analyst computer dispatcher
someone who can do open source social
media whatever you don't have right now
to meaningfully contribute to the end of
this
these set of events or to not be able to
continue delivering our basic police
services this is the time to put that
resource request into this
so I was not in any way trying to put
any other Police Service in a situation
where they would need to give us things
that we did not need it was interpreted
that way by superintendent Abrams as a
guest on that meeting that's unfortunate
if it was reported that way to the
commissioner that's very unfortunate
now we've we've heard from other
Witnesses we've asked other witnesses to
question uh what should go first the
plan
or the the request
uh is it the number that drive the
resources or sorry the the plan or the
the other way around
um what's your view on that
um you'll very rarely hear me agree to
an or I'm always an and person
so it isn't one or the other
particularly in fluid events that
literally up until the day of the 29th
no one really knew what was coming
the plan will always need to make
adjustments
in real time sometimes
but at any point where you have to make
a commitment to some portion of the plan
you need to have some relative Assurance
of the predictability of the resources
available
so these are not consecutive
exercises they are almost inevitably
concurrent
exercises
a lot of my concern about how this whole
issue has been portrayed is it's been
portrayed as one or the other
and the preferred one seems to be
planned before resources consecutive
in this instance in real time events
whether they be natural disasters or
unplanned protests or protests that are
so fluid in the making that you don't
have the benefit of months or even weeks
of advanced planning you're literally
making resource requests in real time as
the threat assessment or the context of
the circumstances change
we saw that play out in the pre-arrival
plan
you asked the question earlier on as the
warnings increase did your resource
requests increase yes they did not
because we stopped everything
and wrote a perfect plan for the next
resource request we continued with the
planning process while we continued with
the intelligence process while we
continued with the resource request
process
and quite frankly that has been the way
that I have seen
the Toronto Police Service work and all
my time there that has been the way that
the Toronto Police Service supported
many other jurisdictions that is a way
that my experience with the Ottawa
Police Service was during my time as
Chief I had never never once before in
my entire career been asked to provide a
fully detailed plan with sub plans laid
out and timing and exact details and
Logistics as to where people were going
to sleep what uniforms they should bring
before we sent out a request in good
faith to good police partners and said
we got something big it's happening
right now or it's happening two days
from now this is our best guess of what
we need there might need to fine-tune
that can you help us yes or no
now a moment earlier you I think you
clarify that it was on the evening of
the fifth that your team started working
on the numbers it's my recollection but
again if my dates are off I stand to be
corrected I I don't know which dates may
or may not be off I just want to to
bring to your attention uh What uh what
is in your summary and give you a chance
to to correct uh anything uh if
necessary can we go to uh the former
Chiefs summary
at page 31 please
so
can we just I'm seeing sorry I'll let
you finish sorry no go ahead yeah
it looks like it was my mistake but just
to refresh my memory can we go to the
fifth is there any reference of the
board meeting on the fifth
um of February well what here's the
thing uh the reference is in the
previous page on this page to the sixth
and the seventh
um I don't think there's a reference to
the fifth
but uh
you saw an earlier email
uh they did the sixth where you had the
1800 number
right yeah so I'm just trying to to get
some clarification in terms of when your
team work on the number in order for it
to be available again my recollection
sorry to interrupt you sir I should
shouldn't talk over you sorry
um my recollection was that we started
those discussions immediately after the
conclusion of the board meeting on on
the
fifth now that might have been the
command team and I my immediate Chief
staff might have started that discussion
and then on the six the the incident
command team and other
command areas were briefed and then
involved so
that there might be some of a bit of a
bleed over from my recollection me
actioning these things in the fifth to
whatever the meeting was on the sixth
that superintendent Abrams was was
participating in so depending on your
best recollection it could be that the
uh the date in the summary is in error
in which case I I wanted to give you an
opportunity to correct it if necessary
I'm not suggesting it's an array I just
recall having discussions with people in
my organization about the Staffing
numbers immediately after the board
meeting where I've been given that
instruction from the board chair I
wouldn't have waited until the next day
to start having people engage in the
exercise of
the planning exercise around getting
that number
moments Indulgence
okay
um
now this number the 1800 number was
publicly announced at some point was it
not I believe yes it was Sir
do you remember the date oh should we go
by the summary
well it looks like there was I it was
announced at uh emergency council
meeting I believe right so if we go to
page 32 of the summary
Chief slowly publicly announced
the request for 1800 police resources
during a special city council meeting on
February the 7th
is that what you remember yes sir
this was not his normal course of action
but the freedom Convoy was unprecedented
specifically Miss Dean's asked Chief
slowly in a public opsb that's
automatically Services board meeting to
provide a detailed report on the level
of resources required could you explain
the circumstances in which you made the
public announcement
yes so it definitely was not the normal
process
um
there were a series of communications
from the end of the board meeting on the
fifth through the sixth into the seventh
as to what role this the board and the
city could play in supporting the Police
Service to get the needed resources the
substantive outflow of all of that was a
desire by the chair and the and the
mayor they arrived at that through some
level of discourse
um to to have a joint letter to the
other two levels of government to seek
their direct support in uh in securing
those resources
now in the ordinary course would it be
the the practice for the request to go
from Chief to Chief
to from One Police Service to another uh
and not through these political channels
in the ordinary course yes
and uh was that not sufficient in these
circumstances these were extraordinary
circumstances
um and so and and there was a
increasing and significant
desire would be the I think not quite
the right word for the board to be seen
as actively supporting the service in
one of its few ways that they can which
is securing resources for adequate and
effective policing again for context the
start of the February 5th board meeting
the chief sorry the chair
in her opening comments talked
extensively about whether or not
circumstances in Ottawa would allow the
Ottawa Police Service to be able to
provide adequate effective policing
the transition from her opening
statements to me was a question directly
to me chief I'm not quoting exactly but
it but as close as I can Chief do you
have the resource is necessary the
ability to provide adequate and
effective policing in the city and then
there was a substantive period of that
board meeting spent on that topic the
sum total of that was the request the
direct request from the chair for the
list of resources that we would need
this is not ordinary but I do believe it
falls somewhere within the realm of the
Police Service Act for the board
to make sure that we had the resources
necessary to provide adequate and
effective policing and I believe this is
one of the ways in which again chair
Deans may make four mature Deans may
choose to frame it differently but I
interpret it as a genuine effort
to exercise some level of their mandate
to support
um
getting those resources there was then
the additional layer of whether the
chair would sign a salon or the mayor
would join in signing I wasn't very much
involved in that so I can't really speak
to it
now there are those who um
are concerned about the public
announcement of
this larger number of requests for
example there
there may be legitimate legitimate
concerns that this announcement exposed
uh the ops's vulnerability to the Convoy
participants
I I presume someone could come to that
conclusion on their own I'm not sure why
that would be so enlightening because I
think almost every public statement that
I made after
January 29th I talked about how
desperately we needed resources and how
we were seeking resources and asking for
resources I think in the middle of the
February 5th board meeting the topic of
resources came up and in fact in the
middle of that board meeting I received
a communication from the RCMP saying
that 250 officers were arriving and I
literally made that announcement on the
board meeting so nobody should have been
surprised I think reasonably surprised
on the seventh that we were
significantly in need of resources and
that we were going to be asking for a
lot of resources
and though to those who hold the view
that this announcement this announcement
was made outside the proper channels and
invited uh inappropriate political
influence into the intra-police
resourcing discussions uh what do you
have to say in addition to what you've
already said about the context of these
and thank you um again listen I think
there would be as many opinions in this
room or all the rooms across Canada on
on any one of the aspects that took
place here so I'm not in any way going
to try to suggest that no one should
ever hold that opinion including another
police leader
but I suspect they would have the same
problem about previous political
announcements around Staffing numbers
that took place the week before
now another criticism that could be
leveled against this Public Announcement
is especially in light of what we've
heard from other police Witnesses about
the lack of an adequate plan at the time
this announcement was made
was it really appropriate to make this
kind of Public Announcement when Ops
didn't seem to have the kind of plan
sufficient to deploy this large number
of resources even if it were given then
um again I can appreciate concerns
raised certainly throughout this process
and and in discourses well beyond these
walls
um this is this again is not an ex not a
practice that I've experienced in my
policing career where there would be a
requirement for detailed completed plans
submitted and then analyzed prior to any
substantive release of resources
it wasn't it wasn't in my experience
around planned events like the G8 G20
and it certainly wasn't my experience in
unplanned or highly fluid and
contentious events like the one that we
experienced here if this had become a
new standard and a new expectation in
policing I was not aware of it and I had
at that point been a chief of police for
over two years
um secondly we did have a plan
it was an ongoing evolving plan I Would
by no stretch of imagination suggest to
anyone the commissioner or anyone else
that it was an excellent plan it was a
robust plan given that we were still
pivoting from what we had experienced
just a week before
Canada was still trying to figure out
what was going on across the country
just as we were trying to figure out
exactly what was going on in the city
and we had been literally using every
resource possible just to get through
hour by hour day by day operations and
the planning for those operations there
was no additional capacity to be able to
produce such a level of standard plan
while we so desperately needed those
resources I think unfortunately it
became an
a misinformed issue
around an unrealistic expectation
and unfortunately that caused a lot of
concern across the board inside our
organization and clearly outside of our
organization
now this commission has heard evidence
from both superintendent Bernier of the
Ops and
superintendent Abrams from the opp that
officers
from the opp already in Ottawa were not
receiving adequate instructions for them
to be properly integrated or deployed in
Ottawa
if there were officers in Ottawa who
were not being effectively used then one
may ask what's the point of sending more
well from what I've heard and what I've
seen in and what I knew at the time yes
there were occasions where officers were
not optimally deployed
can I tell you I had never been involved
in any police operation where we have
brought in resources from across our own
City or brought in resources from
outside of our city into police services
including my time in Kosovo where there
was sub-optimal deployment and
utilization of resources what tends to
happen is The Incident Commander almost
exclusively will be from the police of
jurisdiction will utilize the resources
that they know best and use the most
frequently and then go and tap into the
other resources inevitably that means
that the external resources will be
underutilized it is in no way surprising
for me to have heard that at points
during the entire three weeks that I was
involved in this that there might have
been officers from some Police
Department that didn't get their
briefing at the right time and may have
even spent the better part of the day
not doing the things that they thought
they were going to be doing I'd
experienced that many many times myself
now the the last criticism that could
have been made that I can think of and
that we've heard from some witnesses uh
is that between the third and the 10th
of February
um the Ops was using RCMP and OPP
officers simply to relieve Ops officers
who were exhausted and not as part of a
plan to end the occupation
um what do you have to say to that
that's probably very true sir
our officers were exhausted
Frozen right through they needed relief
and there was no other place to get
relief from and that's part of the
reason why the very first request on the
31st of January that Trish Ferguson
announces to the RCMP commissioner and
the opp commissioner is to send us some
general Duty Officers our people are
asleep on their feet or they're frozen
to their to their post I'm not surprised
that is not an optimal situation but
that's the reality of what was going on
okay now I'd like to take you to
um
to a new topic we've been talking about
your requests for resources but before
we we leave that topic actually
um now that it's clear to you as of the
seventh the sixth or the seventh that
Ottawa would need at least 1800 officers
um in order to effectively resolve uh
the Convoy events
why is it still not a good time to
resort to sections nine six of the
police services act yeah
um
thank you and I appreciate the
opportunity to have a second go around
on this
the concept of of
um
a measured approach I think it's been
talked about usually in terms of PLT and
secondarily in terms of
um
use of force
a measured approach is
we need more resources let's ask for it
we need help with the planning for those
resources let's get that
we might need to integrate our
operations to a greater degree than we
have ever considered before let's work
on that
Okay so we've we've got we're getting
more resources
we are stepping up integration
our planning now is getting to a much
greater uh level of of efficacy
um now we're going to consider a unified
command that is a measured approach of
stepping up
I think it would be irresponsible as I
said before and I'm sticking to that
I think would be unprofessional and
unwarranted to go from Wow we just had a
really bad weekend let's get the opp to
come and police our jurisdiction to we
just had a really bad weekend
figure out how we need to get better
let's start to use everything we
possibly can and let's be as clear as we
can but as quick as we can and
requesting the things that we can
reasonably anticipate we'll need in the
short medium and long term let's be very
open to as we have always been in Ottawa
even during my time to integration
nothing was off the table I think I
probably said that statement 453 times
Everything's on the table including
greater integration and including
unification and ultimately through
greater integration ultimate unification
and some 2200 officers the audible
Police Service
as police of jurisdiction
and the amazing supports we receive from
across the country were able to safely
and successfully end the events here in
Ottawa
perhaps this raises a
more general question
of how should we deal with
multi-jurisdictional event that requires
external support
you've mentioned
that Ottawa is the police of
jurisdiction but the reality is that
you're asking these external agencies
the opp or RCMP
to supply tremendous resources that at
the time Ottawa did not seem capable of
effectively deploying you've
acknowledged that there were issues with
officers already present
but for
different reasons just on that point I
just want to be clear and I think it was
I understand somebody clarified this
before there were instances where
clearly that was happening I believe
superintendent Abrams was a direct con
conduit to deputy chief Bell
organization organization he raised it I
believe it was received well and it was
actioned I don't recall that being a
continuous problem or a problem on scale
I will not deny that it happened
sporadically and particularly in the
early Parts but it's my understanding it
wasn't a daily occurrence on scale where
hundreds of officers were sitting around
being unutilized or unusualized I just
want to make that clear for the public
record yeah and and again that level of
underutilization is something that I've
experienced in my entire three decades
in policing that was not a unique
situation to the events here in Ottawa I
do not wish to exaggerate the the
problem in Ottawa but surely you won't
deny that
um Ops was struggling that's what we've
heard from the I think I think I've said
that repeatedly myself and Ops was
struggling on many different levels it
needed to develop a plan but uh it was
struggling to the point where it was
finding it difficult to have the expert
planners to make that plan is that fair
to say Yes
um and the Ops officers were tired
exhausted
um they needed
external agencies help just to maintain
a regular level of policing
that's the reality at the time we needed
external police agencies held primarily
for the incident command system to
address the crisis happening in the
downtown core we needed less help for
the policing of the rest of the city
we still needed help there but we were
nowhere near by comparison
so again I think my correction is
wouldn't it be very simple
to let
a bigger organization like the opp or
RCMP
to
be to have a greater capacity to help
they wanted to help
um I'm not sure they wanted what you're
suggesting section nine I I never
received
any suggestion from Commissioners Creek
or lucky that they wanted to come in
here and bring the necessary lift of 2
000 plus officers and have them on the
ground here for days if not weeks on end
I stand to be corrected if there's
information out there that's different
from that
um here's the challenge
then you're going to have to get three
levels of government
to invest differently in three levels of
policing
I don't know how the formula would work
but if we're to go down the what if
scenario that you're asking me to to
entertain and please if if the
commissioner doesn't have time for this
or you want to move on just let me know
but here's scenario number one take a
percentage of every Municipal Police
Service just say ten percent fold that
up into the opp because every single
year some event is going to come to some
Municipal Police Service where they
don't have enough resources so
automatically the opp will get 10 cut of
every Police Service for because when
not if they will be required under the
new components of section 9 to come and
take over policing for a day a week a
month
they have the lift to be able to do that
I don't think any mayor or any Regional
Authority is going to go for that and I
don't even think the province would want
that responsibility now just layer in
that on top with the RCMP with how
stretched they are with contract
policing National policing indigenous
policing Force protection
internationally there's probably eight
functions that not one of them are
staffed adequately now are you going to
take a 10 cut from the Provincial Police
Services to allow the RCMP to do that
and now you come to the national capital
region where there are six Police
Services operating in here at any given
day how do you divide the pie there I
understand the intellectual desire to
explore that the Practical and financial
side I'm not sure merits the effort I
think what we need to do is get
standards across the board really
clarify how and when we work together in
integrated and or unified clarify the
gaps between strategic operational and
tactical and how that fits into police
of jurisdiction adequate and effective
that's going to be a lot cheaper and
probably a lot faster and it can be
iterated over the course of time for
lessons learned from experience to
experience
if you're talking about a major
structural change legislative change
that would take years to hammer out and
then years to get to a point of efficacy
well let's uh go back to what happened
on around the time that Chief party let
his group the integrated Planning Group
to Ottawa he arrived on the 8th and he
had a meeting with your command team on
both the 8th and the ninth I want to get
your best recollection of the meeting
you had with them in the afternoon on
the 9th
okay well I think it was around uh 12
o'clock again for context
um
if I get the dates wrong I believe
somewhere around this the 6th or the
seventh there was a communication
between myself and commissioner Creek
where
um we we had talked about a significant
increase in integration
um I forget who raised it whether he did
or I did but we were very quickly in
agreement that that would be very
helpful and that we would need then uh
to bring in uh folks from senior folks
that had experience and expertise and
that type of thing he referenced Carson
party almost immediately that name I
believe came up in our first
conversation and I welcomed him and
anybody else that he could send to
support that and to his word um I think
within 24 hours we were contacted 24
hours after that there was an initial
meeting out at the RCMP
headquarters
um that was a meeting unfortunately and
I realized I'm going really fast so I'm
slowing myself down now
that was the meeting unfortunately that
because of the distance to travel to and
the team's meetings problems that we had
uh acting deputy chief Ferguson was only
able to get a portion of her Incident
Command Staff on there while there was
somewhat of a productive discussion it
didn't get to the level where there was
any substantive move forward there was
an agreement to have another meeting on
the
9th of February right on the 9th of
February
um
and and there was additional efforts
during that period to continue to
improve and evolve that plan a
substantive lift that day I referenced
earlier on that I got involved in that
lift to try to elevate the plan to as
great a degree as we possibly could for
these partner agencies coming in I
believe around 12 o'clock 12 30 Chief
superintendent party superintendent
Abrams
RCMP superintendent Lou and I forget
there were other members but those were
the three primary members of the team
arrived at our headquarters take a pause
there
um but that was the context to the start
of that meeting I had my command team
and my incident command team there as
well so I'm glad you paused there
because uh before we get to the the
actual meeting with the integrated
Planning Group um do I understand
correctly that that morning the morning
of the ninth uh you had another meeting
with your uh the ops command team can
you tell us more about that that meeting
first yeah can we debriefed from what
happened the previous night look to see
where we could again continue to evolve
the plan
um in advance of the this next meeting
and put every effort into that so that
again we could have the best product
available it was clear to me that this
the arrival of this team was not only to
support what the ongoing efforts here
but they needed to assess where we were
with our ongoing efforts here
specifically assess the plan
now let me take you to
um
some notes
um
these are notes written by deputy chief
Ferguson I believe
Ops 3014479
and I want to take you to page 66.
so you see from the top there that uh
this is Wednesday February the 9th
if we go to what time did you say the
the meeting was
I don't I see a note here 710 I don't
know if that's accurate but that that
would seem about right it was relatively
early in the morning so this is the day
after the the group arrived uh and uh
and your attendance uh was delayed the
the day before and then the next morning
uh we have this meeting
um
do you remember Mission Hydra yes sir
tell us about the name
ancient Greek civilization an old myth
about a multi-headed monster when you
cut off one head it would grow back
and was there a reason why
it's this is called Mission Hydra
a bit of creative license on my part
um but the idea was we were struggling
to take
a section of the red zone or a
confederation Park
and then hold it while we continued on
um and so that was a constant challenge
as our officers made efforts to secure
portions of the theater particularly in
and around the red zone that the
challenge was as much to take the
portion and then to hold the portions
concept of the Hydra if you can cut off
the head and cauterize it it can't grow
back if you can take a piece of ground
and hold it people can't come back we
can then focus on a smaller theater with
more resources smaller theater more
resources more smaller theater more
resources that's concept behind thee
right now I understand from the
testimony of deputy chief Ferguson that
the day before on the 8th when your
command team met with the integrated
Planning Group she presented a strategic
concept of operations plan with eight
points with a mission statement that
included elements of Engagement by the
PLT and so on and part of this
discussion at this morning meeting on
the ninth is a new version
uh with a different mission statement
and there's a reference here that this
was a very aggressive posture language
throughout the whole briefing and
mission statement uh
I'm not sure the next word as asked
uh if anyone needed clarification Chief
laid out his plan
omitted negotiation and when I brought
it up he reacted angrily saying we are
not negotiating
um then said it's implicit
I advise
uh is it all cic mission statements are
our cic mission statements always has
explicitly stated uh in the
in the mission statement
and then the next comment I believe is
attributed to you if it doesn't reduce
the size of the footprint that is not a
good negotiation do remember this
Exchange
these are acting Deputy Ferguson's
recollection of that I I would not in
any way characterize what took place in
that meeting
to reflect what I'm interpreting in
language here so again without the
chance to
hear these concerns and understand
we had a very healthy discussion yes
around whether the term negotiation
should be explicit
in I believe the mission statement
um
but other than that I'm not really sure
as to why she has interpreted things the
way that she's chosen to do so so let's
hear it from your perspective you've
told us about this uh as well I believe
during our interviews if I could take
you to your interview summary at page 36
so we go to the section under
discussions
that's right Chief slowly recall that on
February the 9th he held a special
meeting with deputy chief Bell acting
deputy chief Ferguson Ops general
counsel Christian hanod CAO dunker an
inspector Kevin Maloney this meeting
took place after an internal Ops
planning meeting but before the February
9 12 10 pm meeting with Chief
superintendent party and superintendent
Liu his intent was to emphasize that the
entire command team was signed off on
the February 9th plan at the meeting he
stated that he would crush anyone who
undermined the plan Chief slowly
recognizes that it was an unfortunate
choice of words but Public Safety member
Health wellness and safety and the
successful conclusion of the local
Convoy event were all at a critical
juncture and this required absolute
command commitment to supporting the
implementation of the updated plan
he restated the need for Unity within
the command to support the updated plan
including the level of integration in
the acquisition of the needed resources
to safely and successfully end the event
in Ottawa there were to be no major
changes to the plan the concept of
operations the elevated integration in
the senior ICS assignments without
discussion about the need for such a
change
um does this reflect your recollection
of what happened yes sir it's my
statement so there appears to be an
emphasis of
committing to this plan unless there was
there were significant changes that
would have Justified a different course
why this emphasis
we had had the challenge of the previous
week where senior people were swapped
out without any communication
where we had delays around the
development of a significant portion of
the plan that being the public Order
Plan
this was a reminder to folks but the
problems that we encouraged we
encountered last week we are now
bringing in a significant amount of
resources a significant level of
integration and we simply cannot have
a
individual make a change that could
affect the Strategic intent of what we
were trying to accomplish at this point
we needed to have on the positive side
we needed to have a full commitment
across the command team that we had
reached a position now that we could
move forward with there were still going
to be evolutions of the plan and
subplans and as resources became
available but that the base of the weak
and change of pivoting from where we
were into this new position particularly
with the request of resources and
integration this required a very firm
and full commitment from the command
team going forward
now you acknowledge that the word choice
Crush was unfortunate absolutely sir but
you meant to convey
an emphasis
that um
no one should DV should deviate from the
plan likely
lightly at the Strategic level no major
changes in the plan no major changes in
the concept of operations the elevated
integration with RCMP and OPP and the
senior ICS assignments major Incident
Commander event Commander Incident
Commander without discussion first
probably the only thing I forgot to add
in there unless there were exusing
circumstances and again obviously I
shouldn't say Obviously exiting
circumstances is always implicit in any
one of these circumstances
is this consistent with the incident
command
system where the operational level
Commander required a certain degree to
adapt
and to respond
to quickly changing circumstances that's
the concept of circumstances so that
would not fit within what I was relaying
to these folks here so would your
colleagues have come away from this
meeting
understanding that if there were to be
changes that it would require some kind
of an approval from the chief not at all
sir at the operation level no again I'm
very clear no major changes to the plan
no major changes to the concept of
operations not objectives not sub plans
not operational decisions made during
the course of the day the elevated
integration I wasn't going to have a
superintendent inspector a Staff
Sergeant or a deputy chief tell the opp
and the RCMP you know what we don't need
that integration never mind what slowly
says so this was me being very clear at
the Strategic level of where we were no
major changes outside of exigent
circumstances for these areas
so we'll come back to this very shortly
but uh just to clarify this point I may
take you to
um the notes taken at this meeting by
the legal services by uh Miss hanold if
we go to Ops three
zeros14454 please
page 130.
so this is this appears to be the same
meeting
um
you want to screw up and take a look at
the date thank you
February 9th okay so we go back to page
130.
the point I want to take draw your
attention to is the second arrows from
the top no changes to plan unless Chief
approves
yes
so that was the question I put to you
would someone walk away from this
meeting thinking that there were to be
no changes to the plan unless the chief
approves again to be explicit no changes
to the
architectural sorry the architecture of
the plan but that is not me saying you
can't have a tactical change you can't
have an operational change unless I
approve it it would be
even if I wanted that it would be
impossible for me to validate approve or
not approve every single aspect of any
potential change to plan it would just
be impossible I would never have said
that and I can't see any experienced
person in that room taking such a
literate interpretation and walking out
particularly after being
in this theater for almost a week and a
half
and if they had that interpretation with
the maturity and the rank in that room I
would have expected them to raise
clarification
now it was at this meeting as well that
we've heard from other witnesses that um
you discussed politics
um
if I could take you to
page
maybe later on in this page actually or
maybe the next page I'm not sure
uh go down a little more
do you see uh the comment from Trish I
want us to limit politics yes sir and
the comment just before that uh I
suppose was attributed to you Tom C Tom
Curry probably is assessing
if we are worthy of getting the
additional Ask Resources yes sir um what
is your recollection of the discussion
just that it was made it clear to them
that
um the folks that have arrived here have
come with clear instructions from their
command to assess the level of our
planning
the adequacy of the resource requests
that we made and then to assuming that
we could come to that arrangement of of
integration to then move forward and
unbuilding that out but they were coming
to assess where we were
now um so there was a reference to the
deputy chief Ferguson asking
to limit the discussion of politics her
own notes now these are notes taken by
the legal services her own notes are
more uh explicit if we could go to Ops
three zeros one four four seven nine
at page 67
we go down
okay talked about the plan so keep going
see the the dash
talked about the plan
I'm sure the
talked about the plan for briefing
briefing the embedded cell of planners
and commanders and he spoke of a type of
conspiracy that is happening at
provincial and federal levels and this
team is being handled
by their political Masters
and
promoted the idea that they are not
really here to help can you help us
understand
who are these political Masters and uh
what was the conspiracy theory yeah
first of all these are Tricia's acting
Deputy Ferguson's words I I won't
challenge her emotions or interpretation
around it but they're not the
conversation that I was leading at this
point
um
I had a very clear discussion about two
elements we are going to be assessed on
the quality of our planning and the
relevance to the resource requests and
if we cannot
provide enough
substantive justification for what we're
looking for we're likely not going to
get the level of help that we need
secondarily
we I did talk about the politics that
are happening in and around this entire
event by this time it is a national
event with global coverage
by this time I had had several
interactions with all three levels of
government and the board that was clear
to me that there was increasing intense
and in some cases I believe undeserved
and unhelpful political pressures
happening to the Ottawa Police Service
pressures that could affect
our ability to secure the resources
so I was letting them be aware giving
them situational awareness and allowing
a conversation to happen in a very tight
room with my command team so they could
have as much understanding before they
went in front of
the group of external agencies to have
that conversation I didn't want there to
be any surprises and I wanted them to be
as fully informed as possible an example
would be the day before this there is a
public motion put forward by a
significant number of City councilors
asking for the Ottawa Police Service to
be removed of police of jurisdiction for
the purposes of the incident command so
these were very live real time issues
there were others that they were less
aware of so I tried to give them
indications as to what was going on
without going delving down into the
unfortunate details of it
it's in that context that I think acting
deputy chief Ferguson may have thought
it was a conspiracy theory these were
very real experiences that I was aware
of and I was trying to bring my command
team to a level of awareness so they
could appreciate the challenges that we
would have to show a unified approach
around this going forward and if we
didn't have a unified approach these
type of politics could very quickly
divide and conquer us
were you concerned that
these officers coming from the opp or
RCMP may not come with a pure motive to
help but rather were acting on behalf of
whoever was sending them
for other politically related reasons
if you're asking whether Chief party
Chief superintendent party and and
superintendent Lou we're there for
political reasons no I think they were
genuinely assigned and they came with
genuine Hearts
um to offer the help that they could to
understand what was going on and offer
the help they could but I'm very much
aware of the politics that that comes to
play on the heads of chiefs of police
and Commissioners and I'm very much
aware of a number of issues that my
colleagues at that rank were facing
now you were the one who was asking for
help
um and when they came
were you did you have any was there any
reluctance on your part to share the
information within the Ops in order to
help them help you not whatsoever sir
um did you have any issues of trust in
relation to working with them
cooperatively to resolve the situation
in Ottawa trust no but I was very
explicit on two points integration means
that the Ottawa Police Service remains
police of jurisdiction
and the Ottawa Police Service remains in
control of the incident command system
and that the resources I'm asking for
are to be under the control of the
incident command system those are the
only three caveats if they couldn't
agree to those three caveats we'd
probably have to go back to the drawing
board in some other way to get the
resources and Achieve another type of
integration those were the three caveats
it's not a matter of trust simply a
matter of the Baseline aspects the red
line aspects of our ability to move
forward under an integrated model
your command team has told us
that they perceive an issue on your part
of not willing to let go of control to
a concern to to hold on to uh
by way of this police of jurisdiction
concept to hold on to some kind of
control do you agree with that not at
all do you know what they are talking
about no I don't sir
um
what was it that was so important why is
it so important to you that Ottawa
remained the police of jurisdiction
what's the significance of that
what does that mean
it's in the police services exer
we are the police for jurisdiction
but don't different Police Services
often work cooperatively to figure out
how to solve a problem isn't that what
and we did that every single day of my
day and if my time in office Joint
Forces operations I invited in the RCMP
to do internal criminal conduct
investigations we did that every single
day that is a very very different thing
from we are no longer the police of
jurisdiction in the nation's capital for
a million people the Ottawa Police
Service will no longer be the Police
Service here even though we've been so
for a century and change that is a very
different concept of operations
but if it makes sense for like a major
case investigation
for
let's say a crime is committed in
Toronto
um but the expertise
required to successfully successfully
solve the case
um necessitates a combination of
expertise from Toronto police people
police and York Regional Police isn't
there some protocol
that um the lead would not necessarily
be the police of jurisdiction it would
depends on the circumstances what makes
the most sense
I can think of examples where yes a a
lead investigator would come out the
lead investigator in the criminal
conduct investigation was from the RCMP
but Professional Standards were still
under my control as the police chief in
the police of jurisdiction
the decision to lay charges are not lay
charges from a police act we're still
under part five for me as a chief of
police but if I'd abdicated that role
and responsibility then it was ought to
be the RCMP lead investigator to decide
on the totality of the circumstances
around that case so yes hundreds of
times probably thousands of times I've
integrated police services for a wide
variety of things administrative HR
human rights operations guns and gangs I
have no trouble whatsoever with that
concept
in my time in policing let me be careful
here
I can't think of a single time in my 30
years in policing where a Police Service
said
we're done somebody else come do this
for us I stand to be corrected but I
can't recall a single occasion of that
happening
but why would it be a matter of someone
else doing it for us wouldn't be a
wouldn't it be a true matter of
collaboration it would still count on
the the Loco expertise uh but uh
maybe this is a question for the policy
round discussions I don't know
potentially sir
but uh in any event at this meeting on
February the 9th
um if I teach you to um the notes Ops
three zeros one four four five four so
we're returning to
the legal services notes if we go to
page 136
thank you
if we go down
so um
so this is still the ninth I believe
yesterday provided them the org chart of
command
what more
do you need to implement
our plan
to implement or build into our plan need
to know what resources we will get here
in Ottawa
um that was attributed to you and the
opp responded strategic decision because
of rest of provinces do you remember
what this was about yes sir uh explain
to us please I think a very healthy
discussion look we we have a local need
here but we now have a national set of
events
um
by the ninth Windsor might have been
starting to kicking up around that time
um Toronto had just got through their
Queen's Park piece I think much of the
the Prairie Provinces had one or more
things going on Coots was still very
alive so yeah this was a healthy
discussion around look we we know we
need a lot of resources but we also know
you got a lot of other resource demands
happening around this time I believe
there was a steady almost daily call of
all chiefs that were facilitated by the
OPP and they had already I think
established two levels of resource
integration one on public order units
explicitly and another one on General
resource requests so we were already in
a provincial National Theater where we
are trading off resource requests
against risks on a scale that I'd never
experienced and I'm not aware of any
police chief of my generation that says
they experienced something similar so
that's the context of the discussion
taking place here if we go uh scroll
further down
OPP said we stated 1200 OPP staff
over
to read sorry it's actually the the
below uh quote that I'm interested in
can build a plan without a plan
and the chief said fine build a plan and
get us the people
um it I I know what was taking place
here I don't think these notes are
particularly accurate at this point I
suspect there's a lot of back and forth
and people are talking fast as I am now
um and there's a little bit of catch-up
time here so if I will build off these
notes to not increase but tell us what
you remember they're not accurate
um so first there was a discussion I
forgot I forget who raised it it might
have been superintendent Abrams but I'm
not 100 sure
um around how many staff have been sent
over and again I said well there was
that miscommunication from the solicitor
general
um that that left the impression that
1500 officers from the opp or from
across the province were here in Ottawa
on a daily basis and I again explain the
challenges that public trust and
confidence challenges that that caused
us
um that then pivoted out of that
discussion into
again I don't know who from the opp
would have led this but
I don't think this is an accurate
statement but it probably captures the
theme can't build a plan without a plan
this is the chicken and egg discussion
should you have a plan for us before you
get the resources and I'm saying we are
planning and we know we need a level of
resources we can fine to the plan I need
a commitment of resources so that's the
the gist of the discussions that are
taking place probably in Rapid Fire And
The Scribe is in this case Christian you
know is doing her best to keep up
um now you you do recognize these notes
are from the Ops Council yes I just
referenced Christian you know
um because didn't you ask her uh if we
go to page 43
so uh I'm going back in time uh page 43
is her notes on February the 3rd
as you can see here
um do you see the the bullet where
she notated that she asked
he asked
if I've been taking notes I told him I'm
acting like a scribe and capturing
everything so it appears that you've
asked her to take notes and she's been
doing her best to take notes almost like
a scribe uh and trying to capture
everything
but you don't believe that these notes
are
or at least the part that no sorry if
I've let that impression she
Christian you know is many things
wonderful and an excellent general
counsel
chief for a period of days
offered to and took on this role of
being a scribe we were just so thin on
resources she offered to do that until
she could free up Vicky
Vicki Nelson I believe is her name
I'm not suggesting that the effort on
the ninth was an insufficient effort
that was a very Dynamic meeting and
there was a lot of points being making
made and she was doing her best to
capture them I'm only saying they're not
actual quotes that I can attribute and
she hasn't attributed to people so she's
done her best it's
just not able to say who said what
exactly when
the notes that she provided were
incredibly helpful for me
now in the in the interest of time I
think I'm going to skip ahead but uh the
last point I I need to uh I do want to
put to you because uh In fairness to you
Chief Hardy in his will say has said
that the tone the overall tone of this
meeting was somewhat unprofessional and
disrespectful Chief slowly was very
clearly under tremendous pressure to act
and was very suspicious of levels of
commitments from police agencies he went
as far as to advise us that he had
sources in the ministry office that his
requests were not being supported and
essentially they wanted him to fail
there was disagreement on this point
from our team I just want to give you
the opportunity to respond to those
comments
all of them sir
uh you can if it would it would it help
you if you could put it up I just I just
can't there was a lot of things you just
said there so
of course um thank you let's go to OPP
five zeros 792
and you can go to page four please
so do you see the bullet that starts
with the overall tone yeah it was a it
was a tense meaning at times
um we certainly got into very
contentious discussions like the
discussion sorry I slow myself down we
got into contentious discussions like
the discussion around the solicitor
general release of the 1700 number
I could see if during those points uh
Chief superintendent party who I believe
was
selected appropriately and sent quickly
and came
um with the view of supporting I suspect
that would be the same for
superintendent Lou representing the RCMP
they were not aware of and had not been
involved in these events I suspect they
weren't even following all the events
and certainly not the political aspects
of it they were operational people
coming in to provide an Operational
Support
in that context I could understand why
Chief superintendent party might
describe some aspects of it as
disrespectful
right words here
oh do we mean some somewhat
unprofessional and disrespectful
um I needed to be very clear on behalf
of my service and my city and the state
of Public Safety that we're in that we
needed the resources
that we needed them as quickly as
possible they needed to be
predictable
sustainable resources and not as we had
experienced so far through nobody's
fault but
we can send you this but if if an event
comes to us we've got to pull them back
you without any predictability of
resources
I don't want to get back into the plan
first versus the resource request but
absent the predictability of resources
planning for something that you can't
resource becomes a waste of time and we
had no time to waste and we had no
resources to waste so again I come back
it's an and not an or
the rest of this I don't know if you
want to go me to go through bullet point
but no that's fine and comment yes I um
there were so many things I I would like
to uh get your thoughts on but we do not
have
um all the time that we want
um suffice it to say we discussed
political as the political pressure
aspects and that is always an
uncomfortable conversation to have
between Police Services right
now
um if I could take you to a different
topic
um
and this relates to
the invocation of the emergencies Act
I want to ask you before
the 14th of February did you ever form
the view that additional powers that
could be granted under the emergencies
act could help Ops resolve the Convoy
events
I'm not sure I understand the question
sorry I may have just missed it I
apologize right um
so the emergencies Act was invoked on
the 14th of February that's
before that date
did you ever
think about whether
the powers under the emergencies act
might be helpful for the Ops to resolve
the Convoy events
before that date I never thought about
the emergencies act I think I might have
been made aware of it over that weekend
um
my challenge literally up until my last
day in office wasn't additional
legislation or
injunctions it was resources in fact
there was a period of time where we were
hoping there wouldn't be any injunctions
or emergency declarations because they
would give us more powers and we didn't
have any resources
to implement those powers and then we
would be accused again of not doing our
jobs or not using powers available to us
so
for a significant portion of my time in
office
discussions around injunctions
discussions around emergency
declarations were
maybe that's something that we actually
don't want at this point
I was never consulted explicitly on the
emergency measures act
that was put into place on February 14th
if I could take you to the Ops document
three zeros 14566
it appears that these are notes of a
meeting that occurred on February the
14th at around 10 A.M
so if we go to page two
if we go to the section under the
reduction
do you see a note that lucky did not get
prime minister briefed on the plan
prime minister will be enacting the
emergency measures Act
and then
we go to the very bottom of the page
there is a notation that Chief grateful
for every tool we get in the tool belt
but need the resources
do you remember this discussion I
remember the discussion I can't remember
word for word
um and certainly that last line would be
basically summarizing what I just tried
to tell you tools are great if you don't
have the resources to use them there
could be problems with that so was
commissioner commissioner lucky the
first to inform you that the federal
government would be declaring an
emergency
I I don't have an independent
recollection this appears to be the
first time I'm hearing about it
okay and it certainly wouldn't have been
anything more than a day before if if
there was any other discussion on it now
um later that day I understand that you
spoke with chair Deans about the
emergencies act do you remember that I I
don't have an independent recollection
if you could take me to a meeting note
or something so yeah I'll take you to
Ops three zeros 14 566.
at Page Six
sorry if we go back up a little
I'm trying to see
uh go okay so uh the last bullet
you have you have a municipal state of
emergency then a provincial and now a
federal I have already said that we need
more than just the Ops
uh was that something you said during
that
meeting
that would be in line with the sort of
type of discussions that I can go back
to the we there there may not be a
policing solution to this this would be
in line with that line of discussion we
have three levels of states of emergency
um this is obviously more than just the
Ops
now you said also in your interview
summary that you participated in several
phone calls with Federal Deputy minister
of Public Safety Rob Stewart and
commissioner lucky before the federal
government declared an emergency and
that you made it clear on these calls
that number one thing that the Ops
needed were more police officers
um
yes sir sorry I know I need to answer
did the federal
Declaration of emergency help Ops obtain
more resources
um I I can't tell you that because I
resigned office within 24 hours
um I'd like to show you an email
exchange between commissioner lucky and
Mr Mike Jones who was Chief of Staff to
minister manduccino the document number
is
pb.nsc dot can
dot four zeros three two five six
so the contacts in this email
commissioner lucky
enumerates a few emergency measures that
she believes would be useful but then
added that she's of the view that well
I'll let you read it um
we go down she gave a few examples of
additional tools but then if we go
further down
he said that said I'm of the view that
we have not yet exhausted all available
tools that are already available through
the existing legislation
do you agree with that assessment
I don't know what she's referring to sir
the available tools if you want to well
she explains in this paragraph there are
instances where charges could be laid
under existing authorities for various
criminal code offenses occurring right
now in the context of the protest the
Ontario provincial emergencies act just
enacted will also help in providing
additional deterrent tools to our
existing toolbox
again um
she may be relating to elements of Coots
Alberta or other parts that they're
involved in I don't know if she's
explicitly talking about the theater
that I was involved in
um it's hard to tell what she thinks
could be done these are certainly
elements that we were doing in Ottawa we
where we couldn't arrest we were getting
information to lay charges after the
fact
the Ontario provincial emergencies act
had just been announced on the Friday we
were still looking I don't know if
by this time on the
by on the Monday that we'd even had a
substantial briefing from our legal team
as to what those Powers were and whether
or not our incident command team had
considered how to roll them into the
ongoing evolution of the plans
I can't disagree with the position of
the commissioner but I can't say that it
applies entirely to the circumstances
that I was dealing with at that time did
you have a view on whether we have
exhausted all available tools that are
already available through the existing
legislation we meaning the Ottawa Police
Service that's right
again I come back to it sir we didn't
have the resources to fully effectively
utilize
the private injunction and
the elements of the Ontario the
provincial emergencies act at this point
so I can't tell you that I would even
have an opinion on that other than
we were just trying to get resources
okay now let's go back and talk a bit
about
um we began uh today's discussion I'm
sorry I I do recall just as an example
I forget which day it was it could have
been the Saturday or the Sunday it feels
like it was a Sunday
one of those tri-level calls that you
referenced with Rob Stewart and
commissioner lucky
um it was the only time that uh
ministers Mendocino and Blair were on
the call and I joined it late for some
reason I had multiple competing demands
and there was a question asked maybe it
goes to what commissioner lucky was
talking here about existing legislation
but a question was asked to me by
Minister Blair have you considered doing
bylaw enforcement which I thought was a
strange question
um and I said yes we've been doing bylaw
enforcement from the very beginning and
then he asked the second question well
have you considered towing trucks
I said yes we've been towing trucks from
the very beginning but we don't have
sufficient officers to do full
enforcement and we don't have sufficient
trucks to do extensive Towing
maybe that has something to do with this
we haven't exhausted all the tools
comment I but that's the only context
that I can think of
okay
now we began our discussions today with
uh questions about
the Ottawa Police Service at the time
the Convoy arrived and now we're into
well into February I want to come back
to the question of your confidence in
the Ops Team on the day before your
resonation on the 14th of February
um
we have this communication your
communication
with uh
chair Deans if I could find the
reference
foreign
Page Six
so this is a call on February the 14th
so if we scroll down a little
when asked by chair if any of my orders
were disobeyed during the demonstration
Chief advice there have been major
issues with senior leadership team
members but he has not had time to do an
investigation on what has been going on
here the best and the worst of us have
been strained that is why there has been
tense meetings and why some have not
demonstrated their best efforts like
everyone I have been at my best and I
have not been at my best
can you explain what you meant there's a
there was a discussion in there with the
chair
um around the quality of support that I
was receiving inside the organization
and my own sense of where we were we
were at at the leadership level a
reasonable question from the chair chair
of the Police Services Board at the
direct employee level that the board has
with myself and in this case only deputy
chief Bell because
acting deputy chief Ferguson was not an
employee of the board
um and I gave my my best answer to her
there were some challenges I mean I
actually think these notes capture it
well
um
I there would be elements of some of
those leadership challenges that would
need to be reviewed in an after-action
report again I didn't have a chance to
to ever conduct that
um and I had made decisions on the fly
in the midst of this very fluid
situation to address conduct issues uh
and park them or address them and move
on from them completely
um but I also gave the caveat that there
had been incredible levels of stress and
fatigue and that clearly no one
including myself could claim that they
were always operating
in their best at their best
how did that lack of trust affect the
leadership of the Ops during the Convoy
events in the sense did it make you more
likely to step in and provide directions
because you you could not trust others
to lead at the Strategic or operational
levels uh no um
it's an important question you're asking
and it's a it's a not an easy question
to answer so please if you can give me
some leeway here
there was a significant trust issue
that's the only significant trust issue
that I was aware of and I thought had a
material impact on the events that
transpired over those weeks was the
switching out of uh superintendent realm
for superintendent Dunlop and we've been
through that so I won't go back to it
um
when I realized what had happened as
close as I can good discipline should be
uh in the smallest small D discipline
should be applied as quickly to the
event I immediately called a meeting
with the two command officers I asked
them a straight question and to their
credit they gave me straight answers
I wasn't happy with the answers meaning
I was disappointed that they had chosen
to go that route and I expressed that
immediately and clearly and then I
counseled them immediately and I told
them what good behavior would look like
going forward and then I moved on from
it and as I said earlier on
they both in their own ways worked back
towards demonstrating
trust and capability
what I was asked here were overall
what's happening and I related
that circumstance but there were other
elements of
a lack of cohesion within the team
people making assumptions we've heard
already elements of people taking a
rumor and assuming it's truth and how
that impacted a range of issues from PLT
to whether or not there was a plan to
whether or not the plan had been
approved
so those were issues that I was dealing
with on an ongoing basis
they were difficult issues to deal with
they took time and energy away from
everybody involved including me and in
some cases they cause confusion
um so those are the types of things I
was trying to relate to the to the chair
but I was also trying to relate the
context in which we had found ourselves
unprecedented Uncharted unrelenting
pressures
inside the organization and outside the
organization to not leave her with the
impression that we were having some sort
of a mass internal revolt
that was my understanding at that time
and that's what I tried to relay as
honestly and as fully to the chair at
that time
now there are two other
events I want to cover so you had this
conversation with chair Deans on the
14th I want to ask you about the 13th as
well as on the 15th so let's start with
the 13th
um
I'm skipping ahead I I jump a few things
because in the interest of time we've
heard from the other Witnesses including
Chief party and superintendent Bernier
that superintendent Bernier was working
closely with the integrated Planning
Group as of the 12 and by the 13th they
have
they have signed off on a plan and we've
seen the plan
um there is an email
um
that was exchanged uh on around the 13th
I'd like to take you to so as to clarify
what your understanding was as to the
evolving plan that you described
um
can I take you to
um
OPP four zeros1547
.
so if we go to the very bottom of the
chain
this email chain originated from you to
deputy chief Ferguson you asked her to
please send you the latest version of
the operations plan that you approved on
Wednesday February 9th that was the day
when you met with the integrated
Planning Group that we talked about
and then you also ask to please advise
if the plan has received official
approvals signatures Etc as there seems
to be some concerns about this from the
RCMP
um if we go up
one level
so WG Ferguson replied to you saying
um in checking with Rob Bernier he
finally had a chance to review the plan
from the integrated planning team and
ascended back with his comments he would
prefer that it be completed and signed
off
and will then share the plan as he is
the final approver of it
S4 version 3.0
Ottawa truck demo 22 9th of February
um I think she attached yes that as uh
as your uh per your request
so we've heard from both Deputy Ferguson
and from superintendent Bernier uh
superintendo was very clear that to him
the 3.0 and the February 13th plan were
very different plans
um
so I just want to get your comment on
that
they were very different plans in that
they were significantly more evolved the
13th was significantly more involved
than the ninth plan but they were the
same continuity of iterations from the
pre-plan that we had on on January 28th
so if we go one level up the email chain
you'll reply to Deputy Ferguson thank
you for the clarification I was not
aware of this delay as I had approved
the plan last Wednesday by last
Wednesday that would have been the ninth
and I put this question to both Chief
party and superintendent Bernier I
believe and they disagree that you had
approved any plan the previous Wednesday
in part because there was no plan to
approve the previous Wednesday
again I I understand
the perspective of Chief superintendent
party that he did not consider what we
had presented to him as a plan
I disagree with that assessment it may
not have been to his standard or the opp
standard but it was the plan evolved
since January 28th through several
iterations some of which we've seen here
today
that was signed off by inspector Lucas
and superintendent Rio and continued
through until the next signature blocks
appeared on the February 13th version of
the same plan
I can appreciate Chief superintendent
party might not have known of the
iterations that preceded it he might
have understood our business processes
and policies and he might have assumed
that this was a brand new plan I'm also
aware of an email from superintendent
Lou of the RCMP that shares my
impression that the February 9th plan
was being used by the integrated
planning team to build on
and that is entirely my understanding
that is why when I sent the email to
acting Deputy Ferguson send me the
latest version
I wasn't talking about the February 9th
plan what was the latest iteration that
had developed since then I just need to
see is there a new org chart have you
got an updated mission statement have
you got a better sense of objectives you
want to are there sub plans that I
should be looking at I just needed an
update and I was having phone calls on a
daily basis with Commissioners Creek and
lucky in which there was these constant
questions of have you signed off on it
and I would respond I don't sign off on
the plans well we heard it's with you
it's not with me I haven't even been
briefed on it yet well we've heard it's
you that have to approve it I don't
approve the plans and I have to tell you
we went around and around on that and
this is me trying to finally just say
Trish whatever is the latest version
send it to me
if it's been signed off please send to
me quickly so I can forward it to karik
and to Lucky Commissioners Creek and
lucky and that's exactly what I did at
the end I think somewhere around nine
o'clock that night I said here it is you
can see the signatures on it it's
Bernier it's Lou sorry I should use your
ranks superintendent Lou Chief
superintendent party and Acting
Superintendent Bernier it's signed off
it's done I never had to approve it
there's no signature line it's being
implemented
I think there were still questions after
that I cannot to this day understand why
there are still questions about whether
or not the plan was approved and signed
off it had been approved it had been
signed off
finally I like to take you to the events
of the 15th of February that was the day
you resigned
at the time of your resonation did you
think that the Ops was well positioned
to end the occupation
I think we were well positioned I
wouldn't say that we had reached a
position of certainty but we were well
positioned
we had
at that point a significant level of
integration we had received significant
levels of resources including expertise
including experienced leaders of the
quality of Chief superintendent party
superintendent Lou and others
um I think at that time we actually had
the strongest of the different
iterations of incident command teams
uh with uh
Acting Superintendent Bernier as the
event Commander I think at that point he
had a deputy commander in
OPP inspector Springer
both of them seem to have
a very good rapport and inspector
Springer I believe is one of the most
experienced and trained
incident commanders if not in the
province across the country and there
really seemed to be a sense of structure
to what they were doing and they were
building in positions that in my
experience as an incident commander and
and the roles I played in Toronto police
were very useful for us and I could see
how they were being applied here so my
sense was we had
strong and increasingly stronger plan a
strong and increasingly stronger level
of integration and finally demonstrably
a greater level of resources coming in
but it was that last hurry that I still
felt that there was
there were challenges in getting those
resources and it's in that particular
aspect that played probably the biggest
role in my decision to resign my office
we've heard from other witnesses that
after your resonation
things appear to move quicker do you
have any idea why that might be the case
we had a very strong integrated team we
had very strong leaders in that team
there was Clarity around the plan
I suspect yes when there's a leadership
change there's always a sense of
there's a change and that change alone
as you've seen in in decisions to
replace a hockey coach mid-season or
whatever like team plays well for three
or four games and the old challenges
that hadn't been addressed yet come back
pretty quickly after
so I don't in any way challenge the
notion that
change created a change
but I do note that the level of
resources flowing in was incredible at
that point and that within three or four
days there was sufficient resources on
the ground to execute successfully the
operations that have already been
described in this court
when you attended your interview with us
um you told us that the primary reason
for your resignation was consideration
of Public Safety yes sir tell us what
you meant well I think I started off my
testimony here today commissioner with
my thoughts on Public Safety being one
of if not the number one reason
um public trust being if not one of the
number one reasons for Public Safety
um I gave lengthy descriptions
throughout the course of the day here
around the impact of public Trust in the
first day that Saturday
um
The public's opinion uh opinion of three
levels of government opinions of Civil
Society leaders
that I think unfairly
and unnecessarily
laid the blame of this thing on the
Ottawa Police Service
we did our very best for as long as we
could we sought the resources and the
help that we could that we integrated
and implemented those resources
ultimately successfully
but on the morning of February 15th it
was clear to me that the trust factor in
Ottawa Police Service was still headed
in the wrong direction
and the only person that could take that
pressure off the Ottawa Police Service
was me and I made that decision to
resign from office to get the resources
on the ground to support the safety of
our communities and quite frankly to
support the safety the health and
wellness of our own members and our
partner agencies that were at that point
in the theater
now when we began our examination this
morning I took you to your CV can we
bring up the the CV again
is document number com50759
so at the top of your CV there's a motto
others before self compassion for all
why is that on your CV
foreign
everything else after that's just what I
did
thank you commissioner uh those are my
questions my colleague Miss Rodriguez
will have more after the break if you
see this as an appropriate time
okay so we'll take a 15-minute break and
then come back to complete the uh
examination by commission Council
the commission is in recess for 15
minutes
the commission is reconvened
Maybe
okay well maybe I'll take another couple
of minutes uh in the circumstances
for a few minutes
order a lot
the commission is reconvened like
commissioner
okay be okay to continue okay go ahead
thank you uh good afternoon Mr Sully
nice to see you again good to see you
too uh for the record it's Natalia
Rodriguez for the commission thank you
man
um I'm gonna pick off pick up where my
colleague Mr Owl left off with your
resignation
um can I ask was it your decision to
resign
because ultimately my decision there was
a lot of factors that went into it yes
did the board ask you to resign
there were significant pressures
clearly
to me it was clear to me
that um
the board specifically chair Deans had
lost confidence in my position
and that was a factor
in my decision
now I believe chair Dean's told us when
she was here last week that she did not
lose confidence in you but you're saying
you felt that she had lost confidence in
you
from statements made and yes totality of
the circumstances yes okay and did the
board anyone at the board or the chair
expressed that they had lost confidence
in you
on the evening of February 14th I
received a phone call from the board
chair essentially asking what I consider
resignation
okay so I I assume you're familiar and
maybe I shouldn't assume are you
familiar with the evidence that she gave
on on that exchange last week
I'm aware of some of it but I'd be happy
to receive more context or information
around it well maybe you can tell us how
it transpired from your perspective
uh 21 days into an event
of the size and nature that we were
dealing with
and uh 9 30 at night at the end of
I don't know how many hours of days of
in that day I worked
to get a phone call from your chair
um
discussing rumors and then pivoting into
have you thought about resigning
conversation for me is a pretty clear
indication that I no longer had the
confidence of the chair and by the chair
the board of the Ottawa Police Services
and um as she tells it at that time you
told her that you would not resign but
then the next morning you called her to
say that you had reconsidered is that
accurate from your perspective I told
her that I put my heart and soul into
this organization the Mandate that she
had given me
and that I'd be seeing this sing through
and that at 9 30 at night it was a very
inappropriate conversation to be having
with me I wasn't going to be giving it
any more consideration
and so what made you change your mind
the almost 11 hours worth of continuing
to manage the situation in this
in this city on behalf of the audible
Police Services
and did anyone within the city of Ottawa
or the government of Ontario or the
government of Canada
expressed to you that you should resign
I'm a little bit
um I realize I'm not supposed to be
referencing other people's testimony or
evidence presented already but I am
aware of in a very a very alarming text
uh apparently from Brenda lucky
commissioner lucky to commissioner karik
wasn't aware of it before my decision
but I am now aware of it now so I don't
know how to relate that into this
situation so well it's more about did
anybody tell you did anybody put
pressure on you or suggest to you that
you should resign that at the time
obviously you would have been aware of
that if somebody had said that to you
thank you that's that's more helpful for
me
um
I had Direct experiences with
officials at three levels of government
I had Direct experiences with three
levels of government over the course of
the time that these events
that left me with a clear sense that I
had no little to no support
from elements at those three levels
in all three levels
yes
are you aware of any political pressure
on the board to seek your resignation
Municipal yes definitely there was a
motion passed motion motion present I
don't think it was passed so clearly yes
I don't remember if any of this the
board members three counselors that were
on the board voted in support of that
motion to remove the audible places
police of jurisdiction
um
but there was certainly I'm aware at the
at the municipal level significant
pressure on the board for that to take
place my understanding is that motion
didn't make it to the floor there was
not a vote on that motion
still a clear indication okay thank you
now I want to go back
to the beginning if I may and just go
through some of the events with you kind
of from the municipal slash board lens
if you will
so I want to talk a little bit about
pre-arrival intelligence and we you
talked about that with my colleague Mr
Owl and I want to just talk about what
was what information was relayed to the
board with respect to what could be
expected before the Convoy arrived
um
now
Mr superintendent Abrams of the opp
confirmed in his his evidence that on
the 27th there was an intersect call and
on that call Ops confirmed that their
planning was on the basis of assuming 3
000 trucks coming into the downtown
you're aware of that right it's
yes
um and I believe interim Chief Bell
indicated in his witness summary that as
the Convoy Drew closer they were
expecting three to four thousand
vehicles to arrive in Ottawa I don't
remember the three to four thousand
number my memory is around three
thousand but I don't think at this point
it matters sure uh and then I believe
inspector Lucas and in his evidence
um confirmed that by January 26th the
Ops was expecting about 10 000 people on
the 29th on the on that side I did hear
that from inspector Lucas yes and so
um now I want to just having that
context turn to what the board
understood would be the situation uh on
the 26th when there was that board
meeting and my understanding is that the
January 26 board meeting was the only
sorry for interrupting it was a
specifically called meeting for the
purpose of the Convoy
I I have a recollection I stand to be
corrected our regular January meeting
was I think
the week before and and there was some
discussion at that level but by no means
was it a briefing and I wouldn't expect
the board to have sufficient information
to even form substantive questions but I
just recall there might have been some
mention of it at that previous regular
schedule scheduled meeting okay um my
understanding is it wasn't discussed in
any level of detail but you can agree
with me then that this would have been
the briefing meeting in which
substantively the the details would have
been discussed yes
um Okay so
if we can turn to the minutes of that
meeting OPB
four zeros one two five seven
uh and these are the minutes of that
meeting
and I want to take you to page five
so now this is the portion where and we
can scroll up actually because well just
to note that there are no kind of
numbers that we can see there being
given if we can keep going up
um so these are
yeah
in any event there's um there's no
actual numbers that are provided but
there's a question from one of the
counselors at page five regarding the
numbers so I'll just take you to page
five there uh counselor Brockington
um and then the question was raised
regarding whether the service had an
idea of how many people and vehicles
were expected
the service noted that although the
information is in flux the truck
movement began on the west coast and had
swelled and shrunk as it has traveled
the service was also monitoring other
groups expected to participate in
demonstrations over the weekend the
service was anticipating in the 1000 to
2000 person range however they indicated
that it could change even
with an hour
um so
by this time there was a plan in place
assuming 3 000 trucks entering the
downtown core
why wasn't that information given to the
board
these minutes are not verbata minutes
I would prefer to look at it
a more detailed record these are all
um
these are all taped they're available on
YouTube channels these these minutes of
meetings were never intended to be
verbatim minutes so I'm not suggesting
the number wasn't given but I can't tell
you whether or not it was so that's my
challenge with trying to refer to these
as
scribe notes or or detailed minutes of
what was discussed in the meeting
there's substantive summary points as
opposed to what we've been using as
scribe notes I just it right but but I
mean the question is kind of very
directly put how many people in vehicles
are expected and the answer appears to
be one to two thousand people I don't
know who gave that answer ma'am I I
don't know whether it was in relation to
a direct question here there was some
context missing I just don't know okay
but you were present at this meeting I
was yes okay
um and so
by this time you would have known that
that was the expectation or that was
what the plan was based on three
thousand Vehicles right again just to be
clear I don't think
anybody had a fixed number
there that 3 000 Vehicles was I believe
and I'm going to stand to be corrected
an estimate that inspector Lucas threw
his traffic team and his planners felt
it could be accommodated but that
doesn't mean we were going to get
exactly 3 000 Vehicles we could have got
five we could have got one he was
looking at an upper range that he could
accommodate but that wasn't a prediction
of the number of vehicles that were
expected to arrive 72 hours later okay
um but in terms of numbers this was the
only pre-arrival briefing so there were
no other updates that were provided to
the board about the number of people or
Vehicles expected no I I this was a
formal board meeting but I had been in
regular daily contact with the board
there were calls that took place this
week where the board chair was on with
the mayor and and team so there was a
number of other discussions
Communications formal meetings that took
place in this time frame were questions
around what we had what was coming were
we ready what messaging should we be
providing are you getting enough support
from the city there's a range of other
meetings and Communications this was
just the only formal board meeting right
where where there was specifically for
these events
and if we can go
um to page two
if we look at the first paragraph
they indicated I'm just looking in this
second line there they indicated that
there was a coordination of intelligence
between agencies and the service noted
expecting that the freedom Convoy would
arrive in Ottawa as early as Thursday
and likely remain through Sunday their
destination remained Parliament Hill
questions regarding counter protests and
other protest groups was expressed so
this was the information that was
provided in terms of the expected stay
of the carnivore right yes okay
but at this point there was at least
some indication from intelligence that
there was the possibility that they
could stay longer right through the
Hendon reports and other there was a
possibly that some smaller group could
stay longer as opposed to everybody
arriving was going to be staying longer
okay
um and my understanding was that there
was no in camera portion to this meeting
I honestly at this point can't remember
take your word for it
um so I guess my question is that
the Ops had much more detailed
information about what was expected by
this point in time so my question is why
not share that with the board as you
know they are tasked with oversight and
assisting in in helping to prepare for
these types of events we answer the
questions given to us by the board in
the public meeting and the board has the
opportunity to move the meeting into in
camera if they choose that I can't
control their decision on an in-camera
meeting nor do I control the questions
they ask in the public session right so
so we did ask counselor Deans about this
and she testified that she didn't know
to ask for an in-camera portion because
she wasn't aware that there was
additional information that could have
been provided in camera I will accept
that that was her explanation but as a
board chair in a very experienced board
chair on multiple boards she would have
known that that was an option okay
uh and so I understand you're saying
there were other updates with the chair
but in terms of the board as a body this
was the one briefing that they received
and there were no updated briefings
before the arrival of the Convoy as more
information became available right nor
would there have been time quite frankly
I would have gone to a board meeting if
directed to do so but that would have
probably not been the most optimal use
of our time given the circumstances that
were unfolding okay
um now I want to speak about
uh the injunction that you suggested to
the city or you had a call with the
solicitor Dave David White on January
30th about the possibility of seeking an
injunction ultimately we know that the
city uh did seek an injunction and was
successful but by that time it was quite
uh further along in the events and the
injunction was not actually ever used as
a as an enforcement tool and we're
trying to understand why that's the case
um so you recall you had a call with Mr
White on January 30th about the
possibility of the city seeking an
injunction right and again just by way
of context my recollection again stand
to be corrected was that we had within
the Ottawa Police Service we had
discussed a range of options as
mitigating factors uh risk reducing
factors and injunction was one of them
this was before the arrival of uh the
trucks in the pre-planning phase once
the events unfolded as I've described
earlier on the Saturday
there was an attempt to step that up
and I believe that is the call that
you're you're referencing yes and so
what exactly were you seeking from him
we were seeking to now ask the city to
get involved it would be a city
injunction not an Ottawa Police Service
injunction we had now just seen what had
landed in in our city and so we had a
much better understanding of what we
were facing different from the the sort
of blue skying of well let's consider an
injunction before and so now we're
having a real discussion about the real
problem that is unfolding in our city
and uh asking the city to start to put
their minds clearly too
um the possibility of an injunction but
we were not at this point strongly
recommending or anything we were just
keeping all of our options in the table
and trying to engage the fullest range
of City supports that we could okay and
what was your understanding of what the
injunction would be for
an injunction for what could be a range
of different things and again it would
be the city's injunction it would be
their decision to decide what to put
into its injunction we were giving them
some base level ideas from a policing
perspective but we would not be the only
perspective necessary for them to make a
decision and to include Clauses within
that injunction okay and you felt that
that would fit within ops's overall plan
to have an injunction from the city
at that point we were doing the pivot on
the plan and we were just looking at all
the options that we could okay
now my understanding is that at that
time
um there were enforcement opportunities
that were not being taken because of
lack of resources and potentially the
the the concern that it might incite the
crowd if I will
um maybe just rephrase officers always
have the discretion as to whether or how
to use enforcement actions and certainly
the crowd Dynamics made it very
difficult for them to do that I I know
you phrased it there were enforcement
actions not being taken
officers were applying their discretion
around enforcement
inciting other public safety issues and
officer safety issues would have been
part of that discretion right but I
think we can agree that enforcement was
not being consistently done on every
occasion for various reasons including
lack of resources potential safety
concerns Etc right thank you yes thank
you
thank you so at that time there were
multiple bylaw highway traffic
violations so I'm trying to understand
what more you know considering that
there were violations happening that
were not being enforced what would the
injunction then add to that
well it could have added a range of
different things again it's not an area
of expertise that I have there could
have been heightened fines or could have
been new bylaws passed there could have
been through an injunction maybe there
would be some way to engage other
elements like Insurance bureaus hotels
again it's not an area of expertise I'm
not a lawyer I don't believe I've
actually been involved in the Drafting
and carrying through of an injunction
all the way I would have relied it
almost entirely on my legal services
team to have those conversations and
they would have been entirely informed
by the needs of the incident command
group
fair enough so I'll take you to Ott
three zeros two nine six nine five
and this is an email from David White
city solicitor to Steve kanalakis who's
the city manager and this was after his
discussion with you Mr White's call with
you he emailed the city manager copying
others at the city about the discussion
that he had just had with you so that's
the context for this email in case you
haven't had the chance to see it before
uh so he says I just got off the call
with Chief slowly and his team that is
coordinating the Ops response to the
protest on the issue of an injunction
so then he says this is what they're
looking for
um
and then if we go to the second
paragraph
okay yeah thank you
oh third paragraph excuse me I also took
the opportunity to explain to the chief
that any request for an injunction would
need to be founded in public safety
concerns
while the ops's main concern seems to be
around noise traffic impacts public
frustration based on the idea that the
police should be doing something about
the protest mounting costs air pollution
Etc there does not yet seem to be
significant violence associated with the
event nor much in the way of Public
Safety concern
so I just want to pause there for a
second
is that what you told the city solicitor
on January 30th that there was not much
of a public safety concern
at that point well thank you I can't
imagine why I would ever say that I
think this is the 30th this will be the
Sunday I mean we'd seen we had seen
massive public safety concerns across
the downtown core in the Red Zone
were well publicized on mainstream media
and social media events of assaults
threatening behavior hate incidents
I don't know how he would have taken the
impression from us that these were just
minor bylaw issues
public frustration and who's going to
pay the bill I suspect all those areas
were were part of our discussions but he
would only have to look out of his
window at City Hall to understand what
was happening
um in our in our city at this time a
significant Public Safety event
happening in our city
okay so you did not express to him that
there were no significant public safety
concerns at that time I have no
recollection of that and I couldn't
believe that I would ever express that
okay and he he says according to the
police so do you have any sense where he
would have gotten that information from
perhaps he talked to other people before
or after okay
um
so
there seems to be a bit of a theme of
conflicting narratives here about the
the degree of Public Safety uh
especially in the first week and the
first weekend
um so on the one hand we have the city
being told that you know enforcing
bylaws and
um any laws really was too dangerous for
public safety issues that there was the
risk of violence there was the risk of
injury and death and I can take you to
some notes where that's indicated
um but on the other hand the city was
also told at least in this email seems
to have been told that there wasn't much
in terms of a public safety risk and
we've seen actually from some
eoccg which is the group that manages
the the emergency response on a
municipal level that group was putting
out updates every day and they use
language such as party-like atmosphere
it's festive so there seems to be these
two competing narratives was this
um a Tinderbox waiting to explode or was
this a family-friendly Carnival with
bouncy castles and so I wanted to get
your perspective on those two narratives
um it was a Tender Box waiting to
explode it was not a family Festival
thank you
now my understanding is that in terms of
the discussions of the injunction the
city got to the point where they were
looking at potentially seeking an
injunction for various various things
but they they required Ops to provide
them information that they can then use
to support an application for an
injunction and that was never provided
according to the city witnesses that we
heard from do you have any sense of why
that is none whatsoever this had been
assigned I think
again I may be corrected by
documentation but my recollection is
that Christian you know as general
counsel would have been lead for this
should have relied on the supports of
the incident command team as well as
other planning capabilities outside of
the incident command team within our
general organization to be able to to
address any questions or information
requests
I will say on the spectrum of a million
things we needed to get done in real
time this would probably in the middle
of middle middle to bottom half of it so
it is possible that the city was waiting
for updates but everyone in the
organization my organization was busy on
higher priority items at that point so
that's the best exact Destin explanation
I could give you but there was certainly
no indication that I had that we were
disinterested in supporting it we'd
simply pass it over them and washed our
hands of it okay thank you now I
understand that you were looking to have
the city exercise this kind of political
influence at different levels of
government in order to assist in getting
resources and there were various various
things you had asked them to to look
into and to do on that February 6 email
where you you told them you know we need
1800 officers
um I believe in one of the um and
actually maybe we should go to it
Ott
uh three zeros one eight one seven two
just while that's coming up commissioner
um I have your Indulgence for a second
sir I don't know what the procedure
around this is I was asked a question
earlier on
and I was giving an answer and I changed
Midway through my answer and it may have
sounded like a complete phrase it was a
change of phrase can I just correct the
record
we're just trying to get to the bottom
of things so no there's no and if I get
the problem and in fact if
by the later in the day there's
something new comes to you please
interrupt and put it forward thank you
commissioner um if I get the question
wrong at the context please correct me I
believe you asked me a question to what
extent did I believe that other the
three levels of government had lost
confidence or trust in in me and I
believe part of my response was I felt
that all three levels had expressed very
low what I was about to say was very and
then I changed to low
came across I believe is very low I just
want that corrected for the record if
that's so the answer was very no it was
low low but I had experienced
incidents where there was clearly some
level of low level of lack of confidence
in the organization from all three
levels of government
so this is the email of February 6. if
we go to the first email of the thread
right okay and go up a little bit so we
can see uh who it's from
yeah keep going yeah right there so it's
John steinbox from the Ops and it's to
chair Deans and the mayor and others uh
in Ottawa uh within and you as well and
if we go down
chair Dean's and mayor Watson please
find below the list of Ottawa Police
Service asks to the federal provincial
and Municipal levels of government that
was requested Yesterday by the board so
as my colleague pointed out on the 5th
of February you were asked to provide a
number of resources that you required as
well as other requirements that that you
needed in order to bring this to an end
and if we go down
we see that you have some asks there
from the city
and I wanted to just briefly ask you
about a few of these if we go down
okay so here and actually this is an
interesting question because
um I think we touched on it earlier but
maybe didn't get a clear answer so it
says there the service requires 1800
Addis additional Staffing and
enforcement resources so this is I think
the first reference that we see to the
1800 ask
and this is on February 6 I believe it's
at 407 pm
there is later a meeting that you have
with chair Deans and the mayor in which
you provide them that number as well and
then the following day you send them an
email with a chart you might recall that
chart and that was on February 7th so
the question was
um you had been asked by the board to
come up with the number of resources
that you required to end end the protest
on February 5th and on February 6th at 4
30 you send this email so at what point
did you determine the number of
additional resources you needed and how
because my understanding is the meeting
that happened later with your command
team was after this email was sent in
the evening at 7 45. yeah and again I my
recollection is that as soon as that
board meeting ended on the fifth we
turned our attention to start getting
the information we need
um so I I don't I'm not aware of notes
inscribe notes that say my executive
officer and my EA started to assign
things to CAO dunker but there is no way
that I would have left that board
meeting with that request in front of us
and the extremely short timelines and
simply waited 24 hours later to start to
have people thinking about it
so that's just my recollection and I
stand to be corrected if that proves to
be wrong okay so your understanding is
that February 5th in the evening you
would have had a meeting as soon as that
board meeting was over we would debrief
right away as we would with any board
meeting at the end of it what are the
substantive issues that came out what do
we need to do what are the timelines and
certainly in this meeting that was the
direction that needed our full focus and
it would not have simply waited till the
end of the next day to get to okay yeah
I just don't think we have in our in our
documents a meeting on February 5th in
the evening where resource numbers were
discussed so I think that's the question
that we're kind of left wondering with
um and so uh if we look at the third
bullet point professional mediation and
negotiation capacity
um what were you asking for there
again we were trying to think of
anything that could assist us the
concept of mediation and negotiation was
clearly a live discussion at many levels
in the organization and many levels of
government and so any particular advice
supports expertise that we or the city
could uh could bring in could be helpful
okay
um and so with that in mind you're
asking the city to exercise its
political influence and to look into
professional mediation even
um
you're aware on February 6th it's also
the day that the city of Ottawa declared
a state of emergency do you recall that
I don't recall it but I'm not
challenging the date of it uh and so
according to some of the documents that
we've seen and the evidence the
expressed intent of that declaration or
at least one of the reasons for that
decoration was to put pressure on the
premier to exercise powers to resolve
the situation in Ottawa
um
did you ask the mayor to declare a state
of emergency I was involved in
discussions around it I've been involved
in those had been involved in those
discussions in my time in Toronto for a
variety of reasons and literally every
time it ever came up in Toronto was
it may get you some money transfer
payments it might get you access to
certain resources but it's not going to
give you
the Declaration of state of emergency in
our context here in the province
Province isn't the same as it is in
other jurisdictions in other countries
so it has
put my police officer hat on limited
efficacy to support policing operations
and I have
limited understanding of how it supports
other City functions but even there my
understanding is it is by no means even
close to being a silver bullet sure but
it can exercise some political leverage
can it not I can't speak to political
leverage I can only tell you what
practically it would provide for a
jurisdiction and in my case a police of
jurisdiction okay fair enough
um so
I wanted to just ask about the legal
opinion that you had received in which
you said you believe based on that
opinion that you were not able to block
access to trucks entering downtown did I
get that right
I wouldn't put it that way okay how
would you put it we had a legal opinion
sorry can you just frame your question
again please sure my understanding is
that
pre-convoy or when I when the Convoy
arrived um we we saw an opinion in any
event that was dated January 28
um and I assume you saw it sometime
after that no um we requested on the
27th it arrived on the 28th I don't know
the date that I saw it but it was still
in and around that time and again the
event started on the 27th went through
the 28th heightened on the 29th and
continued to the 30th so it arrived in
the middle of the event not prior to the
event okay and that goes to the heart of
my question
um councilor Fleury was here some time
ago a few weeks ago now and he testified
that at the pre-convoy briefing with you
and the city manager the mayor
counselors this was on January 26th uh
he had specifically asked about
maintaining truck routes in the city and
you said to him in answer to that
question on the 26th that you had a
legal opinion that said that the charter
prevented you from doing that that's
what he told us so I want to understand
what would have been the basis for your
understanding that the charter prevented
that on the 26th of January
when you didn't receive the legal
opinion until the 28th was there another
legal opinion probably my general
counsel I mean I don't have an
independent election recollection but
before we go outside for a legal opinion
I would usually run it by my own general
counsel okay
um and you testified that by the 29th on
the Saturday I thought I heard you say
this morning that the demonstration was
an unlawful demonstration is that right
by virtue of the first law broken in and
around it okay and so what did you mean
by that what were the laws broken too
many to list
can you give me a sense like are we
talking criminal code violations about
provincial offenses act criminal code
Federal statutes too many to list okay
so bylaw highway traffic act offenses
okay
um
so my question is
with respect to the first weekend I
think it could be assumed that 3 000
vehicles in the downtown core would lead
necessarily to highway traffic act and
bylaw violations right
I'm sorry just I may admit I may have
missed your question that just having 3
000 Vehicles would mean that there would
be offenses within a limited space would
necessarily mean some violations such as
blocking traffic parking illegally
in the context of a protest yes we
probably have more than 3 000 vehicles
in the downtown Corner in Ottawa on any
given day
right but I'm talking about uh you know
3 000 tractor trailers and big heavy
vehicles coming into the downtown in a
in a space that had been designated for
them to be there right but but they
weren't designated to be there uh to be
legally parked clearly they were all
going to be taking up lanes and
preventing uh traffic and Etc I I think
I understand your question and so I'm
trying to be delivered to my answer
um I can't imagine that the PLT would
have negotiated hey when you come in you
can break our laws
I suspect and I haven't seen PLT log
notes but when you come in in order to
not break our laws in order to maintain
the free flow of emergency vehicles in
order to not create as many problems as
Could Happen we're going to try to get
you to do these several things Park your
vehicles here carpool right right share
downtown we will designate areas where
you can park your trucks and in
designating those areas it would be the
police facilitating that as opposed to
an independent decision by a truck
driver or pickup truck driver to violate
the law on their own
through their own decision making that's
different from us trying to facilitate a
peaceful lawful protest okay so then
um I'm just trying to understand what
changed from the moment they arrived to
the 29th what additional uh violations
would have occurred it seems to me that
by the time they arrive those violations
would have already been crystallized
yeah I'm not sure I understand the
question but if I try to answer it if I
get it wrong please redirect me
um and we've heard some I think very
helpful effort okay I want to be careful
I've I've I'm aware that inspector Lucas
describes
a situation where there's sort of a race
to Wellington Street and it seems that
that is one of one of not the only but
one of the main factors that seems to
kind of end the agreed
levels of cooperation that had been
achieved through a lot of hard work by
these plts it then becomes a series of
snake-like efforts to move heavy
vehicles and lots of vehicles through
the downtown core and the traffic plan
that had been set up had to be in real
time rearranged all of that chaos yes in
all of that we started to see
significant levels of bylaw provincial
offenses act violations
not to mention those who were either
walking riding or in any other
conveyance starting to do
a wide array of social
disorder threatening and intimidating
Behavior physically and psychologically
assaultive behavior and yes hate related
behavior and ultimately criminal code
violations all of which happen in near
real time over the morning and early
afternoon and throughout the remainder
of the time of the events in the city
so um so if by the 29th it had become an
unlawful demonstration
why was access not prevented into the
downtown core by the second weekend the
5th of February when additional convoys
came and joined
by then surely that you would have the
authority you've touched on one of my
frustrations
was not my intention
that is why there's clear documentation
of me saying are we ready to go
have we thought about all the things we
need to do
have we considered whether we're going
to be closing more roads more Highway
off ramps more bridges based on what we
learned from last weekend and what we've
seen in other jurisdictions
and I was really kicking the tires hard
on that
and that is why on the third weekend I
issued my only direct order at the
operational level close the
inter-provincial bridges and close the
highways that give direct access to the
downtown core I rescinded that only when
the then Incident Commander sorry event
Commander Rob Bernier articulated a
substantially robust traffic management
plan to address the circumstances that
were happening at that time and it
turned out to be a very successful plan
but that remained a significant concern
for me and for the organization there
were more roads closed on the second
weekend there were more effective
coordination around the inter-provincial
bridges there was more assistance with
the opp on monitoring traffic along the
king's highways but I really still had a
lot of concerns about that right the
downtown core was never hardened so to
speak in in the fullest sense meaning
that we blocked off
all of the access off ramps which I saw
as a private citizen no to that level
that level of hardening did not exist in
the three weekends that I was a chief of
police for okay
um
I want to turn to Ops
four zeros five six six five
and this these are notes from a command
briefing on February 1st
and I'll take you to page three
and I think you testified today that by
the 30th you had recognized some
elements of an occupation as opposed to
a demonstration is that right yes ma'am
um and so
it says that first point if more
demonstrators are expected back this
weekend early requests for resources is
required decision on whether this is an
occupation needs to be made by tomorrow
use experienced resources I.E Rob Bernie
and others pull from sections why did
there need to be a decision about how to
kind of classify this kind of a
demonstration whether it was an
occupation or not what what turned on
that I I this is the first time I'm
seeing the email I don't know the
context of the meeting
seems to be Kenny Brighton sorry
inspector Bryden would be within the
intelligence directorate so I I don't
know the nature of this
fair enough and if we can go to the
bottom of page two
and trying to find my
my reference yeah just at the bottom
the third line from the bottom plts have
done an excellent job in preventing
rioting and de-escalation but overall
position and change needs to happen
looking more like an occupation than a
negotiated end if we can just keep going
too many photos of police with
protesters trucks Chief would like this
addressed
now this you also conveyed the sentiment
to the mayor and to the counselors on
the 31st explaining that you didn't
think that this was okay photos being
taken between police officers and
protesters so I just wanted to ask
inspector Lucas testified this week that
this was part of de-escalation that this
was trust building it seems like you
might have had a different view so I
just wanted to ask about that yeah no
I'm not sure where you got the
information that I said it was not a
good thing
Council okay so I'll take you to Ops
four zeros 5187
and this is notes of a meeting that you
had with the mayor so
um update from Chief and if we go to the
bottom whose notes through these
um Michael Anderson sent these to John
steinbach's
um it's a it's points of the meeting
that happened on the 31st update from
mayor to Chief and then there's you give
an update first and then it looks like
the mayor has some things to say after
okay so if we go to seven if we go to
the page seven
foreign
I believe there were counselors here at
this meeting as well
so at 7f
councilor Menard says curious on why
certain behaviors are being allowed to
continue not peaceful need to move on
from that language want services to be
maintained and acts of hatred to be
addressed residents should not feel
intimidated bylaw Services should
continue
and so F seems to be your answer I had
asked one of the witnesses who was
answering these questions and I believe
it was Mr kenlakis said that for the
most part you would answer these
questions
and so
the last line there officers posing in
images is unacceptable and are following
up
um
again
sorry I can give you more context if you
like there's there's another notation
your last full day in office of February
14 when you also kind of address the
same issue and if it's helpful I can
take you to that Ops
three zeros one four five six six
and these are I believe
your notes
and if we go to 1932
or sorry 932
okay so Chief's morning brief
um
if you look at
the first point media report two times
jtf2 do you know what that references
what that is
between Task Force officers okay we're
supporting the demo here in Ottawa
supporting the command and control of it
now being investigated internally
Pat Morris last night
I assume this means indicated that he
was not indicted correct
not that I'm aware of okay uh Pat Morris
last night indicated we might have a
significant issue with police members
being involved in demos so I just wanted
to ask about about that Concept in
general how did the public was seeing
this the public was pushing back a
little bit
um and so what is your view on on that
thank you um the language used around
the officers posing in photos are
problematic to me if I was
not clear in my language I'll accept
that
um I I accept and adopt the view as as
relayed by uh inspector Lucas officers
will often have to do a fist bump or
lean in for a selfie just to try to keep
the temperature down and the
circumstances they're in
um that is just the the the reality of
almost any circumstance any date not
even requiring something of this level
just in order to try to build rapport in
a minute so to keep things at the right
level or de-escalate things that could
be escalating and I'll always defer to
an officer on that in the broader sense
I could understand and maybe that's
where my comments were attributed in the
broader sense these photos
that are being going viral on social
media without proper context
could be extremely problematic and were
extremely problematic they were used
extensively in the social media
disinformation and misinformation
campaigns and unfortunately crept into
some of the mainstream media reporting
as well I think it's more in that
context that I would be talking about it
as opposed to every single officer I saw
in a photograph doing a fist bump or a
thumbs up was unacceptable I that's
never been my experience and I would
have done the same things and had done
the same things throughout my policing
career I wouldn't expect to be
sanctioned by a superior officer if they
took the time to find out as to why I
was doing it and do you think this might
have contributed to the erosion of the
resident's trust in the Ops there's no
doubt that the the photographs of
officers sometimes there weren't even
officers in the Ottawa theater that were
being passed around on social media
saying look what's happening in Ottawa
so there was just a lot of that going on
and I can understand why the public
without the context that we're sharing
here now we'll just look at that and say
oh that's sympathy from the officers to
the movement or various movements
represented there
I talk now about the role of the board
um how would you describe the board's
oversight function
what is the scope of their oversight
primarily to set the Strategic direction
of of the police of jurisdiction ensure
that the police of jurisdiction has
adequate resources to develop to deliver
adequate and effective services and to
hire and and manage the the chief of
police and the two deputy chief
positions well in this in our case two
deputy chief position and what's your
understanding of the board's role in a
major event
in in the same respect they they have an
oversight body or does it align to
strategic purposes is it are there any
policies that that get that come into
play are there adequate resources what
is the performance of
uh Chief in command and and through them
the performance of the organization and
do they have a role on going throughout
the duration of a major event
they have the same role ongoing every
single day regardless of whether there's
a major event or not
um can I take you to Ops
three zeros one four four eight four
and I'll take you to page 36.
and I believe these are some of your
notes
we've seen these before notes about
meetings that you've that you often make
to yourself and this one's dated
February 5th uh subject line is call
from Cheer Deans
uh
I understand here she's uh she's called
you for a board meeting and you say I
advise that I was fully focused on the
major demonstration and all other
operational priorities I can refuse a
board Direction I assume that means
can't yes very much so okay I can't
refuse a board direction for a meeting
but I stated that I would put my ability
to lead the service in this critical
operation in Jeopardy and should be
delayed until Monday so
um was it fair to say that these
meetings were distracting you from your
operational responsibilities not
distracting I understand the need that
the board was trying to fulfill but
every minute every hour
where one or all of the command and
supporting Personnel were not focused on
managing the events
was less resources that we could put to
those events less leadership that we
could provide to support those who were
leading those events so it's there's
only a finite amount of time in any day
and on some days I spent
three four hours on board meetings and
had my two Deputy Chiefs there as well I
think in every occasion we had the full
command team there so I understand it's
not a distraction but it is a demand on
time and it's in that context of Demand
on time
and um from her testimony last week we
understand that the board started asking
for more information and more details of
an operational plan to bring an end to
the demonstration as of about February
5th there was some more pressure to
provide that information would you is
that a fair assessment yes
um and if I can take you to the meeting
minutes of that board meeting on
February 5th OPB
four zeros one two six four
and at um page five
paragraph two
although the board expressed frustration
at the lack of clearly outlined plan
that would result in the end of the
demonstration the service noted having
articulated a framework aimed at their
Surge and contained strategy so what did
you understand the board to be
requesting in terms of information at
this time
just what they're asking for a clearly
outlined plan that will result in the
end of the demonstration okay and you
were not able to provide that to the
board not on February 5th ma'am no okay
and why was that because there was no
way to end the demonstration with the
resources we had at that time and we
were in the process of pivoting the plan
to put that in place
um
so there wasn't a fully formed plan that
you could take still evolving that plan
from the pre-planning piece we're still
trying to gather the resources necessary
to move from Simply at this point on
February 5th still just holding on to
the Red Zone and not allowing anything
else in there but not really able to do
much more than that
right
um so this meeting did go in camera and
I'm going to take you to the in-camera
meeting minutes uh OPB four zeros one
six four seven
and so at page two
uh the fourth paragraph
sorry if we can oh sorry yeah at the
bottom the LA the paragraph at the
bottom the chief
reassured the board that there was a
comprehensive plan however he could not
provide all the details of what the
service was doing operationally so I
just want to marry that with the concept
that by February 5th there was not
actually a a well kind of conceived
fully formed plan but the board is being
told there is a comprehensive plan so I
just want to give you a chance to
reconcile that it's not much
reconciliation I mean there's a
comprehensive plan we've looked at the
full range of issues from PLT to Pou
enforcement intelligence gathering
traffic we are engaging in all sorts of
efforts to to it to get resources into
the organization it's comprehensive
just not into the detailed levels of sub
plans and
dates and times when operations will
take place assuming that there are
resources available
so comprehensive it covers the full
range of what we need to have in a plan
lacking the details in order to be able
to say a week from now with these 1800
resources we should have the ability to
execute a Pou plan in the morning of and
by the end of the evening we should have
cleared 75 percent of the Red Zone I
couldn't give them that
right but they're asking for a plan that
would result in the end of the
demonstration
and you're saying well there's a
comprehensive plan don't worry it's a
comprehensive framework I don't know if
plan is the sense that that that's the
reconciliation I can give you okay now
councilor Dean's testified that she
understood there was an evolving plan
but she was asking for details about a
plan to end the demonstration which was
not provided to her because there was no
at that point there was no plan that we
could say this will end the
demonstration right so had there been
that plan or once that plan was
developed my understanding is the board
never never saw a plan or even a high
level or even a summary of the plan
um so even by the time it was developed
that was not provided to the board so I
just wanted to ask why that would be
well I can't speak to the final plan
that was used in the week of after the
15th of February so I don't know what
was provided or not provided by then
interim Chief bill
well I'm asking about your time not
about internships we never provided the
operational plan in its totality in a
bound document to the board let me be
clear about one thing
Ottawa Police Services Board
provided a lot of support to the service
and to
myself our executive team on a range of
issues
but there was a challenge around
confidentiality on that board
there were clearly documented
events where service information board
information including in-camera
discussions had been leaked by board
members to the public
and so there was a concern prior to the
arrival in the events of the Convoy
around the confidential that the ability
of the board to keep confidential
information confidential
and was how was that being addressed
I had formal documentation and
correspondence with Venture Deans around
those concerns and specifically pointing
to those events it was up to her to
investigate and and remediate whatever
issues I never got a final update from
chair Deans as to the outcome of those
concerns right but your obligation to
provide the board the information they
need in terms of to be able to exercise
their oversight function that's
irrespective of whatever internal issues
the board may be dealing with on its own
right it is a factor that came into my
consideration as to the level of detail
that I could provide on intelligence
threat risk assessments operational plan
or other operational details so is your
evidence that the reason that more
information on the operational plan was
not provided to the board because you
had confidentiality concerns about that
board specifically my evidence is that
is one of the factors I had to consider
yes okay and so what were the other
factors
that I was not going to be handing over
an entire detailed operational plan to
the board it's not a practice I'd ever
seen done before it's not one that I'd
be comfortable with and from my
knowledge of the Morton report not one
that's required okay but a summary
wasn't provided either right no we did
provide summaries on a regular basis in
terms of like a document which provides
a high level summary
a document no in hours-long board
meetings we all dedicated to this we
were asked repeatedly questions and
provided as much information as we
possibly could I can't recall whether or
not somebody provided a summary document
that I can't recall okay well uh chair
Dean's testified that at times she did
not have the information she needed in
order to exercise her oversight function
does that concern you not at all well
concerns me that she would characterize
it that way I had daily calls sometimes
twice and three times daily calls with
chair Danes we offered the board and
they accepted to do ride-alongs I think
four of the seven board members actually
participated in ride-alongs that were by
my service sergeant major who actually
put them in a police vehicle and drove
them throughout the the theater in safe
ways they had hours with with the
service sergeant major to ask any
questions that they wanted I had given
explicit instructions to the service
sergeant major to answer those questions
as fully and honestly as possible so we
went through a variety of means Beyond
public meetings to ensure that the board
could literally see and be in the
theater talk to Frontline officers have
direct access to the chief of police
on a regular basis on a daily basis
including the formal board meetings I
can't understand why charadines would
say that she did not have the ability to
ask questions and receive information in
a very timely manner okay I'll take you
to Ops 3011037
and these are again uh your notes these
are from February 11.
and I'll take you to page six of your
notes
and if we go to 1301
there where it says call back from Diane
Dean's 1301.
and then it says expectations for board
meeting gonna do like we did on Monday
minimum level cannot and won't be drawn
into what I cannot lawfully provide
I.E Staffing numbers what the plans are
need you to be clear and understanding
about that and if we keep going
the response will be as much as we gave
you on Monday cannot go into the
confidential
accusatory language and request for
information that is unlawful for me to
provide you will not be provided
she is accusing us of not responding to
crimes we don't respond to Twitter she
needs to report any threats was reported
to Stephanie Lemieux encourage the board
to not ask questions which cannot be
answered operationally
so I want to ask you a few questions
about that it sounds like that was part
of your exchange with chair Deans on
February 11.
what did you mean by gonna do like we
did on Monday minimum level
is this are you referring to the the
amount of information that you're going
to give her I'm going to be consistent
with what we've been doing all along
we're not going to be not going to be
changing and deviating from that so
minimum level well I I don't know what
that what that means I know these are my
scribe notes
we're going to be consistent with what
we did on Monday is a substantive theme
that I'm trying to relay there
when you just to go up a little bit to
the first part of that exchange
um so when you say cannot I won't be
drawn into what I cannot lawfully
provide I.E Staffing numbers what the
plans are you're indicating there that
the board is not entitled to those right
Staffing numbers and what the plans are
detailed plans detailed Staffing numbers
how many we're going to have on this
shift that shift in public meetings and
documents
those are problematic questions
why is that
for all the reasons that have been
explained before we're just it's
this was a unique event that's for sure
but
the types of questions we were getting
repeatedly over and over and over again
what is the plan to end this what
like why do I'm looking out my window
now I can't see a police officer out
there
unfortunately these were these were the
types of questions that just couldn't be
answered and we're taking up hours of
our time literally at these meetings
and then you say cannot go into the
confidential
um in camera would have allowed you to
go into the confidential I don't think
I'm referring to in camera there I
cannot go into the confidential elements
of what we're doing I think is what I
was trying to say there I would have
said in camera
right but my question is can't you get
into confidential matters in camera yes
and I think at the previous meeting
what's the date of this February 11th
right at the previous meeting I think
I'd urged them at least three or four
separate times on the February 5th
meeting let's go on camera okay so you
are saying you can give confidential
information as long as it's in camera I
can give more information on camera I
wasn't at that point committing to give
everything that I was being asked but I
certainly could give more information in
camera okay
um and what did you mean what what did
you understand to be unlawful for you to
provide in terms of information and what
made it unlawful
it's probably more loose language
um
I don't know if it would have meant
unlawful but I certainly wouldn't be
giving there are unlawful information on
human resources things conduct
information that wouldn't necessarily be
lawful for me to provide but I'm not
sure what the actual reference there is
in in your view as you sit here today is
there any information that you lawfully
cannot provide an oversight board
I'm sure that there would be something
that would be allow for that to happen
much where I could give members
blood type or something like that but
there might be some limits on that but I
think in general we can share the
information of the organization
generally the board is entitled to any
information they need in order to there
may be some restrictions that I'm not an
expert on privacy or human rights to be
able to say that you know there's
there's health information that we would
have in the records of the Ottawa Police
Service that relates to a member's
psychological assessment that I could
hand over in complete
free form to the board right but I mean
the the board as you know takes an oath
of confidentiality right I know that and
they had broken that at least on one
occasion during my tenure so that oath
of confidentiality doesn't mean that
there aren't problems with the board's
ability to maintain its oath of
confidentiality right and I guess what
I'm saying is the whatever board the the
issues the board may have does not
alleviate your responsibility to provide
information right you're right but it
does cause me to have to be very careful
under the conditions that I do it and
this was a national security event
um so you would agree with me then that
under the police services act there's no
restriction on the information that can
be provided subject to other acts and
legislation I would agree with you sure
and so right now there's nothing
specifically that you can point me to to
say it would be it's unlawful for me to
provide this type of information right
now my understanding is that during
these events the board did not issue any
formal directions to you as it can
sometimes do Under the police services
act it did Issue a direction to meet to
provide the Staffing numbers on the
February 5th meeting okay and that was a
formal direction from the board okay so
aside from that did the board ever
specifically direct you to provide more
information as as a Direction
I don't recall now okay
now had they specifically directed you
to provide them with a copy of the plan
once it was then formulated uh the 3.0
that we that we hear about would that
have been provided to the board if it
was a formal Direction I probably would
have had to get consultation with my
general counsel
and then assuming that there was no
prohibition we probably would have
provided what we could and that would
largely be a heavily redacted document
now we've heard from some counselors
um that they were concerned that the
ability of Ops to police other areas of
the city was compromised during the
Convoy because all of the resources were
concentrated in the downtown area
you're aware of those concerns yes
so I want to take you to the Morden
report com
[Music]
50616 and we've talked before about the
morning report and I know you're very
familiar with it so we'll go to page 37.
just for clarity I read it probably 12
years ago but I am familiar with it okay
pendant review Into the events of the
G20 for those who may not be familiar
um and it's often referred to as the
Morton report it was authored in 2012.
and if we go to recommendation 22.
the board should review the Toronto
police services continuity of service
plan for major policing events where
there is a large event that may impact
upon the service's ability to deliver
regular policing officers in in this
case Toronto the board should consult
with the chief of police concerning how
continuity of service can be achieved
the board should be provided with any
plans developed by the Toronto Police
Service to Aid in the consultation
uh so I wanted to ask whether the board
was ever our board the Ottawa Police
Services Board uh was ever provided with
plans with respect to the continuity of
service in areas outside of the downtown
core they weren't they didn't request
any continuity plans but we would
briefed them on our ability to maintain
business across the rest of the police
services across the rest of the of the
municipality while we're dealing with
the incident command as well okay so
they didn't uh they didn't receive any
plans but informal briefing it's
explaining what the plan was essentially
um
all right
I want to turn now to
negotiations with the city
and
I think you're aware maybe you can
explain whether you were aware that on
February 7th some protesters asked to
meet with the city manager in exchange
for facilitating a move from the Rito
and Sussex intersection to Wellington
were you aware of that at that time I I
I was not aware of it I became aware of
some level of PLT related negotiations
happening around that location that came
up through superintendent Patterson and
acting deputy chief Ferguson had a
briefing
uh so
my understanding is that meeting between
the city manager and the pro and the
protester in question was Mr marazzo
took place on February 8 but then the
move from Rito and Sussex to Wellington
never happened and according to
superintendent Drummond who was here on
Wednesday he said that the move had not
been approved and uh and I said by whom
and he indicated that it had not been
approved by uh superintendent Patterson
or by yourself as well so um I just want
to understand
um
why that move would not have been
approved I'm superintendent Patterson's
decision I gave no decision on that okay
um and earlier than the eighth my
understanding is there was also a
potential move from the Rito and Sussex
again to Wellington that had been
negotiated by PLT
um after the January the first weekend
so it would have been around the Monday
after that first weekend the 31st there
was a PLT negotiated potential move from
Rito and Sussex to Wellington at that
earlier time
and according to uh inspector Lucas uh
he said that
um that had been negotiated but that the
Direction came from you to prevent that
move from happening so I wanted to ask
about your I think I gave no directions
in regards to PLT actions
and were you generally aware that the
Parliamentary Protective Service had
concerns about moving more trucks onto
Wellington after that first weekend
um my recollection of the first time
hearing that directly was when
is ranked wrong but Larry brookson who
is the head of the Parliamentary
Protection Services raised that I think
on the weekend of the 13th 14th with me
directly
um
and when you first learned of
negotiations between the city of Ottawa
and protesters I believe was around the
12th of February
and is it fair to say that you were
generally
um receptive to the mayor's office
negotiating with protesters to come up
with some sort of negotiated Solution on
one
well one maybe two singular cats two two
caveats it cannot cannot direct policing
operations and it cannot run counter to
the operational plan that was under
under the control of the incident
command team okay uh so on February 12th
my understanding is you received a call
from Steve kanlakis advising you that
over the last 24 hours there have been
some discussions
um and then you had a meeting after that
with
um
deputy chief Bell and Miss Hano to
inform them of that call
um and my understanding is that
Mr kanalakis had indicated to you that
these these discussions were
confidential because they were ongoing
they hadn't been finalized yet
and my understanding is that in that
subsequent meeting with deputy chief
Bell and Miss Hano
um you asked deputy chief Bell to also
keep that information confidential right
um did you see any
did you have any concerns about having
to tell him to keep it confidential were
there and do you see any issues with
that the fact that you asked him to to
not share that with anybody else in
hindsight yes at the time I thought it
was reasonable okay and you thought it
was reasonable
why there were just negotiations that
were ongoing there hadn't been a final
outcome at this point it didn't have any
major impact on our operations any
impact on our operations and since then
your view you're saying has changed so
what's your view of that now probably
one of those areas I would wanted to
share down One More Level into the at
least to the event Commander
who would have been superintendent
Bernie at the time right the date sorry
again February 12th yes
uh and so with that caveat that you gave
us before about wanting to make sure
that these negotiations fit within the
overall plan informing superintendent
Bernier on the 12th or the earliest that
you learned about it would have
facilitated ensuring that those
negotiations meshed or fit into the
overall plan right no
um would have given him situational
awareness but I would have told him you
keep working on your plan because in
this thing may fall apart I don't we
didn't have the time or the effort to be
putting a lot of resources into planning
for something that hadn't been
negotiated and might never happen anyway
so I would have given him for
situational awareness but not to give
him more work to be done around it
right but for example he could have
contacted the mayor's office and put
some parameters around the negotiations
or no because sorry I shouldn't
interrupt you I apologize no go ahead
um please finish your question because I
want to make sure I answer properly that
was the question okay
um
I I would not have wanted
uh anybody in my organization
to then get involved directly in the
negotiation with between the city and I
believe it's Mr French
um and the Convoy organizers I didn't
want the Ottawa Police Service to be
directly involved in that negotiation
why is that
it was a political negotiation
but again
if it's being done separately from the
ops's plans there is the potential of
conflict isn't there and if there was I
would have defaulted to the Ops plans
right but if something is negotiated
without Ops input
can Ops then prevent it from moving
forward that was the condition I gave to
Steve kanalakis when he had called me
okay
um
so you wanted to ensure then that the
city's negotiations was completely
independent from the ops's plan yes okay
um despite the fact that this was a
police-led operation and the police was
the lead agency in the response
yes
uh and then the February 13 in that
morning you got a call from Steve
kanalakis confirming that there had been
an agreement reached letters would be
exchanged
Etc right
um
I believe then at noon there was a
meeting with City officials called by
Steve kanalakis
um and the people who were on that call
were Steve kanalakis yourself deputy
chief Bell and acting deputy chief
Ferguson and a subsequent meeting then
took place
um to inform a broader group of of your
team right
now I understand that day
um shortly after 1 pm you called OPP
commissioner karik to update him on the
negotiations with the city right yes yes
so he knew as of February 13 at around
1pm I believe that's the timing yes uh
on that call did he express any concerns
to you
actually don't have an independent
recollection
okay
but I don't recall anything being
substantively
discussed okay uh and Drummond testifies
superintendent Drummond rather testified
that at that subsequent meeting with the
broader team was the first time that he
learned about those negotiations and he
said everybody on the call was
cautiously optimistic is that was that a
chord with with your with my general
recollection yes
uh and then after that meeting you
called RCMP commissioner Brenda lucky
um and she said she was aware of the
negotiations
um did she express any concerns to you
at that time I don't recall any again
sorry I don't have my notes I don't have
an a clear independent recollection okay
so we're required to carry out
um ops's assistance to care to
implementing that that deal I don't know
I just wouldn't know the level of lift
but I suspect it would be we didn't have
a lot of resources to spare so any
amount of resources could be considered
significant okay and so if I take you
now to just the next day which is
February 14
um I want to take you to Ops
3014566 and these are uh your notes
again and I'll take you to page eight
and at 1631
so just to give you some context the
truck started moving at 1 pm on this day
um it was decided
um that that evening on the on the 13th
the night before uh superintendent
Drummond went and and coordinated kind
of the details and the following morning
it was to start it didn't start until
1pm and this is now at 4 30 PM that same
day so trucks have been moving for the
last three hours give or take
uh so you have a team's call with
brookson so maybe you can explain who
brookson is it's Larry brookson who is
leading the Parliamentary protection
services and I apologize I don't know
his can't remember his rank or his title
yes and I'm not sure either so we can we
can go with Mr brookson
he said trying to get understand the
meeting to completely fill up Wellington
Street
and then you say Chief briefed his team
understood that the intersect team would
then brief everyone including PPS
so is it fair to say that you had
reached out to the opp commissioner and
to the RCMP commissioner but you didn't
reach out to PPS and he's essentially
calling you out on it and saying why
don't you let me know is that
essentially what's happening here no
that's not how I took it okay so maybe
just explain that that discussion
um he's concerned about not being aware
of it which I can appreciate fully but
I'm explaining that the
the major incident command event
commander and Incident Commander would
be able to brief all of our partners in
the NCR and everybody who was
contributing to at that point an
integrated operation about what was
taking place that day and that my
understanding was PBS was part of that
intersect team and would have received
that briefing I didn't get the
impression that Larry brookson was
calling me out or the audible Police
Service out okay and if we just go down
there's more to the discussion
um so again these are Point form notes
it's hard to really get a good sense for
what's being kind of conveyed here but
maybe you can review those Point form
notes and and give us a better sense of
what transpired in that discussion
and specifically I want to understand
the references to does City usually
direct police on how this goes I don't I
don't know what that reference is I
looked at that myself I don't know it's
obviously would be from brookson sorry
Larry brookson Mr brookson um but again
it's hard to like you said it's a back
and forth
sort of almost real-time attempt to get
to get the full conversation
and then the note for an administrator
to reach out on their own and then
permit the vehicles to sardine in on
Wellington Street this was purely
political
what was the discussion around that
point
I I remember Mr Brooks expressing his
concern around around the politics and
as I've said there was a lot of politics
going on all around this at so many
levels
um but I don't know who he's referring
to as an administrator
so I just want to confirm that by this
time certainly he's telling you that
trucks have moved on to Wellington so
you knew by this time correct
I I understood by this time I still to
this day have some confusion as to as to
that portion of things but clearly by
this time I would have known that trucks
are on Wellington Street okay um and
your witness statement says you didn't
know but I think we can agree that you
did know this is probably uh yes okay
um and then my understanding is that
1701 so you have this discussion with
him you're not able to give me too much
more than what's there it sounds like
based on your recollection if we can go
to page is this still page nine yet 1701
um so it looks like there's a demo
briefing call at 501
and the second bullet we see Trish
that's uh acting Deputy treat uh deputy
chief Ferguson lots of convo with Carson
at NOK uh PPS not happy with trucks on
Wellington
um and
at the bottom it says had to Pivot due
to new do you have any sense there it
seems to be some words missing at the
end of that do you have any sense for
what that's referring to
foreign
no I don't sorry okay and if we go to
page 10
the bullet before the redaction
we need or write the the last the first
redactive portion the bullet before we
need some significant legal advice
regarding the mayor's position that they
can be on Wellington
um can you just explain what that refers
to
I don't know I apologize
okay
um are you able to give us any insight
into what was the issue
that was uh that was concerning
I mean it seems to be all a discussion
around the relative
sequence of the sequence of events that
took place throughout the day the
relative efficacy of it
challenges experience logistical
Staffing there's plts referenced there
so it's a general discussion it seems to
be for who's leading and who's making
what points so this is the the day
before you resigned at 5 PM so I don't
know if that helps to situate you in the
timeline of events and if you have a
recollection of this meeting it would
have been one of your final meetings
no it's just another another busy
briefing on on a big
difficult period of time and we know
that after this meeting
um certainly by Nightfall on that day no
more trucks were relocated onto
Wellington and that kind of ended the
facilitation of trucks onto Wellington
do you have any sense for why
um what was the reason behind uh Ops no
longer supporting the movement of trucks
onto Wellington I I I I don't I mean
I've subsequent through disclosure I've
seen things so I don't know if it that
makes my opinion valid at this point but
I understand my understanding is without
getting into any more detail than that
is that the um event Commander made a
decision to discontinue the operations
and the only thing I can say to that is
that would be entirely within his
purview that was the caveat I gave to
city manager uh Cadillac I said if at
any point the the the operations around
the negotiation
cross purposes with the operational plan
that we would default to our operational
plan okay so you can't tell us why I
don't know okay
uh so just quickly uh
last time we spoke in in our interview I
asked you about kind of Lessons Learned
we talked a little bit about that today
you spoke with Mr Owl about that
um and uh I asked you if in your kind of
reflection since these events
um you had thought about anything you
could have done differently as chief of
police and at that time you mentioned
you know clarifying your comment about
there may not be a policing solution
which I understand you've done that now
um but nothing nothing really else came
to mind and so I wanted to ask now
having had the benefit of hearing your
former colleagues going through
documents in preparation for your
evidence today whether there is anything
else that you would add to that
around recommendations going forward or
Lessons Learned in
Reflections on what you may have done
differently or what you would do
differently next time if if you were in
the same position what could you have
done differently as Chief of Police
I think I did provide some list of
recommendations for the commission to
consider in my statement uh
I trust that that will be followed up as
as the commissioner determines
I was about to say we have a board
liaison person because we talked about
the board quite a bit but John
steinbach's was the designated board
liaison person and had that position
before I even arise as Chief I'm just
thinking through sort of top down from
from board relationship
intersect was there there's a
recommendation around funding and
investing in intersect to create more
deconflict some of the problems we've
learned I I honestly this the list of
recommendations that I've provided are
the substantive
um reviews of what what needed to be in
a better level of to address the the
structural deficits that I've talked
about
um and I've tried to provide both
National well National provincial in
terms of police act legislation and
local in terms of the unique aspects of
the NCR region within my recommendations
I can't think of anything else at this
point so I understand kind of at a
systemic level but I'm asking more on a
personal level something you could have
done differently as Chief of Police
and if nothing comes to mind that's fine
that's the answer but um
I wanted to give you that I think the
broadest statement around
um
understanding
how to how to be able to be
able to be even more resilient during
that level of time in the I think
there's a whole new level of science
around sleep and and wellness that
probably executive leaders who face
these types of sustained levels of
Crisis and pressure just need to
understand how to develop a level of
physical and and emotional and
psychological resilience to get through
these things how do you I mean we talk
about Wellness for Frontline officers
and building resilience there it's I
think that would be probably just a
personal lesson learned there just never
is enough sleep I suspect people on this
commission are sleep deprived as well
and I'm not optimal in terms of what
they're doing
so I mean it's just a human condition I
don't know what you're talking about
I know from my legal team and I'm
looking at sleepy eyes all around me
um so I mean you I said it I think I
came up in a comment earlier on when I
was talking to chair Deans like
we're just human beings
and none of us are Superman or super
women and this was a super difficult
situation and
mistakes were made moments were lost
relationships were strained
meetings didn't go the way that they
were intended to
language was not precise enough
assumptions were made rumors were passed
around I just
Human Condition
systems are built by human beings
policies are designed by human beings
institutions
are just human institutions
and and
I said it before and standing committee
someone asked did the Ottawa Police
Service failed Canada was exposed
in these events our institutions were
exposed our systems were exposed and our
leaders were exposed and Frontline
members were exposed
probably worse overall our communities
were exposed
we just got to get it better the next
time
I'm fully committed to doing that that's
why I'm here
thank you and you mentioned your
recommendations to the commission I
understand you have spoken to some of
those but I wanted to give you the
opportunity to highlight some of the
other ones that perhaps we haven't had a
chance to get to if that's something you
would like to do
um I I think I'll leave it with the
commission to see those areas and I'll
make myself available commissioner to
you and your team at any point to expand
on that I think each one of my
recommendations could probably fill
another 20 Pages or so but I just think
for the time here I'll leave it there
and make myself available to you
thank you very much those are my
questions for you thank you
okay well we're finishing a little early
I'm not sure if we want to start
cross-examination but I promised we
wouldn't so I'm I'm going to uh adjourn
I just want to raise if there are if
there are any concerns of course uh
as was mentioned this has been a very uh
a very tight schedule a very a lot of
documents a lot of movement everybody in
my view has cooperated very well but if
there's anything that is of concern to
the commission please don't hesitate to
raise it either with commission Council
or directly with me because ultimately I
think we know it's been stressful but I
think we're doing a not bad job
certainly the
I'm very impressed with everyone's work
so far so thank you and
have a great weekend
the commissioners